GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. TODAY WE WILL
BE DISCUSSING THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. ALL
THE PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA OR
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY THERE WILL BE NO
VOTES IN TODAY'S HEARING AS
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TO DISCUSS THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS. WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
1-877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
ALL THE MEMBERS HAVE CONCLUDED
THEIR QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL I
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN FEEDBACK
THROUGH THE SUB ONE EMAIL
ACCOUNT. AND THE ADDRESS IS
BUDGET ONE AT ASM DOT CA DOC
OF. I'D LIKE TO START BY BEING
BOTH GRATEFUL AND APPRECIATIVE
TO THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THEY'VE MADE
INTO SUB ONE WHILE STILL
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WE HAVE MORE
WAYS TO GO TO TAKE CARE OF
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE.
I'D LIKE TO FOCUS MUCH OF OUR
HEARING TODAY ON THOSE WHO ARE
WITHIN CAL WORKS AND THEN R. D.
D. SYSTEM AS WELL AS THOSE WHO
NEED FURTHER PROTECTIONS FROM
OUR APIS AS WELL AS- THOSE WHO
ARE SUFFERING WITH FOOD. THIS
PANDEMIC. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR JOINING US TODAY.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH A PANEL ONE
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES MAY REVISE UPDATE. FOR
THOSE PANELISTS WERE PRESENTERS
PLEASE PRESENT IN THE ORDER
THAT YOUR NAME APPEARS ON THE
AGENDA. WE HAVE SIX PRESENTERS
ON THE PANEL TODAY INCLUDING
DIRECTOR KIM JOHNSON. CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR JENNIFER TROYA.
WITH THE OF SOCIAL SERVICES
RYAN ANDERSON ANGELES SHORT
JACQUI BRASFIELD AND LOTUS MODI
LESS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE WILL HOLD
ALL MEMBERS QUESTIONS ON THIS
PANEL UNTIL AFTER THE
PRESENTERS HAVE CONCLUDED. LET
US BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR JOHNSON.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING KIM JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES I'M GLAD TO
HIGHLIGHTS SEVERAL PROPOSALS
FROM GOVERNOR NUISANCE ONE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
CALIFORNIA COME BACK PLAN IN
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL WHICH PROPOSED
TO MAKE INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
DESIGNED TO COLLECTIVELY WORK.
TO DISRUPT POVERTY BY PROVIDING
HOUSING CASH ASSISTANCE. HEALTH
BENEFITSAND MORE THESE RESTORE
CALL MULTI GENERATIONAL
INVESTMENTS WILL HELP PROVIDE A
FOUNDATION TO ADVANCE THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS IMPROVE SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOCUSED ON
SUPPORTING BUT TO WITH THAT FOR
THOSE WHO NEED IT MOST. CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CHEN CHOI THAT
WILL BE OUTLINING THE- RELIEF
PREVENTION INCREASE AFTER
PROPOSALS I WILL FOCUS MY RE
THIS ON THE- DESIGNED TO
HOUSING AND HOME. SO HOW
HOMELESSNESS AND STRENGTHENING
INTEGRATION AFTER. IN THE
HOUSING AND HOME A OF OTHER WE
ARE SEEK TO WHICH- FUNCTIONAL
ZERO I'M VERY HOMELESS WITHIN.
YEARS THREE. THREE QUITE SEVEN
DOLLARS. UNCTION WITH ZERO
MEANS THAT. IS A- BRIEF AND NON
RIESCO. FOR SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE MAY
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED AND SO
THE DOLLARS IN BOTH YEAR TWENTY
ONE TO TWO AND TO TWENTY. AND
IN OF FOUR AND SEVEN FIVE
COMPARED TO THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FOR THE COWBOYS HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE HOUSING NEEDS OF
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND TO SUPPORT
THEM AND KEEP INFORMED HOUSING.
THE PROPOSED HOUSING SCORE
PROGRAM EXPANSION ALONE IS
PROJECTED TO SERVE OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND FAMILIES OVER A MULTI
YEAR FUNDING PLAN. NEW PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITIES INCLUDE A FOCUS
ON PREVENTION TO STEM INFLOW
INTO HOMELESSNESS. WE KNOW THAT
THE TWENTY TWENTY ALONE THERE
WERE OVER EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE IN
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN WHO
TOUCH THE HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM
AN ESTIMATED 85% OF FAMILIES TO
TOUCH THAT HOMELESS SYSTEM I
RECEIVE. OR RECEIVING CAO.
WORKS WE ARE ALL PROPOSING IN
THE MERRY BASS. TWO HUNDRED AND
MILLION DOLLAR FOR THE BROUGH
FAMILIES HOME PRO. INFO TWENTY
ONE TWO AND TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE DEGREES OVER YEARS THIS
PER IS IN TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF FAMILY IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO INCREASE FAMILY
REUNIFICATION. AND TO PREVENT
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENTS.
BRINGING FAMILIES CURRENTLY HAS
A TO ONE OR 1100% BACK. THE
PROPOSED X. HAVE A 20% LOCAL
ORDER ENSURE. IN TRIBES ARE TO
LOG AND- THIS PROGRAM THEIR
CURRENTLY TWENTY TWO BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME GRANTEES WE- THAT
WE CAN SERVE APPROXIMATELY
ELEVEN THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS WITH
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE. AND WE
ALSO KNOW FROM TWO THOUSAND TO
THAT OVER TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
AND THE COMPANY HE TOUCHED
HOMELESSNESS. AS WE SHIP TO SO
OUR- ARE ADULTS ELDERS AND
THOSE WITH THIS. REPOSITIONING
ONE HOW SO FIFTH FIVE IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO IS PART OF A ONE
TIME. MULTI YOUR FOR TO. THAT
AND DISABILITY ABBOTT GROUP.
THE FUNDS SUPPORT THE RIVER OF
OUR- CASE MAY. DISABILITY
ADVOCACY. AND HOUSING AND
SISTER TOWARD INDIVIDUAL IN
NEED. THIS PRO CURRENTLY HAS
ONE TO OR PER MATCH THE PURPOSE
EXPAND HAS A 25% LOOK MATCHING
TO GET. ENSURE COUNTY AND
TRIBES ABLE YOUR EX THE PRO.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY FIVE T.
INCLUDING TO TRY. FOR EXTRA WE
ASK THAT WE SERVE PARKS. A
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WITH THE-
INVESTMENT. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABLING
CONDITIONS IN OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY FIVE TOUCH THE
HOME SYSTEM. LAST YEAR. DIM
THIS SIGNIFICAN NEED. WE'VE
ALSO PROPOSED IN THE MAY. TO
FIVE THE HOME STATE PROGRAM
WITH ONE HUNDRED NO DOLLARS IN
TWENTY ONE TWO AND TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. DEFENSE
HOMELESSNESS IS AND- SERVICES
FOR OLDER AND THAT ADULT EXPIRY.
OR AT RISK.
OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT I'M SO. HOUSING
INCLUDING EXPANSION OF ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE MAYBE VISION.
AND NOTABLY THERE ARE HAVE BEEN
OVER THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS STARTED TO DATE
CURRENT LEADING NINE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HOTEL. AND
MOTEL ROOMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
FINALLY THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES FORTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FRIENDS. IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AGAIN THIS PROGRAM IS
PROPOSED TO PROVIDE ACQUISITION
CONSTRUCTION AND OR
REHABILITATION OF ADULTS SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES IN SUPPORT OF
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES THAT
ARE HOMELESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. THESE RESIDENTIAL
SETTINGS ARE CRITICAL PART OF
THE HOUSING CONTINUUM. FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING
INDIVIDUALS WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS WHO HAVE NO
ALTERNATIVES TO IT TO HOUSING.
AND TO MEET THEIR LEVEL OF CARE
IN THESE IN THESE SETTINGS.
KALYAN TRIBAL GRANTEES WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR REGULAR
REPORTING TO SOCIAL SERVICES
INCLUDING DATA ON THE
FACILITIES IN THE NUMBER OF
UNITS ACQUIRED OR
REHABILITATED. THE OWNERSHIP
STATUS OF THE FACILITIES THE
NUMBER OF SSI RECIPIENTS START
BUTTONS ALL THESE THEIR
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION AS WELL
AS THE SERVICES AND SUPPORT
PROVIDED IN THE FACILITY
SUPPORT HOUSING STABILITY AND
HEALTH OUTCOMES. YES THAT'S
WHAT HORSEMART LICENSING
FUNCTION MAINTAIN THE ROLE THAT
ROLE IN THESE FACILITIES.
FACILITIES THAT RECEIVE THIS
FUNDING WILL BE REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN COVENANTS TO CERTIFY
THEIR INTENDED USE RESIDENT
POPULATION AND THE LENGTH OF
THE CABINETS ASSOCIATE WITH THE
FACILITIES WILL BE CHEERED.
BASED ON THE LEVEL. OF FUNDING
AWARDED. FOR THIS PROJECT. WE
ESTIMATE EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EXPANSION AND TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PRESERVATION WHICH WOULD
PRODUCE AROUND FIVE THOUSAND
NEW BEDS AND PRESERVE OUR
APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND
BEDS. RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THERE
ARE APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SS I SS BE RECIPIENTS
IN ADULT AND SENIOR. BEDS IN
ACROSS OF THESE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
WE HAVE EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO WRAP
UP MORE QUICKLY- AND SUPPORT
ARE AT PROGRAM ADMINISTERS.
MINISTERS IN THIS EFFORT WE
PLAN TO PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- ACROSS
THE ENTIRETY OF INVESTMENTS. I
ALSO JUST WANTED TO NOTE- AND I
WAS HERE TO THE IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION PROPOSALS AND MAY
REVISION THERE ARE NUMBER AB
PROPOSALS FOCUSED ON SPECIFIC
POPULATE POPULATIONS INCLUDING
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AND USE.
OUR MIGRANT ARRIVALS ON THE
BORDER COMMUNITIES AND ALSO TO
SUPPORT A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME AVAILABLE OVER
THREE YEARS INVESTMENTS. I IN
SUPPORTING THOSE. INVOLVED IN
THE FINE FOR ARE SUBJECT TO THE
DOCKET STATUS IN CLIENTS
APPLYING FOR NATURALIZATION TO
BECOME A UNITED STATES CITIZEN
INCLUDING COVERAGE OF THE
FILING FEES. THE DEPARTMENT
WILL WORK WITH EXISTING
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE PROVEN TO
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DELIVER
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES. IN
AN EFFORT TO BALANCE EXPANDED
REACH AND ENSURING QUALITY
SERVICES FOR FIVE YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ADMINISTERED A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS EACH YEAR
THEN PROVIDED TECH OF CLOSE
DISTANCE TO MONITOR PERFORMANCE
OUT SELECTED. TO ENSURE THIS
NETWORK IS EXPANDING TO
ORGANIZATIONS WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY SERVICES
TO IMMIGRANTS. IN ADDITION THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PROVIDED
CAPACITY INVESTMENTS TO
ORGANIZATIONS TO EXPAND
CAPACITY SYSTEM SEPARATE
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS THE A. T.
I. COMMUNITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OR THE INLAND AND
RULE CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST
CENTRAL. VALLEY AND INLAND
EMPIRE. SO WITH THAT I'M GOING
TURN IT OVER TO CHI DEPUTY CHOI
SOME ADDITIONAL. INFORMATION OR
THE PROPOSEDINVEST FOR SOCIAL.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH
YOU TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
MAY REVISION. WHICH IS THE
DIRECTOR POINTED OUT- PRESENTS
A REALLY ONCE IN A. GENERATION
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
HEALTH. ECONOMIC AND RACIAL
INEQUITIES THAT WERE
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC. IN
KEEPING WITH THAT OPPORTUNITY
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
STRUCTURAL CHANGES TO OUR
SAFETY NET TO SUPPORT MANY
CALIFORNIANS ON THE PATH TO
DISRUPTING POVERTY AND MEETING
THEIR MOST BASIC NEEDS. THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
SUPPORTING ECONOMIC STABILITY
AND MOBILITY THAT INTEND TO
CREATE BOTH A MORE INCLUSIVE
SOCIETY AND A MORE RESILIENT
ECONOMY. I WILL FOCUS FIRST
WITH RESPECT TO THESE
INVESTMENTS ON ITEMS. THREE
TWELVE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY TWO ON YOUR AGENDA. I'M
BEGINNING WITH THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM AS THE CHAIR ALREADY
MENTIONED WHICH IS ONE OF THE
KEYS KEY PROGRAMS- FOR
DISRUPTING POVERTY AND
SUPPORTING FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- CAL WORKS PROGRAM IN
THE MAY REVISION IS PROPOSED TO
INCLUDE SIX POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. FISCAL YEAR.
THERE'S AN ANTICIPATED CASELOAD
FOR THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM IN
THE BUDGET YEAR OF THREE
HUNDRED OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND FAMILIES I WILL
NOTE THAT THIS IS LOWER THAN
WITH ESTIMATED IN JANUARY. IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET- DUE TO
UPDATES WITH ACTUAL DATA BUT IT
IS DOES STILL REFLECT AN
INCREASE DUE TO THE ASSUMPTION
THAT FEDERAL BENEFITS
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WILL
EXPIRE. THIS FALL. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO REFLECTS A GRANT
INCREASE FOR CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS A FIVE POINT 3% AS
OF OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. BASED ON FUNDING AT LOCAL
REALIGNMENT FUNDING. THIS
EQUATES TO- A GRANT OF NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A
MONTH FOR A FAMILY OF THREE AND
A HIGH COST COUNTY WHICH IS 51%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THE MAY REVISION ALSO INCLUDE
SOME INVESTMENTS FROM FEDERAL
FUNDING IN THE PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE FUND. THIS
FEDERAL FUNDING PROVIDES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME NON
RECURRING SHORT TERM BENEFIT
FOR ALL CAO WORKS RECIPIENT
FAMILIES WE EXPECT TO PROVIDE
AROUND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
DOLLARS FOR EACH FAMILY AS
EARLY AS THIS JULY. TO SUPPORT
THEIR- ABILITY TO PURCHASE
URGENT NECESSITIES. WITH
RESPECT TO CAO WORKS THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES SOME
OVERPAYMENT RELATED CHANGES THE
FIRST IS THE CHANGE TO HOW WE
COLLECT M. OR HOW WE ESTABLISH
OVERPAYMENT CLEANS. SO IF A
FAMILY HAS- RECEIVED MORE
ASSISTANCE THAN THEY WERE
ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE FOR. THIS
PROPOSAL LIMITS THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND COLLECTION OF
THOSE OVERPAYMENTS TO- TWO
YEARS BEFORE THE DATE THE
OVERPAYMENT WAS DISCOVERED THIS
POST BRINGS PARITY WITH THE
CALFRESH POLICIES AND A
GREATER- SENSE OF TIMELINESS IN
FAIRNESS TO THOSE ACTIONS. THE
SECOND IS OVER PAYMENT
COLLECTIONS RELIEF THIS RELIEF-
CLASSIFIEDS OVERPAYMENTS FROM
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH FROM APRIL
THROUGH JUNE. OR THE END OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY-
WHATEVER IS- SOONER AS
ADMINISTRATIVE ERRORS THE
DIFFERENCE THIS MAKES FOR A
FAMILY IS IN THE AMOUNT OF THE
RECOUPMENT THAT THAT WILL
HAPPEN- FROM THEIR GRANTS IT
WOULD BE SET AT 5% RATHER THAN
10% I'M ALSO WITH RESPECT TO
CAL WORKS THE MAY REVISION
REINVESTS IN INDIAN HEALTH
CLINICS AS AN IMPORTANT SOURCE
OF FUNDING FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
TEN OF PARTICIPANTS ARE CAL
WORKS PARTICIPANTS. FINALLY
WITH RESPECT TO CAO WORKS I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT ITEM THIRTEEN
IN YOUR AGENDA WHICH IS AB
RELATED TO SUPPORTING FAMILY
REUNIFICATION. THIS ITEM WOULD
PROVIDE SIX MONTHS OF
ADDITIONAL CASH AID AND
SERVICES FOR PARENTS WHOSE
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM
THE HOME BY THE CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES SYSTEM. CURRENTLY
THOSE PARENTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
SOME CONTINUED SERVICES BUT
THEY'RE CASH ASSISTANCE STOPS
WHEN THE CHILD IS REMOVED AND
THEY'RE OFTEN DESTABILIZED. IN
ADDITION TO CAO WORKS WITH
RESPECT TO THE SAFETY NET THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDE SOME KEY
INVESTMENTS IN A GUARANTEED
INCOME PILOT PROGRAM AND IN THE
GRANTS FOR THE SSI S. S. P.
PROGRAM. WITH RESPECT TO THE
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT
PROGRAM. THE IDEA IS TO INVEST
IN A NUMBER OF PILOTS ACROSS
THE STATE AND- IN RECOGNITION
OF THE INCREASING BY
LOCALS IN INVESTING IN THIS
AREA THIS WILL EXPAND THE
EXISTING PILOTS AND WILL ALSO
SUPPORTER OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH AND EVALUATION
OF THIS CONCEPT. THE INTENT IS
TO SUPPORT A PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP WHERE THIS STATE
INVESTS TO INCREASE THE POOL OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT
THE PILOTS. COUNTIES NONPROFITS
AND PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS
WOULD WORK TOGETHER TO DEVELOP
THE PILOTS THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION
AND WHILE SOME DETAILS WOULD BE
PROVIDED IN ADVANCE IN THE
LANGUAGE PROPOSED FOR THIS
ITEM. MANY ADDITIONAL DETAILS
WOULD BE SPECIFIED IN THE RFP
PROCESS AS WE WORK TO IDENTIFY
THE INDIVIDUAL GRANTEES. WITH
RESPECT TO THE S. S. P. PORTION
OF THE SSI S. S. P. GRANTS FOR
OUR ELDERS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. THE BUDGET THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDES SIXTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
BEGINNING JANUARY. ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO INCREASE BY
AROUND 6% THE S. S. P. PORTION
OF GRANTS. THIS INCREASE COMES
IN ADDITION TO A FEDERAL SSI
COLA THAT WILL BE PROVIDED. IT
IS FOCUSED ON INDIVIDUAL
RECIPIENTS I'M AND YOUR- AGENDA
ASKS A QUESTION ABOUT ITS-
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A
COLA AND ALSO AND ALSO SOME
QUESTIONS HAVE COME UP RELATED
TO THE CONNECTION TO TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. I'M THIS IS A
GRANT INCREASE THIS IS NOT
SPECIFICALLY A COLON. WITH
RESPECT. TO TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION AT THE TIME WHICH WAS
FOCUSED ON INDIVIDUAL GRANTEES
AND THAT IS THE PART OF THE
REASON FOR THE FOCUS HERE ON
INDIVIDUAL GRANTEES. IN
ADDITION THE INDIVIDUAL
GRANTEES IN THE S. S. I. S. S.
P. PROGRAM THEIR GRANTS WITH
RESPECT TO THE COMPARISON TO
THE POVERTY LEVEL DO NOT COVER
AS MUCH AS THE GRANTS THAT ARE
GRANTED TO COUPLES AT THIS TIME.
B. S. S. P. PORTION OF THE
GRANT IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL
BE THE SAME DOLLAR AMOUNT AS
THE S.S. P. GRANT AMOUNT WIVES
IN IN TWENTY ELEVEN. SO AT THIS
POINT I'M GOING TO SHIFT AND
TALK SOME IN MY REMARKS ABOUT-
INVESTMENTS IN THE MAY REVISION
RELATED TO OLDER CALIFORNIANS
IN ADDITION TO SSI SST. IN
PARTICULAR THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS THAT RELATE TO OUR IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES OR I
H. I. S. PROGRAM. THE IHS US
PROGRAM PROVIDES CRITICAL
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES TO ALLOW
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
TO REMAIN SAFELY IN THEIR HOMES
WITH THE ASSISTANCE THAT THEY
NEED. THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
TO ELIMINATE THE 7% REDUCTION
IN HOURS OF SERVICES IN THE OUT
YEARS WITH RESPECT TO THIS
PROGRAM A CHANGE THAT WE KNOW-
YOU HAVE HEARD A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
PAST. IN MAY REVISION ALSO
PROPOSES A PERMANENT BACKUP
PROVIDER SYSTEM TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE WITH THE
HIGHEST NEEDS- AND THOSE WHO
ARE SEVERELY IMPAIRED. THIS
BACKUP SYSTEM IS FOCUSED ON
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE IS AN
IMMEDIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
RISK TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
NEED OF A REPLACEMENT OR BACKUP
CARE GIVER. THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES A WAGE DIFFERENTIAL TO
SUPPORT THE PROVISION OF THOSE
BACKUP SERVICES- AND ALSO-
INCLUDES A AN UPDATE TO THE
MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE CONTRACT RATE
HE'D FOR COUNTY CONTRACT MODE
SERVICES. AS SOMETIMES
SHORTENED TO BE CALLED THE
MASSACRE. ALSO WITH RESPECT TO
THE I HSS PROGRAM THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- WITH RESPECT TO EVD
OR ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION- THE EBV
REQUIREMENTS ARE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT CALIFORNIA
MUST COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
AB HAS A HAS NOTIFIED
CALIFORNIA THAT WE WILL NEED TO
COMPLY BY VERIFYING A PROVIDERS
LOCATION FROM THE BEGINNING TO
END OF SERVICE PROVISION. OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM DOES NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO IDENTIFY THIS IN
TIME SERVICE DELIVERY LOCATION
AND THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT IS PROPOSED- CLARIFIES HOW
WE WILL COLLABORATE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
CMS REQUIREMENTS IN THE LEAST
INTRUSIVE MANNER THAT IS
POSSIBLE TO ADD CAPTURE AND
IDENTIFY THIS. LOCATION THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES EIGHT
AND INVESTMENT IN CAREER
PATHWAYS- AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROVIDERS.
THIS IS A PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORT TO
SUPPORT THE CARE ECONOMY THESE
FINES WILL INCENTIVIZE SUPPORTS.
YOUR PATHWAYS FOR HSS PROVIDERS
IT WILL ASSIST THE PROVIDERS IN
GAINING SKILLS TO OBTAIN
EMPLOYMENT EITHER AS A NIGHT
JUST LAST PROVIDER OR TO
COMPETE FOR A HIGHER LEVEL JOB
IN THE HOME CARE AND HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRIES. OPPOSE ALL IN
GENERAL FOCUSES ON PAID
STIPENDS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. REMOTE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL HELP TO
PREPARE THE WORK FORCE TO
ADDRESS ANY LANGUAGE BARRIERS
OR HELP WITH THINGS LIKE WORK
READY NEXT OR THE TRANSITION
INTO OTHER EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS. WE HAVE HAD
SUCCESS DURING THE PANDEMIC
WITH REMOTE LEARNING IN OUR CAL
WORKS PROGRAM AND INTEND TO
BUILD OFF OF THAT SUCCESS HERE.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO SUPPORT
ACCESS TO IN PERSON TRAINING
OPTIONS THAT SUPPORT THE REMOTE
LEARNING THINGS LIKE ADULT
EDUCATION OR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE PROPOSAL CAN ALSO
SUPPORT CAREER COUNSELING AND
NAVIGATION OR APPRENTICESHIP OR
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PREPARATION
IN THE HEALTHCARE FIELD. WHAT
WE ANTICIPATE IS EARLY
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS IN BED
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BUDGET YEAR. WITHIN
EXPANSION STATEWIDE IN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. FINALLY I WILL
EMPHASIZE SOME KEY INVESTMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO THE SAFETY AND
WELL BEING OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
AND THOSE WHO ARE AT RISK OF
ABUSE OR NEGLECT. THE FIRST IS
WITH RESPECT TO THE FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES ACT
OR F. S. PSA. AND OTHER
PREVENTION FUNDING. FF'S PSA IS
A RECENT FEDERAL LAW THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY REFORMS THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND ITS
FINANCING PART ONE OF THE NEW
FF PSA LAW AUTHORIZES SOME NEW
OPTIONAL FUNDING UNDER TITLE
FOR EACH OF THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ACT SO SOME NEW FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION. FOR
TIME LIMITED EVIDENCE BASED
PREVENTION SERVICES TO CHILDREN
OR YOUTH WHO ARE CANDIDATES FOR
FOSTER CARE. PART FOUR OF THE
NEW FF PSA LAW CREATES A NUMBER
OF NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR STATES
TO FOLLOW AND PLACES
LIMITATIONS ON THE USE OF
CONGREGATE CARE. IN JANUARY WE
PROPOSE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
FFP SA REQUIREMENTS- IN THE
STATE AT THERE ARE SOME CHANGES
COMING BASED ON STAKEHOLDER
COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO THE FF
PSA TRAILER BILL BE PROPOSED
EARLIER. COMMENTS RELATED TO
THINGS LIKE THE- USE OF THE
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL AND THE
STRUCTURE OF OUR- ACCESS TO
NURSING SERVICES WE ANTICIPATE
THAT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
BEING THE UPDATES TO THAT
CHANGE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
BEING MADE AVAILABLE THIS WEEK
POTENTIALLY EVEN AS SOON AS
TODAY. THE MAY REVISION DOES
ALSO OFFER AN INVESTMENT INTO
THE PREVENTION SIDE OF FF PSA
AND- ALLOCATE SOME OF THE
FUNDING THAT IS ADDITIONALLY
AVAILABLE UNDER SOME OTHER
FEDERAL PROGRAMS FOR PREVENTION
SERVICES. I'M UNDER DE UM ARPA
PROVISIONS THE STATE IS
RECEIVING AROUND AN ADDITIONAL
FORTY NINE MILLION ENHANCE
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR PREVENTION
PURPOSES THAT I'M REFERRING TO.
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL IS A
BLOCK GRANTS OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD IT INCLUDES AROUND A
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE MILLION
TOTAL FUND. A BLOCK GRANT WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES THAT
OPT IN TO PART ONE OF FF'S PSA
AND DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE
PREVENTION. PLANS THAT ARE
APPROVED BY. HOW COUNTY'S
INTEND TO EXPAND THE A PORTION
OF THE ART BUT FUNDING THAT I
MENTIONED WITH RESPECT TO
PRIMARY PREVENTION STRATEGIES
THE REMAINING ARPA FUNDING WILL
BE AVAILABLE MORE BROADLY FOR
OTHER STEEP RIGHT PURPOSES.
WITH RESPECT TO CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE I ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WITHIN THE
MAY REVISION A PROPOSAL THAT IS
INTENDED TO ASSIST IN MEETING
THE NEEDS OF YOUTH WITH COMPLEX
CARE NEEDS. INCLUDING THOSE WHO
RECENTLY RETURNED FROM OUT OF
STATE CONGREGATE CARE
PLACEMENTS. THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES- INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
BOTH ONE TIME AND ONGOING TO
ASSIST IN MEETING THE NEEDS OF
USED IN CALIFORNIA B. ONE TIME
INVESTMENT IS TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT AND EXPANSION OF
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS TO MEET
THE ACUTE AND COMPLEX NEEDS OF
THESE YOUTH. AN EXAMPLE WOULD
BE TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL USES
OF THE S. T. R. T. P. OF ONE OR
THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE MODELS.
THE MAY REVISION ADDITIONALLY
PROVIDES AS I MENTIONED ONGOING
INVESTMENT THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE INTENDED TO SUPPLEMENT. THE
ASSESSMENTS EVALUATIONS CARE
PLANNING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AN EXCEPTIONAL SUPPORTS
AVAILABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH THE
MOST COMPLEX SET OF NEEDS IN
FOSTER CARE IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS ALSO SOME DEDICATED
FUNDING FOR TRIBAL ENGAGEMENT
WITH RESPECT TO MEETING THESE
NEEDS AND THERE WILL BE A
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK GUIDED
BY OUR STATE IT OUR SYSTEM OF
CARE STATE TEAMS TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH RESPECT TO
THIS INVESTMENT OF FUNDS. AT
YOUR AGENDA ASKS THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER OR NOT THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDED A PROPOSAL
FOR A MORATORIUM ON OUT OF
STATE PLACEMENTS AT THAT IS NOT
BEING PROPOSED AT THIS TIME
ALTHOUGH WE DO CERTAINLY INTEND
FOR THESE INVESTMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF YOUTH WITH
IN CALIFORNIA. WITH RESPECT TO
THE RECONCILIATION OF THAT-
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM OR C.
C. R. PROPOSAL- EVERY YEAR THE-
ASSISTANCE IN ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS IN SAVINGS WITH RESPECT
TO C. C. R. ARE REQUIRED TO BE
RECONCILED THIS IS OFTEN CALLED
THE TRUE UP OR C. C. R.
RECONCILIATION. BEDS THIS
SAVINGS FROM ANY ASSISTANCE
COSTS ARE USED TO COVER ANY
OVERAGES IN ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. AND C. C. R.
RECONCILIATION DETERMINES THE
AMOUNT. IF ANY OF ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDS. STATE FUNDS THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO BE PROVIDED TO
YOU- COUNTIES. I'M THERE ARE IS
SOME FUNDING ALREADY INCLUDED
IN THE MAY REVISION AB WITH
RESPECT TO SOME C. C. R.
ACTIVITIES YOUR AGENDA ALSO
ASKS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THERE
IS ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
NEEDED WITH RESPECT TO RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL OR OTHER COSTS.
ADDI ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
CONSIDER THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL- PROGRAM MANY OF THOSE
COSTS TO BE PART OF CCR
RECONCILIATION AS THE RFA
PROGRAM WAS REAL LINES PRIOR TO
C. C. R. AND I WILL DEFER TO MY
FINANCE COLLEAGUES IF YOU HAVE
ANY MORE DETAILED QUESTIONS
ABOUT M. DOT SET OF
CALCULATIONS. THE FINAL THING I
WILL HIGHLIGHT WITH RESPECT TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE- IS THE RESTORATION OF A
NUMBER OF REDUCTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUSPENDED IN RECENT YEARS
BOTH WITH RESPECT TO THE- LA
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
PILOT PROGRAM. THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM AND THE
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY RATES THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE THOSE REDUCTIONS SO
THEY WILL NO LONGER NEED TO BE
SUSPENDED IN THE OUT YEARS- AND
WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS I BELIEVE YOU WILL BE
HEARING NEXT FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN WE
PLEASE BEGIN WITH RYAN ANDERSON.
GOOD MORNING RYAN ANDERSON OF
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. ALL RIGHT A FEW OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
BRIEFLY SO JUST TO SET UP ALL
OF OUR REMARKS- FIRST TO TELL
YOU THAT OF COURSE WE'RE IN THE
VERY EARLY STAGES OF REVIEWING
THESE MEN ARE VISUAL PROPOSALS.
AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE THAT
WORK AND PUBLISH OUR FINDINGS
AND SEND EMAILS AND OTHERWISE
LET Y'ALL KNOW AND- SORT
COMMENTS TODAY WILL JUST FOCUS
ON OUR INITIAL POTS SOME OF THE
KEY PROPOSALS THAT WERE
PRESENTED IN MINISTRATION. A
SECOND GENERAL NOW IS THAT WE
WERE. ASKED BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
IS COOLEY TO HIRE YOUR- FOR
LEGISLATIVE AND- OR- IN WHICH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
MAY NOT FULLY ALIGNED. WITH
PREVIOUSLY STATED LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. I WITH THAT IN
MIND- MY COMMENTS ARE GOING TO
BE FOCUSED ON CAL WORKS- AND
FIRST ONE CALVERTS CASE THOUGH.
COURSE WE'RE IN THE OF
REVIEWING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CASELOAD ESTIMATES ACROSS THE
S. ANCE BUT I KNOW THAT. OUR
EXCUSE LOGIN PARTICULARS IN AN
INTEREST OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
SINCE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN OUR
OFFICE HAS BEEN PRODUCING MUCH
LOWER FORECAST FOR THIS PROGRAM
AND ADMINISTRATION- OVER THE
MAY REVISION INCLUDE SOME LARGE
DOWNWARD REVISIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES AND-
UPON INITIAL REVIEW THEY APPEAR
REASONABLE. STOPIT MORE
CONSERVATIVE THAN OUR OFFICES
BUT THEY'RE IN THE SAME
BALLPARK- ALSO EDIT HEARING TO
SKIP SUBCOMMITTEE EXPRESSED A
PARTICULAR INTEREST. IN
REVIEWING OPTIONS TO
POTENTIALLY REVERSE THE
PRECIPITOUS DECLINE IN COMMERCE
IS THE THAT WE'VE SEEN SINCE
LAST SPRING. AND ON INITIAL
REVIEW OF THE MAY REVISION WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED TWO POLICIES
THAT HAVE SOME POTENTIAL TO
INCREASE BY COWARDS IS THE-
ALTHOUGH WE THINK IN BOTH CASES
THAT POTENTIAL CASE THAT IMPACT
APPEARS QUITE MODEST. THE FIRST
IS THE FIVE POINT 3% GRANT
INCREASE THAT IS PAID FOR BY
REALIGNMENT REVENUE WELL WE
ROUGHLY ESTIMATE THIS COULD
INCREASE KESSLER WELL MAYBE A
FEW THOUSAND CASES GENERALLY
OKAY SO DOES SEEM TO INCREASE
AS THE BENEFITS OF THE PROGRAM
INCREASE. THE INCREASE WOULD
STILL FAR SHORT OF THE WHICH
STATED AND- HISTORY GRANT 250%
FAVORABLE FEDERAL POVERTY. FOR
A FAMILY THAT'S ONE PERSON
LARGER THAN THE CAL WORKS
ASSISTANCE YOU. THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO PROPOSES
THIS IS SECOND PROPOSAL HAS
SOME POTENTIAL CASE OF IMPACT.
DO YOU SOME FEDERAL FUNDING TO
CENTER SIX HUNDRED FORTY DOLLAR
ONE TIME PAYMENT ALL CAL WORKS
FAMILIES IN JULY. THIS BILLS
OFTEN EARLIER SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR ONE TIME PAYMENT OF SENT
TO THE SAME FAMILIES LAST
SPRING. WELL AS CONSTRUCTIVE
THIS WOULD OF COURSE PROVIDE
SOME BENEFITS OF FAMILIES WHO
ARE ALREADY ENROLLED IN CAL
WORKS BUT WE THINK IT'S
UNLIKELY. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
HAVE ANY NOTICEABLE IMPACTS ON
CASE THOUGH HOWEVER WE DO THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS SOME
OPPORTUNITY HERE SO LEVERAGE
THIS. FOR ITSBROADER CASELOAD
GOALS OF FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO. CHOOSE TO
DELAY THIS PAYMENT BY A MONTH
OR TWO AND COMBINE THAT WITH-
IN APPROPRIATION OF. SAY A FEW
MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS A STATE
WIDE MOTIONAL CAMPAIGN SAYING
THAT THESE BENEFITS WILL BE
AVAILABLE IF YOU ENROLL IN THIS
PROGRAM THAT THAT MIGHT
ENCOURAGE MORE FAMILIES
STRUGGLE- THOSE ARE OUR INITIAL
COMMENTS ON CAL WORKS WITH
THAT'LL BE. HANDING IT OVER. TO
MY COLLEAGUE ANSHEL SHORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD CHEN MEMBERS
ANGELES SHORT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUE- WE WILL BE PROVIDING
MORE DETAILED COMMENTS IN THE
COMING DAYS AS WE'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VIEW MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT- BUT THERE ARE
REALLY TWO KEY POINTS WHO
WANTED TO RAISE THE
LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION TODAY.
REGARDING THE ADMINISTRATION
MAY REVISION PRO PROPOSALS
WITHIN CHILD WELFARE. FIRST OF
THE MAJOR VERSION PROPOSES A
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION. OF ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. TO BE
SPENT OVER THREE YEARS TO
ASSIST COUNTIES WITH DEVELOPING
PREVENTION SERVICES IN LINE
WITH. F. P. AS A PART ONE-
WHICH YOU HEARD- DIRECTOR
TRYING TO EXPLAIN. AND THE TIME
THE JANUARY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
NOTE STATE INVESTMENT HAD BEEN
PROPOSED FOR THIS PURPOSE. AND
WE HAD FLAG THIS AS A KEY AREA
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR COUNTIES.
IN ORDER TO HELP ENSURE THAT
ALL ELIGIBLE FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN WOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS PREVENTION SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE- WELL WE HAVE
NOT YET SEEN THE DETAILS OF
THIS NEAR VISION PROPOSAL IT
DOES SEEM. ODD THAT THIS MAKES
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS TOWARD
THIS RECOMMENDATION. AND SECOND
THERE MAY REVISION CONTINUES
SOME SIGNIFICANT AUGMENTATION
RELATED TO PANDEMIC RESPONSE
WITHIN CHILD WELFARE- THESE
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR SUCH THINGS
AS FLEXIBILITY IS AN EXPANSION
FOR NON MINOR DEPENDENTS AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. AS WELL AS
SUPPORT FOR FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS- TECHNOLOGY AND HOTLINE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH. AND FAMILIES.
ONE NO WE WOULD MAKE IS THAT-
EIGHT GAP REMAINS IN TERMS OF A
LACK OF FUNDING FOR ALL
RESOURCE FAMILIES AS WELL AS
FOR A SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM FOR S. T.
R. T. P. PROVIDERS. AND AS WE
RAISED AT THE TIME OF THE
JANUARY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OVER
THE COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC
YOU'VE CARE GIVERS HAVE BEEN
FACING INCREASED COST PRESSURES
SUCH AS FOR FOOD. AND HAVE ALSO
BEEN NAVIGATING THE VARIOUS
CHALLENGES OF STAY AT HOME
ORDERS NOW WITH THE YOUTH IN
THEIR CARE FOR EXAMPLE
CHALLENGES AROUND VIRTUAL
LEARNING. AND LACK OF ACCESS TO
CHILD CARE. THEREFORE WE
CONTINUE TO FLAG FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- THAT IT MAY WISH
TO PROVIDE STIPENDS OR SOME
OTHER DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO ALL
FOSTER CARE PROVIDERS AS PART
OF THE STATE'S OVERALL
CORPORATE NINETEEN FISCAL
RELIEF EFFORTS WITHIN CHILD
WELFARE AND FOSTER CARE. AND
WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE JACKI BRAZIL
FOR COMMENT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S I H. S. S. AND
AT THE SITE AT THE P. PROPOSAL.
JACKIE BRINGS YOU WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE. MY
COMMENTS WILL BE FOCUSED ON
HIGHLIGHTING SPECIFIC AGING
PROPOSALS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES THAT IS.
THAT ONE RAISE ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION OR
MAY NOT FULLY ALIGNED WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. A ONE
EXAMPLE THAT I'D LIKE TO START
WITH IS ISSUE NUMBER THREE IN
THE AGENDA OF THE S. P. GREAT
INCREASE PROPOSAL. FOR
ADDITIONAL CONTACTS BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. S. S. P. RECIPIENTS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF GREAT
REDUCTIONS RESULTING IN A
STEADY DECLINE OF THE GRANT
AMOUNTS. TO THE POINT THAT THE
GRADES REACHED A FEDERALLY
ALLOWABLE MINIMUM. LEVELS BY
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. SAN THEN
THE STATE. A SLOW AS AS P.
GREAT IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
ADDITIONALLY AS A PART OF THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
INTENT LANGUAGE TO ONCE AGAIN
PROVIDE ESSES P. GRANT- COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS BEGINNING IN TWO
THOUSAND. AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR. THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING ALSO
SUCKS OF GOAL OF BRINGING AS A
SCIENCE IS P. GRANTS UP TO THE
ELDER ECONOMIC INDEX AND
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. TO THE
EXTENT THAT FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE. NOW CURRENTLY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS EFFECTIVELY
PROPOSING TO INCREASE S. S. P.
GRANT LEVELS FOR INDIVIDUALS
ONLY BY ABOUT TEN DOLLARS. WELL
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
GREAT INCREASE IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION IT ALTERNATELY
DOES NOT PROVIDE THOSE FUTURE
COLAS I'M PER LEGISLATIVE
INTENT LANGUAGE OR INCREASE
GRANTS TO THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL AS MENTIONED IN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE THE PROPOSED
INCREASE RETURNS GRANTS TO TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN LET THE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN LEVELS MOST OF
THE PRIOR REDUCTIONS ARE NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR ESPECIALLY FOR
COUPLES. AND BASED ON OUR ROUGH
CALCULATION INDIVIDUALS ARE
STILL AT A LOWER LEVEL RELATIVE
TO THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE AND
THEY WERE IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. AGAIN WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL GREAT
INCREASE IS A MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I WITH REGARD TO
THOSE BROADER GOALS OF
INCREASING THE S. S. P. GRANTS
THE LEGISLATURE COULD PICK A
DIFFERENT GRANT GRANT BENCHMARK
IF IT WANTED TO RESTORE LET'S
SAY A GREATER SHARE OF THE PAST
JUSTICE P. REDUCTIONS OR GET
INDIVIDUALS CLOSER TO THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. AND A
BROADER POINT THAT WE'D LIKE TO
REDUCE FOR THE LEGISLATURE IS
THAT IF WE LOOK AT THE BUDGET
IN ITS TOTALITY WELL THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DIRECTING
RESOURCES TO PROP UP NEW SOCIAL
SERVICES INTERVENTIONS- WE
DON'T NECESSARILY SEE THAT SAME
LEVEL OF AUGMENTATION. AND THE
MAJORITY OF THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS LIKE ISIS ISIS P.
GRAMS. THE LAST ISSUE BUT I
WILL TO COMMON ON IS THIS
NUMBER TWO. THE LONG TERM CARE
PATHWAYS PROPOSAL. JUST TO
RAISE POSSIBILITIES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION AND
AGAIN FOR CONTACT THE CONCEPT
ITSELF OF PROVIDING TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL AGES AS
PROVIDERS. HAS BEEN RAISED-
DURING THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND
WAS BROADLY MENTIONED WITHIN
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING OUT
RESULTING ONLY ADOPTED. AND
THIS MAY BE DUE IN PART BECAUSE
I JUST I JUST AS PROVIDERS AND
TO THE PROGRAM. PERHAPS NOT
NECESSARILY WITH THE INTENTION
OF MAKING A CAREER OUT OF IT
BUT REALLY TO CARE FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER OR FRIEND. HOWEVER THE
TYPE OF SERVICES THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDING ARE VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT- A PRIVATE HOME HEALTH
AIDE PROVIDES SO THEN THE
QUESTION IS RAISED AS TO
WHETHER IT. PERHAPS A MORE
TAILORED PROGRAMMING YOUR
OUTREACH APPROACH IS NEEDED TO
MAKE THOSE LINKAGES BETWEEN THE
WORK THAT I JUST AS PROVIDERS
ARE DOING AND CONNECTING THEM
TO EXISTING HEALTH CARE PATHWAY
PROGRAMS. SO WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL MAY
TRY. TO GET INTO THIS BROADER
CONCEPT AT THIS TIME WE DON'T
HAVE THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
TO REALLY ASSESS THE MERITS OF
THE PROPOSAL. AND WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS THAT A ONE WE DON'T
KNOW HOW THE ADMINISTRATION
CAME UP WITH THATTWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BAKER WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE A FIRM GRASP
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE- WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY I JUST AS
PROVIDERS WILL ULTIMATELY BE
SERVED. BUT THEN ALSO WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT PROBLEM OR UNMET NEED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS AND HOW IT
SUCCESS WILL BE MEASURED. AND
WE DON'T KNOW NECESSARILY THE
MIX OF TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
ARE THOSE THE MOST INFECTIVE OR
IMPACTFUL- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ACCESS PROVIDERS- AND TO WHAT
EXTENT WILL THE DEPARTMENT
LEVERAGE EXISTING. AND PROVEN
HOME HEALTH TRAINING PROGRAMS
IT THROUGH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS- IN
THIS ENDEAVOR. AND AGAIN WE
WILL STE- WE'RE STILL BE STAGE
OF IT AND- TO MAKE. PROPOSAL
AND ILL CONTINUE TO WITH THE
MISTER TO ADDITIONAL DE.
HOWEVER IF THE NAY. LEVEL OF
DEEP CANNOT BE PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITHIN THE SHORT
BUDGET TIME FRAME- BUT THE
LEGISLATURE ITSELF IS STILL
INTERESTED IN DOING SOMETHING
IN THIS SPACE. WE CAN HELP THE
LEGISLATURE THINK THROUGH
PERHAPS ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES
THAT ARE MORE DEFINED IN
ACTIONABLE WITHIN THE SHORT
TIME FRAME WHICH MAY NOT
NECESSARILY REQUIRE AS MUCH
FUNDING TO BEGIN WITH. BUT CAN
AT LEAST BE BUILT UPON PERHAPS
NEXT YEAR IN FUTURE YEARS AS
THE ADMINISTRATION SOLIDIFIED
THE MORE DEFINED LONG TERM
STRATEGY- WITH THAT I'LL NOW
PASS IT ON TO MY COLLEAGUES
LEARN THIS. WHO I WILL END WITH
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
COMMENTS. GOOD MORNING I'M AS
WELL AS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND I WILL
PROVIDE COMMENTS RELATED TO THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSALS. THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION CONTINUES TO RECOGNIZE
THE STATE'S HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY READY AND
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES.
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN A PRIORITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AND ARE WORTHWHILE GOALS. THE
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PLAN WILL BE
DISCUSSED AT THE ASSEMBLY STEP
FOR HEARING TOMORROW. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS
THAT YOU HAVE HEARD ABOUT FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION TODAY OUR A
PIECE OF THIS LARGER MULTI
DEPARTMENTAL PROPOSAL. WELL KEY
QUESTION WE HAVE A SPECIFIC TO
THE PROPOSALS AND DSF IS HOW
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS AND
FUNDING INCREASES WORK WITH THE
OTHER COMPONENTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN. TO ACHIEVE THE
STATED GOAL OF ELIMINATING
HOMELESSNESS FOR FAMILIES
WITHIN FIVE YEARS. WELL THE
REVISION PROPOSES TO EXPAND A
JANUARY PROPOSAL FOR A NEW
PROGRAM TO ACQUIRE AND RENOVATE
COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES. MOST
PROPOSAL SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND
EXISTING DSS PROGRAMS. THE
PROPOSED AUGMENTATIONS
REPRESENT VERY LARGE INCREASES
TO THE BASELINE FUNDING FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE TYPICALLY SPENDS NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
ON THE CAL WORKS HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. FOR EACH
OF THE NEXT TWO YEARS IT IS NOT
CLEAR WHAT ASSESSMENT WAS DONE
TO DETERMINE THIS LEVEL OF
ESTIMATED NEED FOR EACH OF
THESE PROPOSALS. A KEY QUESTION
WILL BE WHETHER THE PROGRAM
WILL HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
ADMINISTER AND SPENT THIS NEW
FUNDING WITHIN PROPOSED
TIMELINES. WOULD IT BE BETTER
PERHAPS TO PROVIDE SMALLER
AMOUNTS OVER MORE YEARS. WE
UNDERSTAND THE ADMINISTRATION
ANTICIPATES INTRODUCING TBL FOR
SOME OF THESE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS WHICH
COULD MAKE MODIFICATIONS TO
HAVE SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS
OPERATE. FOR EXAMPLE THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD ADDRESS
SOME KNOWN BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING THESE PROGRAMS WHICH
COULD ENHANCE THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO SPEND A PROPOSED
CONSULTATIONS. HOWEVER THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THIS
PROPOSAL IS NOT YET AVAILABLE.
IN THE CASE OF THE COMMUNITY
CARE EXPANSION PROPOSAL THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
SIGNIFICANT AUGMENTATION AND IT
IS UNCLEAR IF TV ALL OF THE
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
ON THE ISSUE. THIS CREATES
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
HOW THE PROPOSAL WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED AND HOW THE
LEGISLATURE WILL OVERSEE THE
PROGRAM. THESE ARE JUST SOME OF
THE OTHER VERY INITIAL THOUGHTS
AND QUESTIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
REFINE OUR THOUGHTS AS MORE
DETAILS BECOME AVAILABLE ON THE
PROPOSALS. THAT I THINK YOU AND
I CONCLUDE THE ELLIOTT'S
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO THIS PANEL I WILL NOW BRING
IT BACK UP TO THE DYESS- BEFORE
I BEGIN WITH MEMBERS QUESTIONS
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT. SINCE WE
HAVE LIMITED TIME AND TODAY'S
HEARING AND WE DIDN'T GET TO
ALL OF THE QUESTIONS WITHIN THE
AGENDA. I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR MY
STAFF TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR RESPONSES TO
COME BACK AND WRITING. AFTER
THIS HEARING. WITH THAT WILL
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR WHAT. THANK
YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
OUR WITNESSES- I SIT HERE AND
KIND OF REFLECT. A LITTLE BIT.
THERE ARE SOME VERY I THINK
VERY WORTHY PROGRAMS THAT ARE
THERE GOING TO BE FUNDED AT A
GREATER LEVELS AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I'M SPECIFICALLY GONNA
SPEAK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING. AND I HEARD LORD LOTUS
YOU TALKED ABOUT- THAT MORE
DETAIL COME AND BUDGET SUB FOR.
THAT'S GOING TO COME OUT- YOU
TALKED ABOUT A MULTI
DEPARTMENTAL PLAN- I GUESS WHAT
I LOOK AT THIS AND I THINK OF
ALL THE MONEY WE HAVE SPENT AND
WILL SPEND ON HOMELESSNESS AND-
I WENT I HAVE SOME. SOME
QUESTIONS AROUND THAT. IN THE
END. WHO IF ANYONE WILL
COORDINATE ALL OF THESE EFFORTS
SO THAT THERE IS YOU KNOW SOME
SOMEBODY'S WHO COORDINATE ALL
THESE EFFORTS- AND- IT AND YOU
MAY NOT HAVE THE ANSWERS AND SO
I DON'T I REALLY DON'T EXPECT
YOU TO- BUT I'M JUST THROWING
THIS OUT FOR THOUGHT- HOW ARE
WE MEASURING OUTCOMES WITH. ALL
THESE DIFFERENT RESOURCES GOING
TO ALL THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
HOW ARE WE MEASURING WHAT THE
OUTCOMES ARE FOR THE OVERALL
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE- DO WE HAVE
STATISTICS- THE- FOR THE
CATEGORIES OF HOMELESSNESS YOU
KNOW WHO IS HOMELESS WHY
THEY'RE HOMELESS. AND ALL THE
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS IN FOR
EXAMPLE I THINK OF. MENTAL
HEALTH AND- AND- SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDER AS AS
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS FOR SUN
SAID WE HAVE A BIG BREAK DOWN
OKAY. THESE ARE ALL THE THESE
ARE ALL THE HOMELESS PEOPLE
THESE ARE ALL THE CATEGORIES IS
ROB CONTRIBUTING FACTORS. IF WE
DO. HOW ARE WE COORDINATING ALL
OF THAT BECAUSE- A LOT OF THE
WHAT I WILL CALL TE REAL
VISIBLE HOMELESS THAT WE SEE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. FEEL TO ME LIKE
THERE ARE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER ISSUES
AND HOMELESSNESS AND SO JUST
DROPPING THOSE PEOPLE INTO A
HOME SETTING. OR YOU KNOW A
MOTEL OR WHATEVER DOESN'T SOLVE
THE PROBLEM FOR THEM. DOES IT
LEAD TO SUCCESS I WOULD BET.
NINETY NINE TIMES OUT OF A
HUNDRED. SO I GUESS MY BIGGER
QUESTION FROM AS I THINK ABOUT
THE L. A. O. AND LOOK AT THAT.
WHOA WHO'S COORDINATING ALL OF
THESE EFFORTS OR ARE WE PUTTING
MONEY IN INDIVIDUAL SILOS AND
EXPECTING. DIFFERENT RESULTS.
THANK YOU SO THAT IS ACTUALLY
ONE OF OUR MANY QUESTIONS AS
WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS ACROSS I THINK IT'S
UPWARDS OF TEN DEPARTMENTS- FOR
VARIOUS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL TO
BECOMES MORE IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS
COORDINATION ACROSS THE STATE
AND STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY SO
ONE OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WILL SPEAK TO AND SUPPORT
TOMORROW IS JUST MAKING SURE
THAT ANY PLAN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ULTIMATELY ADOPT
DOES HAVE STRONG CREDIBILITY IS
METRICS AND REPORTS BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THE STATE
IS MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
MEETING ITS GOALS. I WOULD SAY
THAT ONE OF THE PROPOSALS
WITHIN THE BUSINESS AND
CONSUMER SERVICE AND HOUSING
AGENCY IS TO DO AN ASSESSMENT-
ABOUT THE LANDSCAPE SERVICES
BEING PROVIDED LOCALLY AND THE
STATE WITH THE INTENT OF
INSURANCE THIS MORE
COORDINATION OVER THE LONG TERM
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
RECENTLY STEP UP- ORAL THAT
PROVIDE MORE VISIBILITY INTO
THE LEVEL OF SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED LOCALLY SO IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE IS SOME PROGRESS ON.
THAT WORK REMAINS TO BE DONE IN
THAT SPACE. THANK YOU. IF I
COULD ADD JUST RECORD NAY OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE QUICK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SO A FEW
THINGS I THINK AS AS THE L. A.
OFFICE JUST MENTIONED THERE
SOME ADDITIONAL ORDINATION AT
HAPPENING WITH THE HOMELESS
WERE DATING AT COUNCIL WHICH
AGAIN MULTI DEPARTMENTAL GOING
ACROSS MUCH OF THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE ABSOLUTELY
CONNECTED MY COULD AGREE WITH
YOU MORE ON THE NEED TO
EMIGRATE THE ACTUAL HOUSING
SUPPORT INTERVENTION WITH THE
SOCIAL SERVICES COMPONENTS TO
ENSURE THAT STABILITY IS A REAL
ALCOHOL NEVER OUT KINDS SO. I
WON I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT BE AT
HOME STATE THAT IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM AT IS GETTING STOOD UP
BY THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES IN HOUSING AGENCY
WHICH IS GOING TO HELP GET TO
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
THAT WE WANT TO ANSWER THAT
YOU'VE RAISED HERE TODAY AROUND
THE REASONS BEHIND IN SECOND
HOW WE'RE GOING FORWARD ALSO
REALLY WANT TO SUPPORT AND LIFT
UP THE ACCOUNTABILITY
COMPONENTS WE ARE HAPPY TO
SHARE- AT THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
ARE WORKING TOWARDS OF COURSE
WORDS PREVENTION IT IS THAT WE
ARE LOOKING TO IDENTIFY THAT
HOUSING STABILITY WHERE WE ARE
RE HOUSING INDIVIDUALS FOR
EXAMPLE FROM PROJECT ROOM G.
TWO WITH DIFFERENT PERMANENT.
ESUPPORT HOUSING SOLUTION OR
OTHERWISE WE CAN CERTAINLY
MEASURE THAT AS WELL SO WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF WAYS IN WHICH THOSE
METRICS I WILL BE MORE READILY
AVAILABLE REQUIRED. TO SHARE
OUR SUCCESSES TO DATE. CORRECT
FOR THE- SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS I HAVE. THAT SO WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE THE DATA NOW
BUT WE'RE STANDING IT UP
CORRECT. THAT THE KINDS OF
THINGS WE DO YEAH. SURE SURE I
THINK FOR THE INTERSECTIONAL
COMPONENTS THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO SEE A MORE RICHER
DATASETS FOR THE PURPOSES AT
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT DSS
ADMINISTERS WE CERTAINLY CAN'T
TELL YOU. HOW MANY AT
INDIVIDUALS HOUSEHOLDS ARE
BEING SERVED WHAT THOSE
OUTCOMES LOOK LIKE WE'RE WE'RE
GLAD TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
ACROSS THESE PROGRAMS WERE
LOOKING TO EXPAND INVESTMENT. I
WE ALSO HAVE A NOT RIGHT NOW IN
THE PROCESS OF CONDUCTING A
SURVEY OF COURSE AS YOU MAY
KNOW THE POINT IN TIME COUNT
DIDN'T OCCUR. I LAST YEAR DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC WHICH PROVIDES
SOME INFORMATION AGAIN POINT IN
TIME AROUND ASK HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND WHO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE THAT ARE AND
SHELTERED. I BUT WE ARE RIGHT
NOW WORKING WITH DOCTOR CAN
SHOW AND TO HAVE SOME SURVEYING
ACROSS- INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES TO LEAD US OUT WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL DATA AND
INFORMATION SO YES WE DO HAVE
INFORMATION TODAY. ON HOW MANY
PEOPLE WERE STARVING WHAT THOSE
OUTCOMES ARE ACROSS OUR
PROGRAMS AND WILL HAVE A
RICHARD K. THE SECOND TERMS
THAT. HAS THIS PERSON I TOUCH
THE SYSTEM PRIOR WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE OUTCOMES WHERE THE
CONNECTIONS TO SERVICES
ETCETERA WITH THE H. D. I.
SYSTEM STIS. SYSTEM THAT'S
BEING STOOD UP. SO IN A IN A IN
THIS BE MY LAST QUESTION I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR- MISTER
CHAIR. SO I GUESS THAT BEGS THE
BIGGER QUESTION THAT I HAVE I
MEAN I BELIEVE WE HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH SORRY IN THE- YOU NOW-
DO WE IS THERE IT IS YOU'VE GOT
ALL THE STATE ALL THESE
DEPARTMENTS. IS THERE A TEAM IS
THERE A CORE GROUP OF PEOPLE
THIS WORKING ACROSS MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING.
TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS. BECAUSE I. OR ARE WE
GONNA WAIT FOR THE DATA SETS
AND- WE JUST GONNA SPEND MONEY.
NOW WITHOUT THE DATA TO REAL IS
I JUST I'M I'M LOOKING FOR SOME
I'M LOOKING FOR SOME. SOME
REASSURANCE AND SOME HELP THAT
THAT THIS IS A REAL COORDINATED
EFFORT THAT. THAT WORKS ACROSS
THE SILOS WE KNOW ALL EXIST IN
AND STATE GOVERNMENT. SURE TWO
THINGS I'D SAY TO THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WIND IS THAT IT IS THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL THAT HAS THAT
LEADERSHIP ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENTS TO COME TOGETHER
JUST ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED. AS
SOMEBODY'S PRIORITIES AND PLANS
MOVING FORWARD PRIOR TO THE
RELEASE OF MAY REDUCTIONS IN
THAT IS THAT WAS. THAT WHO IS
THAT THAT'S OUR DAY THAT THAT'S
THAT'S THE B. C. S. H. I'M
SORRY THE OLD. OKAY BUSINESS
CONSUMERS. AND HOUSING AGENCY.
SO IS THE PERSON AHEAD OF THAT
AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF
THIS I MEAN WHO WHO WHO IS
WEARING THEY COORDINATION
HAPPENING THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR. YES THEY ARE THEY
ARE STOCKING THE BODY WHERE
THAT COORDINATION IS OCCURRING
IN ADDITION TO THAT OTHERS NO
DOUBT AS THROUGH THE LAST. TWO
YEARS SPECIFICALLY THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE ABSOLUTELY
COMING TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY HOW
TO LEVERAGE BLEND BRADY
SPENDING STRINGS WE'VE
DEVELOPED A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TOOLS THAT WE
RECENTLY RELEASED. JUST AROUND
FINANCING AND LEVERAGING
RESOURCES HOW WE'RE TAKING HOME
HE AS A PLACE TO ACQUIRE.
BUILDING FACILITY BUT ALSO THEN
WRAPPING IN THE SERVICES THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SUPPORTS
EXCEPT REST OF THAT IS
HAPPENING IN REAL TIME ACROSS
DEPARTMENTS IN ADDITION. TO THE
VISIONING AND LONGER TERM GOAL
SETTING WITH THAT HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL. SO AND I APOLOGIZE SO
HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE TO GET TO
THAT POINT. I GUESS IT WE'RE
WE'RE NOT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
LOT OF MONEY THAT'S GOING TO GO
GO OUT THE DOOR HERE FAIRLY
QUICKLY IS IT GOING TO GO OUT
WITH. THE OVER ARCHING PLANS IN
THE GUIDANCE OR IS IT JUST
GOING TO GO OUT THE DOOR- AT
THIS POINT I'M SORRY I DON'T
MEAN I REALLY I REALLY AM
TRYING TO BE CONSTRUCTIVE HERE
I JUST I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. WE HAVE A FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MONEY IS SPENT IN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAY AND SO JUST
LOOKING FOR SOME ASSURANCE THAT
THERE IS. SOME BIG COORDINATION
HERE THAT LOOKS AT ALL THESE
FACTORS AND THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE END OF A
LINE THAT SAYS YEAH WE DID.
THIS RIGHT AND WE GOT GREAT
OUTCOMES. THE VERY MUCH. THAT
AND OUT. THERE ARE STE.
REQUIREMENTS TO DATE FOR THE
COUNCIL I'M REFERENCING AROUND
THE APPROACHES ANY DEPARTMENT
IS TAKING SO THAT'S THINGS LIKE
THINKING ABOUT. HOUSING FIRST
PRINCIPLES SO THEY DO WE DO
HAVE THROUGH LINES ACROSS ALL
OF THESE INVESTMENTS IN TERMS
OF YOUR COACHES WERE DOING IN
TERMS OF PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
AND DELIVERY- AND THAT AGAIN
THAT WORK CONTINUES IN THAT
SPACE. AND FULLY APPRECIATE
THAT OUT VERY CLEARLY THAT
NEEDS TO BE THERE FOR AT THE
LEGISLATURE AROUND THE OUTCOMES
AND HOW THESE. INITIATIVES AND
EFFORTS ARE COMING TOGETHER
IT'S SOMETHING WE ABSOLUTELY
ARE COMMITTED TO AND CONTINUED
TO ACTUALLY WORK TOGETHER. AT
TO PROVIDE SO GET HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THE SPECIFICS ON
THE METRICS AND WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE CAN EXPECT TO
RECEIVE THOSE IN OUR IN OUR
SUCCESS TO DATE. THANK YOU.
NEXT ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I GUESS
ONE OF THE THINGS ALL START
WITH- HSS IS YOU KNOW WHEN WE
LOOK AT- THE CAP ON HOURS.
HELLO OKAY IT SEEMS SOMEWHAT
UNREALISTIC FOR AS MANY HOURS
THERE ARE THERE ARE IN THE
MONTHS. THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO. INCREASE THE HOURS SO THE
PEOPLE HAVE A LEVEL OF CARE
THAT THEY DESERVE- THAT WAS
CHANGED WHEN THE FEDERAL
MANDATE. WAS IMPLEMENTED BUT-
YOU KNOW IT JUST SOMETIMES I
WONDERING IF WHAT IF THERE IS A
PLAN TO LOOK AT INCREASING THE
HOURS ON THE CAP. PRICE HSS.
YOU FOR THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- THE PROPOSAL THAT I
REFERENCED WITHIN THE MAY
REVISION IS A RESTORATION- OF A
REDUCTION OF 7% IN HOURS- THAT
HAD OCCURRED IN THE PAST IN
VARIOUS FORMS AND THEN BEEN
PROPOSED OVER THE TIME FOR
SUSPENSION. AND THIS IS
ELIMINATING THAT REDUCTION I
THINK YOU ARE PROBABLY
PREFERRING SEPARATELY TO THE
FACT THAT THE IHS US PROGRAM
HAS A STATUTORY MAXIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE HOURS
OF SERVICES. PER MONTH AND WE
DO NOT AT THIS TIME HAVE ANY
PROPOSALS RELATED TO THAT
STATUTORY MAXIMUM. HAS THE L.
A. O. HAD ANY KIND OF
OPPORTUNITY TO. GO BACK AND
ADDRESS THE AUDIT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THERE'S BEEN. A LOT
HSS THERE IS THERE'S BEEN
IMPLEMENTATION PROBLEMS OR- IS
THERE OTHER SUGGESTIONS HELIO
HAS BASED OUT OF THAT POINT
FORWARD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE
HAVE REVIEWED THE AUDIT IF
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDIT THAT WAS
RELEASED I BELIEVE SOMETIME IN
FEBRUARY- WE'RE HAPPY TO LOOK
BACK WITH COMMITTEE STAFF TO
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU'D LIKE
US TO DIG A BIT DEEPER ON THERE
ARE A LOT OF. FINDINGS AND
OBSERVATIONS MADE SO IF THERE'S
A PARTICULAR BUCKET THAT YOU
WOULD WANT US TO FOLLOW UP ON
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT. AND ONE
MORE QUESTION MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE.
THE ONE THE ONLY THE ONLY OTHER
QUESTION I DO HAVE IS BASED ON.
THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO BREAK
MOVING BRING MORE PROVIDERS WE
KNOW THAT I. HSS IS A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE MONEY- IT
SAVES US HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IF NOT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- WHAT KIND OF PROGRAMS
ARE WE GOING TO DO- TO
INCENTIVIZE IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN. IN HIGH SCHOOLS TO
BRIDGE PEOPLE OR EVEN ANY WALK
OF LIFE TO BRING PEOPLE INTO
THIS WORKFORCE- TO NOT ONLY.
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR CARE
FOR THE FOR THE POPULATION BUT
ALSO- OR WORK FOR CENTER. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AB THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
RELATED TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT MORE BROADLY WHICH
CERTAINLY CAN BENEFIT THIS
PARTICULAR POPULATION AS WELL.
AS WHAT YOU JUST ASKED ALSO
DOES RELATE TO OUR WERE
PROPOSAL FOR THE LONG TERM CARE
CAREER PATHWAYS- IN THE SENSE
THAT IT M. BOTH IT CAN BE USED
BOTH FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
NEWLY BECOMING I. HSS PROVIDERS
AS WELL AS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE I. HSS PROVIDERS. AND ONCE
YOU UP SKILL AND- INCREASE
THEIR SKILLS WITHIN THE IHS US
PROGRAM AND OR TO MOVE ON TO
OTHER- HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONS
AND WE THINK THIS IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF THE RESPONSE TO THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL CARE
GIVING. ONE MORE QUESTION AND
BASED ON THAT. DO WE HAVE ANY
KIND OF DATA THAT THAT KIND OF-
SHOWS THAT WE HAVE A DEFICIENCY
IN OF PROVIDER CARE. I DON'T
KNOW IF THE L. A. O. HAS
ANYTHING OFF THE TOP OF THEIR
HEADS IN TERMS OF STATISTICS I
DO NOT HAVE A STATISTIC CANDY
FOR YOU CERTAINLY ANECDOTALLY
WE HEAR- QUITE OFTEN IN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING PROCESS
WE DID HEAR FROM STAKEHOLDERS
QUITE A BIT. THAT THAT IS ONE
OF THE CONCERNS- BOTH IN TERMS
OF FINDING A PROVIDER GENERALLY
AND SPECIFICALLY FINDING BACKUP
CARE WHICH HAS LED TO OUR MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL WITH RESPECT
TO OUR PERMANENT BACKUP CARE
SYSTEM. SO I WOULD SAY THEN IF
WE ARE. EXPECTED TO RELEASE
MONEY THROUGH A BUDGET. THAT WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS AN EFFORT TO-
CREATED AND BACK FILL THAT HOLE
OF CARE FOR THIS POPULATION IN
AN ONGOING EFFORT TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOBODY GOES WITHOUT THAT
WE ALL INTEND THAT THEY'RE
TAKING CARE OF OUR OWN A-
APPROPRIATE MANNER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I WILL
BRING IT. BACK TO THE CHAIR I
FIRST WANT TO SPEAK IF I CAN
ABOUT TELL WORKS AND THE
IMPORTANCE THAT THIS PROGRAM
PLAYS. IN US ADDRESSING
SYSTEMIC RACISM. THIS PROGRAM
BY ITS NATURE HAS NOT ALWAYS
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AND THUS AM
ENCOURAGED BY THE DIRECTION
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
MOVING IN WITH CAL WORKS TO
POINT OUT. AS WELL AS CAL OR
OUTCOMES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO BE DRIVING TOWARDS METRICS
AND IMPROVING UPON THESE
PROGRAMS WITH THE DESIRED
EFFECT OF DISRUPTING POVERTY
AND SUPPORTING FAMILIES. SO I
REALLY WANTED DAY AGAIN IF I
CAN INTO THE H. S. P. PROPOSAL
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN GET
MORE DETAILS TO OUR STAFF AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. BUT HOW THESE
FUNDS WILL BE ENVISIONED AND
UTILIZED TO HELP US WITH
CASELOADS AND SERVICES. OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS TO GET TO
THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF REACHING
ZERO HOMELESS IN OUR STATE. AND
SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE TO ASK
WHAT PROGRAM FLEXIBILITIES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING WITH THIS
INVESTMENT. THANK YOU CHAIR YES
GLAD TO BE MORE SPECIFIC HERE
AGAIN I MENTIONED BRIEFLY IN
THE OPENING REMARKS A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT- WHAT WE ARE SEEING
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN THAT EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT. 85% OF THE
FAMILIES ARE TOUCHING THE
HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM I WERE
ACTUALLY RECENTLY RECEIVING CAO
WORKS- OR HAD RECEIVED IT
RECENTLY SO WE AGAIN BELIEVE
THAT THIS INVESTMENT EXPANSION.
IS TARGETING EXACTLY WHO WE
NEED TO AND SUPPORTING AND
REACHING OUR GOAL. AT THE
ADDITIONAL- WAYS IN WHICH WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT FLEXIBILITY AND
H. S. P. WITH THE EXPANSION IS
REALLY THINKING ABOUT
PREVENTION. SO WE HAVE HAD IN
THE PAST A REQUIREMENT THAT
THERE WAS NO IMMEDIATE AT THAT
STRESSOR OR AT CHECK OUT
OPPORTUNITY THAT WAS OCCURRING
RELATED TO INFECTION- IN THE
HSP DESIGN WAS LIKE TO LOOK
FURTHER EXTREME IN OUR ABILITY
TO ACTUAL WE- ARE BE ABLE TO.
PROACTIVELY PROVIDE THESE
RESOURCES TO AGAIN I PROVIDE
STABILITY DIRECT STABILITY
EFFORTS THAT HAVE OCCURRED OVER
THE LAST OF COURSE THE LAST
YEAR OR SO. HI BEGIN
DEMONSTRATED THAT WHEN WE CAN
CREATE BANKS HAVE A BIG XIN OUT
WE ARE CERTAINLY MUCH BETTER
OFF IN TERMS OF THE LONGER TERM
OUTCOMES FOR THE FAMILY SO
AGAIN OUR GOAL WOULD BE TO WORK
ON OUTLINING SOME ADDITIONAL.
BROADER ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS ON WHO COULD BE
SEE. THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM RESOURCES. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AND AM REALLY LIKED
YOUR ABOUT A- AS A CAL WORKS.
OUR BEST ABILITY TO GET
UPSTREAM OF MANY OF THE
PROBLEMS. THAT FACE US OF THE
STATE WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
HOMELESSNESS OR- SUBSTANCE
ABUSE OR MENTAL HEALTH AND SO
SEE THESE INVESTMENTS THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR US. I
THINK THE QUESTION I HAVE
DIRECTOR IS A GAP ANALYSIS AND
AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHETHER
THESE FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT. WE'VE DONE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR BOTH THIS YEAR AND
NEXT YEAR BUT- WOULD LIE TO
GET AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
MUCH NEED THERE IS WITHIN THE
CAL WORKS POPULATION TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE. PROVIDING ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO GET FULLY UPSTREAM.
GLAD TO DO THAT CHAIR WE HAVE
BOTH- THE NUMBER I HAVE-
APPLIQUE APPLICANTS THE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS IN THE APPLICATION.
TO ACTUALLY ADMINISTERED THAT
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM THAT WE
COULD CERTAINLY PROVIDE AT YOU
IN THE COMMITTEE. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY. THERE
WERE EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TEN PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN WHO
TOUCH THE HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM
SO AGAIN. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
INVESTMENTS OVER THE COURSE. OF
FIVE YEARS IS GOING TO HELP US
AGAIN GET TO THAT FUNCTIONAL
ZERO SO GLAD TO PROVIDE TO YOU
BOTH THE- NUMBERS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED IN TERMS OF NEED
FROM OUR COUNTY APPLICATION
PROCESS. BUT ALSO WE KNOW ABOUT
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE FAMILIES
WHO HAVE BEEN TOUCHING THE
SYSTEM. LIKE TO DRAW A PARALLEL
AND CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN- OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF AND HE WAS
WHILE DIRECTOR SPECIFICALLY ON
HOW WE CAN PROVIDE. RESOURCES
TO THOSE WHO HAVE THE GREATEST
NEEDS. WITHIN CAL AIM THIS YEAR
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ECM AN
ENHANCED CARE MANAGEMENT
BENEFIT THAT WE WILL BE GIVING
TO THOSE WHO HAVE THE GREATEST
NEEDS. WITHIN OUR CAL WORKS
POPULATION WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH AN INTENSIVE
CARE MANAGEMENT TOOL TO PROVIDE
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOURS OF
BENEFIT FOR. THOSE WHO HAVE THE
GREATEST NEEDS. I'D LIKE TO
ENGAGE INTO A CONVERSATION
ABOUT SEEING IF WE CAN INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF HOURS TO WE CAN
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES TO THOSE
WHO HAVE THE GREATEST NEEDS AT
THE YOUNGEST AGE THAT WE CAN.
RATHER THAN WAITING UNTIL WE
GET DOWNSTREAM AND HAVING TO DO
IT WITH AND CAL LAME AND ECM.
INSTEAD GET UPSTREAM AND REALLY
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES IN THE
INTENSIVE CARE MANAGEMENT. WAS
HOPING YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THAT. WHAT GLAD TO CONNECT
FURTHER AT HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WE DON'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL THATINCREASES THOSE
HOURS THAT CERTAINLY OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST FEW YEARS
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING SPECIFICALLY
AT INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT.
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE FAMILY
STABILIZATION RESOURCES IN A
COW WORKS PROGRAM AND HOW WE
CAN ENSURE THAT COUNTIES HAVE.
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED FOR IT
TO BE A HOUSEHOLDS IN THE
FAMILIES THAT NEED THAT SUPPORT
THE MOST SO GLAD TO ADD GAUGES
MEDICINAL CONVERSATION ON WHAT
LED US. TO OUR- OUR HOURS THAT
WE IDENTIFIED IN TERMS OF THEIR
RESOURCES FRANCIS INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT WHAT WE THINK
AND IT'S GOT TO. FOLLOW UP ON
THAT. I LOVE TO INVOLVE C. W.
D. A. INTO THAT- DISCUSSION AS
I BELIEVE THEY HAVE SOME
NUMBERS FOR BOTH THIS BUDGET
YEAR AN ON GOING THAT MAY BE
USEFUL FOR. THOSE DISCUSSIONS
AND REALLY HOPE WE CAN. BE
PRODUCTIVE AND MEETING THE
NEEDS OF. THOSE WHO ARE IN THE
COLORS PROGRAM. I'D LIKE TO NOW
FOCUS MY QUESTIONS IF I CAN ON
TO THE COUNTY MATCH. I SAW ON A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS NUMBERS
FIVE SIX AND EIGHTEEN- THE- H.
TAPPED THE HOME SAFE IN THE
BRING FAMILY HOMES. PROPOSALS
THAT THERE WAS A COUNTY MATCH.
AND GENERALLY WOULD LIKE TO GET
AN UNDERSTANDING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION IF THIS 25%
MATCH WHICH IS REQUIRED IN
ORDER TO ACCESS AND UTILIZE
THESE FUNDS. WILL THIS INHABIT
THE ABILITIES OF COUNTIES. TO
READILY UTILIZE THESE ANTI
HOMELSSNESS FUNDS. AND WHAT
SPECIFIC PROGRAM FLEXIBILITIES
IS. THE GOVERNOR PROPOSING WITH
THIS INVESTMENT. THANK YOU
CHAIR OUT AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
SOME OF THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT THIS DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTERS DO YOU HAVE A ONE
TO ONE MATCH. IN THE EXPANSION
IN SEVERAL OF THE PROGRAMS WE
ARE PROPOSING A 25% MATCH A
LEICESTER MATCH BUT THAT THERE
STILL IS THE COMMITMENTS AND
ENGAGEMENT. LEVERAGING THE
WHOLE TO THE PRIOR AT COMMENTS
MADE WE REALLY DO WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE INTEGRATING
BLENDING BLAKE GRADING AND
LEVERAGING. THESE ARE THE
INVESTMENTS LOCALLY AND AFTER
COMING TOGETHER SO WE DO
BELIEVE THAT I WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
INVESTMENTS WE'VE MADE THERE IS
THAT OPPORTUNITY. I HAVE FOR
THE MATCH TO ENSURE THAT AGAIN
I COUNTIES ARE WORKING
HOLISTICALLY ACROSS THE SPENCER
SYSTEM TO LEVERAGE RESOURCES.
I'M GLAD TO AND TO FURTHER MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IF THEY WANT TO SEE
MORE ABOUT AT A MATCH. IN A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- COMES
FROM IN FINANCE THANK YOU CAN
FOR THAT HAVE NOTHING FURTHER
TO ADD- JUST REITERATING THE
FACT THAT EXISTING. RUN STATURE
WITH THESE PROGRAMS REQUIRE
SOMEONE TO NOT ONE MATCH THIS
IS PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO REDUCE THAT ONE
TO ONE MATCH. I'M WITH THE 25%
WHICH- WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO-
PULL THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE IN AND ASK THAT WE
FOLLOW UP TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ROLE THAT
THESE MATCHING FUNDS MAY HAVE
FOR CERTAIN OF OUR COUNTIES.
REPRESENTING A POOR RURAL
COUNTY IT'S OFTENTIMES
DIFFICULT FOR US TO. FIGURE OUT
HOW TO COME UP WITH THOSE
MATCHING FUNDS AND JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF OUR
ACCOUNTS. WITH THAT I WILL TURN
TO MY FINAL TWO QUESTIONS. NEXT
I WILL LOOK AT ISSUE NUMBER
NINETEEN THE F. F. P. S. A.
INVESTMENTS. AND I'M TRYING TO
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING. I
FEEL LIKE WE NEED MORE DETAILS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION. AND
WAS HOPING THAT YOU CAN SHARE
WITH THE SUB COMMITTEE THE
LANGUAGE. THAT WILL BE RELEASED
WITH THIS PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS
SPECIFICALLY IN PART FOUR OF
THIS PROPOSAL. AND THEN WHICH
CATEGORIES OF ISSUES DOES THE
REVISED LANGUAGE ADDRESS WAS
HOPING YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THAT. THIRD OUR TOO- TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE RELATED PIECES TO
F. PSA THAT I THINK ARE
PROBABLY WORTH HIGHLIGHTING IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION ONE
IS UPDATES TO TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT YOU RECEIVED
WITH- THE JANUARY BUDGET. AND
THEN THE SECOND IS- TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD BE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BLOCK
GRANTS WHICH IS NEWLY PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISION- BOTH OF
THOSE ARE ANTICIPATED TO BE
PROVIDED THIS WEEK POTENTIAL
EVEN AS SOON AS TODAY. D. WITH
RESPECTABLE BANK WHICH FROM
JANUARY- THAT LANGUAGE HAS BEEN
OUT FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND
THERE'S A LOT OF STAKEHOLDER
COMMENTS THAT WE'VE RECEIVED.
SOME OF THOSE STAKEHOLDER
COMMENTS ACTUALLY RELATE TO OUR
PREVENTION PLAN WHICH IS DUE TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT'S-
CAUGHT- COMMENTS ON THINGS LIKE
WHAT IT IS THAT QUALIFIES
SOMEONE TO BE A CANDIDATE. FOR
FOSTER CARE OR AT IMMINENT RISK
OF FOSTER CARE THOSE WILL BE
ADDRESSED IN THE- PREVENTION
PLAN PROCESS NOT IN TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. WE DO ANTICIPATE
RELEASING A REVISED VERSION OF
OUR PREVENTION PLAN- BY THE END
OF THIS MONTH EARLY NEXT MONTH.
THEN WITH RESPECT TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE
THINGS THEY DO ACTUALLY NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED IN STATE STATUTE-
WE RECEIVED A LOT OF COMMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO PART FOUR. OF
FF PSA ON THINGS LIKE THE ROLE
OF THE- THE QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUAL IN ASSESSING THE
CHILD'S NEEDS AND SERVICES. AND
ALSO THE STRUCTURE OF HOW WE-
IN SHORT ACCESS TO NURSING
SERVICES UNDER PART FOUR
REQUIREMENTS SO THOSE
REFINEMENTS TO THOSE PIECES ARE
ARE BUT I'M ALSO REFERRING TO
IS THE BUT WILL BE AVAILABLE
VERY SOON- AND THEN WITH
RESPECT TO THE PREVENTION
FUNDING WHAT'S NEW IN THE MAY
REVISION. IS A PROPOSAL FOR
THIS BLOCK GRANTS TO PROVIDE
SOME- INITIAL UPFRONT
INVESTMENT TO YOU- SUPPORT THE
COUNTIES THAT OPT IN TO PART
ONE. OF PREVENTION SERVICES TO
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING AND WE WILL BE
PROPOSING LANGUAGE THAT PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THE-COUNTY PLANS. THAT ARE- WILL
NEED TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT IN ASSOCIATION WITH
THE COUNTIES OPTING IN TO
RECEIVE THOSE BLOCK GRANTS AND
THAT TOO YOU WILL BE AVAILABLE
VERY SOON THIS WEEK. THANK YOU
FOR THAT- I LOOK FORWARD.
PERMISSION OF MY FINAL QUESTION
WILL BE ON NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
REGARDING DACA AND THE
NATURALIZATION FILING FEES. I'D
LIKE TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE CURRENT NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT THIS.
OR WOULD THIS PROPOSAL WARRANT
CONSIDERATION OF SERVICE
PROVIDER NEEDS SPECIFICALLY IT
SEEMS THAT THE FUNDS ARE FOR
THE FILING FEES BUT WHO IS IT
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO DO THE
FILING. I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION CHAIR YES THE ANSWER
IS THAT YES WE DO BELIEVE THAT
ARE. THAT CAPACITY EXISTS TO
COUPLE OF REASONS WHY ONE FIRST
I JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
JUST GENUINELY APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ESPECIALLY
ON THIS EFFORT. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DID EARLY ON THE
WITH THE FUNDING TOGETHER WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON IMMIGRATION
SERVICES FIND WAYS TO ENSURE WE
WERE INCLUDING SOME CAPACITY
BUILDING. RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AT THE BILL THAT OVER TIME AND
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CONTINUE
THAT SO IT IS WITH BOTH- OUR
EXISTING NETWORK WHICH HAS BEEN
IT HAS HAVE HAS NOT BE ABILITY
TO GROW BUT ALSO TO REACH. OUT
COMMUNITIES I AM POPULATIONS
THAT WERE INITIALLY ON AND NOT
BACK WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF
SERVICE. WE HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT EFFORT OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT ADD TO THE
CBO'S AT WHAT THE RESOURCES TO
GO FORWARD SO YES WE DO BELIEVE
THE EXISTING NETWORK HAS THE
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT THE
ISSUANCE. ISSUANCE. OF THE
SILENT PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND I LOOK FOR TO WORKING
CONVERSATIONS I AYE WELL IN
THIS SECTION IF I CAN SPEAKING
ABOUT. FOOD AND- DISAPPOINTMENT
THAT I HAVE THAT- THERE WASN'T
FURTHER INVESTMENTS INTO OUR
FOOD BANK INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS WITH THE
RESOURCES WE HAD- I DO NOT
BELIEVE THIS IS THE LAST CRISIS
WE WILL GO THROUGH AS A STATE.
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S DROUGHT OR-
A WILD FIRE WE WILL HAVE NEEDS
FOR HER FOOD BANKS AND BELIEVES
THAT INVESTMENTS INTO. HELPING
THEM WITH TRANSPORTATION OR
RENOVATING THEIR FACILITIES
WILL GO A LONG WAY FOR AS A
STATE. AND BELIEVE THOSE
INVESTMENTS WILL BE NECESSARY
FOR US TO LOOK AT AS WE ARE
PUTTING THIS BUDGET TOGETHER. I
ALSO WANTED TO UP LIFT THE
EFFORTS WITH FOOD FOR ALL TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR IMMIGRANTS
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO. FOOD THAT
WE ARE DISTRIBUTING AS A STATE
IT IS. AGAIN IRONIC WHEN YOU
COME FROM THE BREAD BASKET OF
THE WORLD TO HAVE AS MUCH FOOD
SECURITY IN SECURITY. AS YOU DO
IN MY COMMUNITY. WITH THAT I
WILL THANK VERY MUCH PANEL
NUMBER ONE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
PANEL NUMBER TWO. ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. ME
REVISED. FOR THIS WE WILL HAVE
THREE PRESENTER ON THE PAY. JOE
HOBBY ED. THE DIRECTOR OF TO
PER OF REHABILITATION. NANCY
BARGE MAN WITH THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND SONYA PADDOCK WITH
THE HOLIDAYS PLAN MINIMALIST
OFFICE. LET'S BEGIN WITH
DIRECTOR HOW YET. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF GOOD
MORNING TO YOU- I'M JONES
XAVIER DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
AND- GLAD TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT OUR PROPOSAL
AND CERTAINLY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS. THAT YOU HAVE. THE
GOVERNOR'S- COME BACK PLAN ALSO
INCLUDES- THIS INITIATIVE TO
HELP IMPLEMENT- FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES. AND I
WOULDN'T KNOW TO HEAR THAT
EMPLOYMENT HAS A VERY POSITIVE
BENEFIT BOTH ON HEALTH.
COMMUNITY LIVING AND PROVIDING
A PATH OUT OF POVERTY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
WE SEEK TO DO TWO THINGS HERE
ONE IS TO ADDRESS. THE JOB LAWS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC O THAT WE'VE BEEN IN.
AND TO FOCUS ON THE OVERALL
INCREASING THE EMPLOYMENT RATE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. SO REALLY THIS
RESPONSE FROM BILLIONS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL WITH THE DISABILITY-
I CANNOT- GET SCREAMED INTO THE
INTERVIEW I DON'T GET AN
INTERVIEW AND IF I GET AN
INTERVIEW I'M NOT GETTING THE
JOB. AND SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT IN THIS PROPOSAL IS
WHO'S DOING THE HIRING AND
TAKING SOME INITIATIVES TO
REALLY FOCUS ON THE DEMAND SIDE
OF THE EMPLOYMENT EQUATION. THE
PARADIGM REALLY IS SHIFTING
BUSINESS THINKING FROM YOUR
HIRING BECAUSE AS A SOCIAL GOOD
TO YOUR TRULY HIRING BECAUSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
FRIENDS REFLECT A LARGE MARKET
SHARE BUT YOU AS AN EMPLOYER
YOU WANT OR YOU AS A BUSINESS
WANT TO MAKE SURE- IS
REPRESENTATIVE IN YOUR WORK
FORCE. SO ULTIMATELY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO DO WITH THESE
INITIATIVES IS TO- TRANSFORM
THE TRANSACTIONAL ENGAGEMENT OF
BUSINESS ON HIRE TO REALLY-
SHIFT THAT MINDSET THAT I'VE
DESCRIBED SO HOW ARE WE GOING
TO DO THIS. ONE IS- INITIATE A
TARGETED CAMPAIGN THAT REALLY
FOCUSES ON- LIFTING UP THE
EMPLOYMENT OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. TO INCENTIVIZE.
THREE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
A COUPLE OF OTHER NATIONAL WAYS
THE EMPLOYERS TO HIRING
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DIRECTOR BARGE MEN FROM
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WILL
SPEAK ABOUT THE THIRD LEG OF
THIS. SO THE MEDIA CAMPAIGN-
REALLY FOCUSES ON DOING THREE
THINGS. ONE USE THE STATE'S
CONVENING POWER TO BRING
EMPLOYEES TOGETHER TO- LIFT UP-
AND GET THEIR COMMITMENT INTO
HIRING INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEN TO.
THROUGH GRANT DOLLARS- THROUGH
OUR CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IS
ANOTHER SOURCES REALLY- LIFT UP
THOSE EMPLOYERS THAT ARE DOING
A GOOD JOB PROVIDE RECOGNITION
THAT ARE REALLY HIRING
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
THE THIRD PIECE OF THIS IS TO
RALLY- CREATE AN EMPLOYER
INCENTIVE- PACKAGE THAT IT
HOPES EMPLOYERS- LEAN INTO THE
HIRING AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. ONE THING THAT WE
WOULD DO IS TO PROVIDE BOTH
GRANTS AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO FOCUS ON THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO HELP THEM DO TWO
THINGS ONE IS MAKE A COMMITMENT
TO HIRING INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND TO- HELP THEM
ADDRESS ANY ACCESS ISSUES THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE- IN BRINGING
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
INTO THE WORK FORCE. THROUGH
OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
SOCIETY FOR HUMAN RESOURCE
MANAGERS COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS UP FRONT
AND FRANKLY TO BORROW AN
EARLIER TIME USED. UPSTREAM
BOTH THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY'RE DOING THE
HIRING THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
DOING THE HIRING AND THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND SO PROVIDING
THEM WITH SOME AWARENESS AND
SKILL SET AROUND THE
RECRUITMENT. THE SCREENING AND
THE HIGHER OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES SO THAT THEY WILL
BE. MORE OPEN- AND WILLING TO
BRING THOSE INDIVIDUALS INTO
THE WORK FORCE AND THE THIRD
ELEMENTS. I'M THEIR SISTER- FOR
LACK OF A BETTER TERM- I SHARED
LEARNING- AND WORK EXPERIENCE
OPPORTUNITY OUR MODEL THAT I
OFTEN POINT TO WHEN THIS IS-
HANDS ON WITH THE HYATT HOTEL
SYSTEM WHAT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN THE CULINARY
ARTS. GO TO WORK FOR THE HYATT
HOTELS IN THIS EARN AND LEARN
APPROACH THEY GET BOTH OF THE
EXPERIENCE- AND THE SKILL SET
THAT IS NEEDED TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THAT COMMUNITY. AND THEN OF
COURSE WORD HI IT HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO BE
HIGHER THERE THEY ARE BUT THEY
HAVE BOTH OF NOW THE SKILL SET.
AND HIGHER AS A REFERENCE TO GO
ON TO WORKING ANOTHER HOTELS
OTHER RESTAURANTS IN THE OTHER
PLACE THAT PROVIDES. CULINARY
SERVICES. THE OTHER PIC THE
THING THAT WE DO HERE IS WOULD
HOW HAVE ONE LIMITED TERM
POSITION THAT WOULD BE FOR
ADMINISTERING THIS- THESE
GRANTS OF ONE JUST TALKING
ABOUT HERE AND GETTING THESE
INITIATIVES- UP. COLLEAGUE IS.
THE SUSPENSION OF THE RATE
INCREASE FOR THE JOB COACHING
AND THAT IS ALSO LISTED IN THE
AGENDA ITEM THERE. SO ALL STOP
MY COMMENTS THEIR ALTERNATE
OVER TO DIRECTOR BARGE MEANT TO
SPEAK TO THE OTHER. PART OF THE
INITIATIVE SO NANCY YEAR. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR EXACTLY IN- YOU
MISTER TO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RELIX ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY TO.
FURTHER THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
HAVE WITH DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION TO FOCUS ON SUCH
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE- WE REALLY
REALLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT NOW TO BE ABLE TO LEAN
INTO SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS- TO
FURTHER THEIR THEIR DESIRE AND
INTEREST AND ABILITY TO. BE A
PART OF THE VALUED WORK FORCE-
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND- THROUGH
THIS GRANT PROGRAM IT REALLY
DOES BUILD UPON AND MANY OF THE
INITIATIVES- THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK ON BUT AS MANY
THINGS THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC-
EMPLOYMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- WAS SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED- SO AS IT'S BEEN NOTED
THAT- INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES REALLY DO
REPRESENT A VERY SMALL PORTION
OF OUR WORKFORCE- AND I WILL
TELL YOU THAT- THROUGH
EXPERIENCE THAT I WILL ALSO
SAY. THAT THERE ARE ACTUALLY
SOME OF THAT THE GREATEST-
STAFF AND WORK FORCE THAT YOU
CAN NEVER HAVE- TO BE PART OF
YOUR BUSINESS AND SO TO HAVE
THE IMPACT THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
BE SO SIGNIFICANT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE USE OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO FOCUS ON. OF RECOVERY
BUT THEN ALSO LONGER TERM
STRATEGIES- TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
BUT ALSO TO HELP BUSINESSES SEE
THE VALUE AND THE BENEFIT OF
INDIVIDUALS- WHO HAVE
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- THAT THEY BRING
TO THE. WORK FORCE INTO THE
COMMUNITY. SO THE AREA THAT-
DDS REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO-
FOCUSING ON IN ADDITION TO THE
COLLABORATION WITH DEPARTMENT
OF REHAB ON THEIR EFFORTS-
BECAUSE WE REALLY WILL USE OUR
OUR EFFORT TO WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANY INITIATIVE-
IS REALLY DONE IN CONCERT
TOGETHER- WE HAVE A REALLY
GREAT EXPERIENCE I'M USING A
GRANT PROGRAM. AND WE WOULD
WANT TO USE OUR EXPERIENCE
WITHIN THE GRANT PROGRAMS FOR
OTHER INITIATIVES- TO BE BUILT
ON IN IN THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
THE FUNDING THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING FOR THIS PURPOSE-
AND THE FUNDING WOULD REALLY
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PROVIDERS. REGIONAL CENTERS-
SMALL BUSINESSES TO WORK
TOGETHER- AND REALLY BRIDGE
THAT GAP YOU KNOW LOOKING AT
WHERE WE CAN- PROVIDE SMALL
BUSINESSES AS AN EXAMPLE- TO
OPEN THE DOOR HAVE THE ABILITY
TO- TRAIN THEIR STAFF TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE- THE OPPORTUNITY
TO- TAKE A LOOK AT IF THERE'S
ANY- ACCOMMODATIONS THAT'S
NEEDED THAT WE CAN ENHANCE
THAT- AND THEN USE THE- ABILITY
TO MAKE THESE CONNECTIONS- AND
INCREASE OUR OPPORTUNITIES- ONE
OF THAT THE LAST THING SAID
LIKE TO NOTE. IS THAT WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT THIS IS A
PATHWAY TO EMPLOYMENT- AND WE
HAVE OTHER INITIATIVES THAT
I'LL BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO- IN A
LITTLE BIT IS THAT COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AND ARE
PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS. THAT
THIS WOULD ALSO BE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THOSE EFFORTS-
AND AGAIN BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN
SUCH A DECREASE- SO BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE THOSE PATHWAYS
TOGETHER I'M USING THIS AS A
WAY TO. REALLY FOCUS AND- DO A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF AN INTENSE-
FOCUSED IN WHAT WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO HAD READ NOT-
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER
THIS INVESTMENT SO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR. TIME AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. NOT WE'LL
HEAR FROM SUN UP WITH THE L. I
THINK YOU MISTER TERROR US YOU
PUT IT FROM THE LEDGE. AND
OFFICE. AS MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE ILIO NOTED EARLIER WE ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING ALL OF THE PROPOSALS
IN THE MAY REVISION AND
ESPECIALLY AS MORE INFORMATION
BECOMES AVAILABLE AND- WE WILL
BE RELEASING US AND SUBSEQUENT
ANALYSIS OVER THE COMING WEEK.
I'M IN THE MEANTIME I WOULD
ALSO NOTE AGAIN THAT WE'VE BEEN
ASKED BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
COMMENT ON AREAS IN WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS ALIGN WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. AND
THEN TO DISCUSS ANY ISSUES THAT
WE SEE WITH THAT WITH THE
CURRENT PROPOSALS SO WHEN IT
COMES TO THE EMPLOYMENT GRANTS
PROPOSED FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION AND DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. TO
INCENTIVIZE PRIVATE ENTITIES TO
DEVELOP INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS WE
WOULD NOTED THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THESE- THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD RESULT IN INCREASED
EMPLOYMENT AMONG INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
OR INCREASED INTERNSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THIS DOES
ALIGN WITH PREVIOUS.
LEGISLATIVE ACTION INCLUDING
THE EMPLOYMENT FIRST LAW PASSED
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AS WELL AS
FUNDING PASSED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN FOR PAID INTERNSHIPS
AND COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED.
EMPLOYMENT INCENTIVES. NO I
OFFICE WOULD KNOW THAT THE THAT
THIS SEEMS TO HAVE MERIT
HOWEVER BECAUSE THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL IS NOT YET
AVAILABLE WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO REVIEW THE DETAILS OR
CONDUCT A THOROUGH ASSESSMENT-
IT'S ALSO UNCLEAR IF THE
PROPOSED ACTIONS ARE THE BEST
METHOD TO ENGAGE OUR EMPLOYERS
AND THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY WE
DON'T KNOW- WHEN ALL. OTHER
ALTERNATIVES WERE CONSIDERED.
WE WOULD NOT THE DDS PROPOSES
TO CHANGE SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
GOVERNING ITS CURRENT
INTERNSHIP- A PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE SOME AMOUNT OF FUNDING
TO THE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
COVER. COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
DEVELOPING INTERNSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES RIGHT NOW FUNDING
ONLY COVERS THE PAID INTERNSHIP
ITSELF IT APPEARS THAT THAT-
PROPOSED CHANGE THE LANGUAGE AS
WELL AS THESE EMPLOYMENT
BROWN'S PROPOSEDFOR DEAL ARE
IN DCS WOULD BE COMPLEMENTARY.
THE LAST COMMENT- THAT WE WOULD
MAKE ABOUT THE EMPLOYMENT GRANT
PROPOSAL IS THAT CURRENT- OR
RATHER ABOUT- DDS IS CURRENT
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM WHICH IS
THAT. THE CURRENT INTERNSHIP
AMOUNTS ARE BASED ON- A CAPPED
AMOUNT PER YEAR PER PERSON AND
IT'S BASED ON AN EARLIER AND
LOWER STATE MINIMUM WAGE. THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT ALSO WANT TO
CONSIDER REFINING LANGUAGE SO
AS NOT TO LIMIT AN INDIVIDUAL'S
CHANCE TO WORKING. FULL TIME
INTERNSHIP OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEAR. AND THEN THE FINAL
CUT I MAKE A REGARDING DIRECT
AND SAVE YOU CEMENT OF THE- OF
SUSPENSION- FOR JOB COACHING
AND JOB SUPPORT- DO YOU GENERAL
SPEAKING THE WOMEN. OF SOME.
ARE THE- O. R. AND- IN OF SO
RATE INCREASE AS AS YOU HALL.
SCHEDULE ARE A LINE WITH BOTH
WITH LET'S JUST PRAYER AS WELL
AS RECOMMENDED THAT OUR OFFICE
HAS MADE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I BRING IT UP TO THE
DíAS FOR MEMBERS QUESTIONS I'M
GONNA ASK DIRECTOR PARCHMAN TO
MAKE SURE SHE HAD ADDRESSED THE
DDS COMPONENT OF THIS PANEL.
RECTOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APOLOGIES TO THE
COMMITTEE- I'D SO TO CONTINUE
WITH THE PROPOSALS- FOR THIS
YEAR THAT- DDS IS- PROVIDING
THAT THAT IT'S INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I'D LIKE TO
GO AHEAD AND JUST MAKE NOTES
THAT I WILL BE HIGHLIGHTING
STEP SEVERAL ELEMENTS WITHIN
THE AGENDA AND- FOR YOUR
TRACKING I'LL JUST MAKE NOTE OF
THOSE- RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S
ITEM. 575-355-5450 EIGHT AND
SIXTY THREE- I WILL JUST-
PROVIDE JUST OF A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW FOR YOU- I'M JUST IS
THAT A REFERENCE POINT IS THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S- BUDGET. AS A-
PROPOSAL FOR- BUDGET YEAR TO BE
FUNDED AT- TEN POINT SEVEN
BILLION TOTAL FUNDS SIX POINT
SIX BILLION GENERAL FUND AND IT
REPRESENTS A PROJECTION OF
SERVICES 230-086-0004 HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE INDIVIDUALS AS A
CASELOAD OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
WE ARE PUTTING FORWARD REALLY
ARE IN ALIGNMENT TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S VISION
AND HAVING TO COME BACK PLAN
AND FOCUSING ON REALLY THOSE
AREAS IN WHICH WERE ABLE TO
CONSTRUCT THE HEALTH IN THE
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL INEQUITIES
THAT HAVE REALLY BEEN FUELED BY
THE CAN DOWN BACK- AND THAT HAS
BEEN VERY DEVASTATED SO MANY
COMMUNITIES- OF NOTE- AND WHERE
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FOCUS AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO SHARING WITH
YOU TODAY. IS A FOCUS WITH OUR
CHILDREN PARTICULARLY WITH AN
EARLY START RECOVERY CONTINUING
TO DO OF FOCUSED WORK ON-
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY AND
THEN REALLY LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN SUPPORT OUR WORK FORCE THAT
IS HERE IN A CALL TO SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE. I'M
SO FIRST I'D LIKE TO JUST GO-
THE LETTERMAN FOR. ALLEGED THAT
WE FOR. ITEM FIFTH SEVEN. OF
THIS IS A REALLY UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SERVICES AND
DISRUPTED- AT ISSUE THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. WE'VE NOTED AND
WE'VE BEEN TRACKING INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE LEFT THE EARLY START
PROGRAM AND HAVE NOT BEEN
ELIGIBLE FOR LETTERMAN
SERVICES. UNDER A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY AND SO I'LL JUST
MAKE NOTE THAT- BURKE EIGHT IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY CHILDREN
BETWEEN THE AGES OF FIVE AND
TEN. THAT WE HAD. SIX SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND FORTY NINE
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING SERVICES
DURING THAT TIME AT THAT AGE
GROUP. OF NOTE EIGHT POINT 1%
SELF JUST OVER FIVE THOUSAND
CHILDREN EXPERIENCED A GAP
BETWEEN BEING AN EARLY START
AND THEN HAVING TO RETURN TO
LETTERMAN SERVICES. SO IN THIS
GAP- IT IS ALSO NOTED. THAT A
NUMBER OF THESE CHILDREN HAVE A
DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM. SO 75% OF
THE CHILDREN AND EXPERIENCE
THIS GAP- IS OUR CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM- WHEN WE HAD DETERMINES
ELIGIBILITY IS ACTUALLY LOWER
THAN THAT. AND SO WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE'RE HAVING TO BRING KIDS IN
AT A LATER DATE WITH A
DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM. IN WHICH-
THIS PROPOSAL IS ACTUALLY-
PRESENTED TO ADDRESS THIS- ONE
KEY ISSUE. ADDITIONALLY DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AS
OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE OUR
EARLY START IN ROME AND HAS
BEEN DOWN BY TEN PERCENT.
COMPARED TO THE PRIOR YEAR THE
SAME MONTH. THIS DECLINE AS
WE'VE NOTED TO AND WE'VE I'M
SURE THAT WE ARE REALLY FOCUSED
ON BRINGING THE KIDS IN. FROM
BIRTH TO THREE TO THE REYES
ALSO ENTERS FIRST AND SERVICE.
BUT WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT
WE BETWEEN TEN AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN THAT MAY HAVE
ACCESS EARLY START SERVICES IN
THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS. THAT
WOULD NOT THAT HAVE NOT
ACTUALLY ACCESS THESE SERVICES
TO THAT END OUR PROPOSAL IS
PRESENTING- I REQUEST TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A PROVISIONAL
ELIGIBILITY FOR THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS THAT IS DIFFERENT
THAN THE ELIGIBILITY FOR THOSE
THAT ARE CURRENTLY FROM THREE
ON THAT. SO THIS PROVISION
WHICH I'M REMOVED A REQUIREMENT
OF HAVING AN ACTUAL DIAGNOSIS-
OF AN INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY THAT'S
OUTLINED IN THE LATTER MANAK-
BUT IT WOULD STATE THAT THERE
WOULD BE THAT NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE. YOU KNOW TO-
SIGNIFICANT- AREAS OF JUST- OF
DELAYS THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
IDENTIFIED BY THE PHOENICIANS.
SO WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING HOW WE CAN DISRUPT AND
THIS- TREND THAT WE HAVE AS
WELL AS RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC. ADDITIONALLY
ENHANCING THAT ENHANCE-
CASELOAD RATIOS ITEM FIFTY
THREE IS IT THIS IS ONE THAT
WE'RE REALLY REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
WITH OUR DISPARITY FUNDS
PROGRAM IS A REMINDER. ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
EASTERLING ALSO. I INTO THE
SEVEN PROPOSED A REDUCE
CASELOAD RATIO I'M FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LOW AND NO
POS- THEIR PARTICULAR PROJECT-
FOLLOWED PRIMARILY INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE MONOLINGUAL WITH
SPANISH AND CANTONESE. I'M OF
THIS PROJECT THEY HAD FOCUSED
ON TWO HUNDRED CHILDREN AND
DURING THE LAST FOUR YEARS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SEE IT.
OUTCOMES THAT REFLECTS NOT
ONLY- A QUALITATIVE BUT ALSO
QUANTITATIVE SO WHAT IT- THIS
REPRESENTS IS THAT WE DO HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE HIGHER
COVERAGE IS A SERVICE BUT ALSO
THEIR EXPERIENCES HAVE
INCREASED AND- UNDERSTANDING OF
SERVICE SYSTEM AND SATISFACTION
WITH REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES.
FURTHERMORE THIS- PROPOSAL OF
AND SPREADING THIS AND
REPLICATING IT TO ALL TWENTY
ONE REGIONAL CENTERS. GIVES US
A CHANCE TO- REALLY SEE
STATEWIDE WHAT ARE THOSE
MEANINGFUL CHANGES THAT CAN
HAPPEN WITH ON THIS FOCUSED
WORK ON A POPULATION AND THAT-
IS NOT ACCESSING SERVICES- ONE
OF THE OTHER FINDINGS THAT-
EAST LA REGIONAL CENTER HAS
NOTED IS THAT. WE REALLY SAW
THAT FAMILIES BUILD
COMPETENCIES TO BE ABLE TO
NAVIGATE NOT ONLY THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM BUT ALSO GENERIC
RESOURCES BUILDING THERE NOT
ONLY CONFIDENCE BUT THEIR
CONFIDENCE. IN BEING ABLE TO
ADVOCATE AND- ACCESS SERVICES
WHICH WILL HAVE A LIFELONG
IMPACT TO THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCESS SERVICES GOING FORWARD-
THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT WOULD BE ON AN AVERAGE TWO
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS. WITH A ONE
TO FORTY CASELOAD RATIO IT
WOULD ALSO SUPPORT SUPERVISING-
SUPERVISORS TO SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS AS WELL AS TRAINING-
FOR THE REGIONAL CENTER STAFF-
THAT QUESTION HAS BEEN NOTED
WISE THEY'RE NOT. COMPANION.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND AS WE
HAVE NOR HAD BILL LAKE- STATUE
FOR RATIOS- ARE INTENT WAS TO
PUT THIS AND TO PUT IT INTO THE
CONTRACT WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS IT ALLOWS US. TO HAVE
BE NIMBLE THIS YEAR AS WERE
ROLLING IT OUT TO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS SO IF WE- HAVE A NEED
TO BE ABLE TO BE FLEXIBLE IN
THE APPROACH SO WE CAN BE
RESPONSIVE TO UNIQUE REGIONAL
CENTER NEEDS THAT WE CAN DO
THAT. AS I NOTED- EAST LA I
WORKED WITH- TO POPULATIONS
WITH PARTICULAR LANGUAGE-
PREFERENCES ADD EACH REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT
IN THEIR APPROACH AND SO WE
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO- WORK
WITH EACH OTHER REGIONAL
CENTRES. THEN MOVING ON TO
ABSTAINED WITH THE IMPORTANCE
OF WORKING ON SERVICE ABSENCE
IN EQUITY AND ALSO WITH OUR
EARLY START- AND- ABILITY TO
HAVE APPROPRIATE DIAGNOSIS. IS
THAT WE HAVE CONTINUED TO HEAR
FROM OUR COMMUNITY- THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON THE
VALUE OF DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE REALLY BEING AWARE OF OUR
BIASES- AS WE ARE DELIVERING
SERVICES THROUGH THE REGIONAL
CENTER- ON AN AREA IN WHICH I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHILE
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE.
EVERY REGIONAL CENTER STAFF BE
REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING- IT IS REALLY-
OUR FOCUS TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
IN A VERY THOUGHTFUL WAY- AND
PRIORITIZE- THE ELIGIBILITY
ANYBODY WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR-
DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS. FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS. THAT THAT IS WHERE WE
WERE- OUR PHONE- FOR THE FIRST
IMPLEMENTATION- AND WHY IS THAT
AND THAT HAS- CERTAINLY
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT- WITH- BE UNDERSTANDING
BECAUSE SOME STUDIES HAVE
DEFINITELY DEMONSTRATED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- WITHIN
THE HEALTH- SYSTEM. HAVE OFTEN
HAD HARDER TIMES IN ACCESSING
SERVICES AND- BIASES. CAN COME
INTO PLAY INTO THAT IMPACT ON
THERE ARE STUDIES THAT SHOW
THAT ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR-
ARE DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM LATER
THAN THOSE THAT ARE WHITE- SO
BEING ABLE TO- HAD THE FRONT
DOOR OF THE REGIONAL CENTER THE
CLINICIANS AND THOSE. WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLEFOR ELIGIBILITY
THAT WE CAN REALLY SEE IF WE
CAN DISRUPT THIS- CAN I SAY
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN ABSOLUTE
CHANGE IT IS GOING TO BE ONE OF
THE RESOURCES THAT WE WANT TO.
USE TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS OUR
OUR CONTINUED- AREAS OF FOCUS
TO AND- TO JUST WRAP THE
INEQUITIES. OF SERVICES- FOR
THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
SUPPORTS TO OUR COMMUNITY SAID-
HAVE FOUND IT VERY CHALLENGING
TO ACCESS REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES. I'D LIKE TO MOVE NOW
TO- WHERE WE WERE- PROPOSING TO
SUPPORT OUR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS THEY HAD JUST
BEEN ABSOLUTELY AMAZING OVER
THE YEARS CERTAINLY THE
PANDEMIC HAS DEMONSTRATED- THE
TIRELESS WORK OF OUR DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS- I. FOR
THAT AND BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT-
THEIR EFFORT TO REALLY
PROFESSIONAL LIES THIS
WORKFORCE AND ESTABLISHING A
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION- FOR
OUR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS- OUR PROPOSAL IS-
IDENTIFIED AND APPRECIATE THAT-
AGENDA OUTLINING CLEARLY BUT-
THERE'S AN INITIAL INVESTMENT
OF FOUR POINT THREE MILLION.
THAT WOULD BE TO DEVELOP THEIR
FRAMEWORK FOR- THAT TRAINING
AND WE WOULD BE DOING AN R. F.
P. AND- BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT THE PROGRAM IN WHICH-
SERVICE AT THAT DIRECT SERVICE-
PROFESSIONALS WOULD RECEIVE A-
ADDITIONAL- HEY. NOT STATEMENT
BUT IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE AT-
PASSED THROUGH TO THE WAGES OF
THAT DRUG SERVICE PROFESSIONAL
OUR VISION IS THAT W WOULD
HAVE THAT WAY TO FOLLOW THE
DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONAL AND
BE ABLE TO TRACK THAT AS THE
INDIVIDUAL HAS THEIR
CERTIFICATIONS- THAT THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO MOVE FROM PROVIDER
TO PROVIDER. AND NOT LOSE THAT
ONE LAST NOTE THAT WE DO HAVE
IN OUR PROJECTION TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE SERVICE PROVIDER IN
THEIR EFFORT TO GIVE STAFF TIME
TO GO ATTENDED THE TRAINING BY
REIMBURSING THE SERVICE
PROVIDER FOR THE STAFF TIME AS
WELL AS A SLIGHT-
ADMINISTRATIVE- SUPPORT.
ADDITIONALLY BILINGUAL
DIFFERENTIALS FOR DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS- ALLOWING
FOR DIRECT SERVICE%
PROFESSIONALS TO RECIEVE A
STIPEND- AT OUR ASSUMPTION WAS
AT A HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH-
FOR ANY DRUG SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL WHO WOULD BE ABLE
TO PASS A- COMPETENCY- TEST
THIS WOULD INCLUDE- ASL TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DEATH. THE CONCEPT IS REALLY
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
EXPANDING OUR SERVICE CAPACITY
TO SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE- PREFERRED LANGUAGES OR
ARE DEPENDENT ON- STAFF- WHO
ARE SPEAKING A LANGUAGE BUT
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE CULTURE IN
WHICH- IS IMPORTANT TO THEM AND
GETTING INTO THE SERVICES. ON
THAT IT DEFINITELY WE ARE
INTRODUCING AND REQUESTING
SUPPORT FOR- PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVES- AND- THE. GENDER
CORRECTLY NOTES THE FOR YEAR
INVEST INTO THE PROGRAM- WE ARE-
LOOKING TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
REDUCING SERVICE COORDINATOR
RATIOS- SO YOU'LL SEE AN OUT
YEARS TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY THREE. THAT THE FUNDING
INCREASES TO I REQUEST AT
EIGHTY SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF TOTAL FIND- OF WHICH
THIS WOULD HAVE AN ASSUMPTION
OF SUPPORTING APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT HUNDRED SERVICE
COORDINATORS- TO ADDRESS A
SERVICE COORDINATOR- NEED TO-
HAVE ASSURANCES THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO MEET THE VARIOUS NEEDS
WITHIN OUR SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM- WE WOULD BE WORKING
WITH- ARE STAKEHOLDERS IN
DESIGNING IT BUT VERY MUCH
FOCUSED ON ANY INCENTIVE. THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO THE
REGIONAL CENTERS WOULD BE BASED
ON THE FOUNDATIONS THAT ARE-
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE ALREADY
SHARED COMPLIANCE WITH AGE CBS
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY-
CONSUMER SATISFACTION AS WELL
AS- ADVANCING THROUGH SELF
DETERMINATION- AND I. WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY- ANY
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
BIRDMAN- WITH THAT WE WILL
RETURN TO SONYA PADDOCK WITH
THE L. A. L. TO AT HER COMMENTS
ON DDS BEFORE WE RETURN TO THE
DíAS. FOR MEMBERS QUESTIONS
MISS PATRICK. YES YOU YOU MISS
CHAIR AND- YOU KNOW WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE DDS IS ME
REVISION INCLUDES MORE THAN A
DOZEN NEW POLICY PROPOSAL SO
AGAIN WE'RE STILL SORTING
THROUGH- THE AVAILABLE
INFORMATION AT THIS TIME BUT WE
WOULD AGAIN LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME AREAS WHERE THE- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
ALIGNED WITH PREVIOUSLY
EXPRESSED LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES AND SOME AREAS WHERE
THEY DO NOT ALIGN. SO FIRST- AS
DIRECTOR BARGE MEN- INDICATED
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROPOSALS
THAT ADDRESS SERVICE ACT THANK
ACCESS AND EQUITY ISSUES. WE'VE
IDENTIFIED- SIX THOSE ARE
ISSUES. 515-253-5550 SEVEN AND
FIFTY EIGHT THAT HAVE A
COMBINED- BUDGET YOUR COST OF
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND- AND HE'S ALSO
BUILT ON TWO OTHER PROPOSALS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE GOALS OF
THESE PROPOSALS- SEEM TO
REFLECT LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES
AND ACTIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
HAS TAKEN IN THE PAST. TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO SERVICES AND
REDUCE DISPARITIES-
PARTICULARLY ALONG RACIAL AND
ETHNIC LINES- FOR EXAMPLE- IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED FUNDING FOR GRANTS AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO SERVICES AMONG PEOPLE
OF COLOR- AND- I WOULD ALSO
NOTED THAT THIS. PARTICULAR SUB
COMMITTEE OF THE ASSEMBLY.
BUDGET COMMITTEE HAS VOTED TO
RESTORE SOCIAL RECREATION CAMP
SERVICES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN- THESE WERE NOT THESE
ACTIONS WERE NOT APPROVED IN
THE FINAL BUDGET ACTS OF THOSE
YEARS- I MENTION THIS BECAUSE
UNLIKE MOST OTHER SERVICES
SOCIAL RECREATION IN CAMP IT
TENDS TO HAVE- TENDED TO HAVE
HIGHER PER CAPITA EXPENDITURES
AMONG PEOPLE OF COLOR RELATIVE
TO WHITES. SO I WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS IS ONE AREA WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS DO
NOT ALIGN WITH- PREVIOUS- A
LEGISLATIVE. ACTION AND INTENT-
SO IT- REGARDLESS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THESE OTHER PROPOSALS THAT
ARE IN THE MAY REVISION- LEAD
TO IMPROVED ACCESS AND
REDUCTIONS IN DISPARITIES THAT
SEEMS TO REFLECT LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. ANOTHER AREA OF A
OF POTENTIAL ALIGNMENT IS IN
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
DDS PROPOSES SEVERAL ACTIVITIES
TO IMPROVE CONSUMER ONBOARDING
INTO THE PROGRAM INCLUDING
ADDING PARTICIPANTS SPECIALIST
INTENSIVE TRANSITION SUPPORT
SERVICES AND REGIONAL CENTER
TRAINING. I'D NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A POLICY
BILL IN TWENTY THIRTEEN TO
IMPLEMENT THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM SO THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THE PROPOSED
CHANGES. EASE ENROLLMENT AND HE
SAID AND SUCCESSFUL TRANSITIONS
INTO THE PROGRAM THAT WOULD
SEEM IN LINE WITH LEGISLATIVE
INTENT TO MAKE THE PROGRAM
AVAILABLE TO ANY INTERESTED
CONSUMER. I AM FINALLY AREAS OF
ALIGNMENT AND THE ELIMINATION
OF SUSPENSIONS OF SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE INCREASES AND UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE. THERE ARE A
FEW KEY AREAS WHERE- I
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAIN
REVISION THE FIRST I'D MENTION
IS REFORM. THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IN. TWENTY SIXTEEN TO REQUIRE A
RATE STUDY- THIS REPORT I WAS
COMPLETED IN TWENTY NINETEEN IT
IDENTIFIED ISSUES IN THE
CURRENT RATE STRUCTURE MADE
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
HOW TO IMPROVE IT AN ESTIMATED
THAT IT WOULD COST TO THE STATE
AROUND ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT A RATE
REFORM IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
SINCE THEN RATE INCREASES
TOTALING MORE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE
INCREASES TOTALING MORE THAN
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED THAT RATE
RESTRUCTURING AND FULL FUNDING
OF A RATE REFORM HAVE NOT. THE
SECOND AREA WHERE I WOULD NOTE-
THAT SPENDING REVISION DOES NOT
NECESSARILY ALIGNED WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. IS IN
THE AREA OF DIRECTIVES ISSUED
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE DEMOCRATIC BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE STAFF. I HAVE MET
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DISCUSS CODIFYING SOME OF THE
DIRECTIVES ISSUED DURING THE
PANDEMIC SUCH AS VIRTUAL
PROVISION OF EARLY START
SERVICES OR VIRTUAL SERVICE
COORDINATION MEETINGS IN
ADDITION- THE SENATE DEMOCRATS
IN BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE EXPRESSED IT'S-
PRIORITIES TO CODIFY SOME OF
THESE DIRECTIVES ITS ME SIX
HEARING. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
MAY REVISION DOES NOT INCLUDE
ANY PROPOSALS CONCERNING
CODIFICATION OF DIRECTIVES- I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
NOTING- SOME ISSUES THAT OUR
OFFICE HAS IDENTIFIED IN SOME
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT MEET
REVISION. THE FIRST CONCERNS
THE PROPOSED PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVES PROGRAM WHICH WAS
FIRST PROPOSED IN A GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN TWENTY TWENTY- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
LIKELY HAS MERIT IF IT'S DONE
IF IT'S DONE WELL WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF DETAILS OF HOW IT
WOULD WORK JUST YET. HOWEVER WE
DID HAVE CONCERNS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THAT STILL REMAIN SO
UNDER CURRENT CONDITIONS IN THE
SYSTEM ARE NUMEROUS CHALLENGES
STRAIN THE SYSTEM INCLUDING
SERVICE PROVIDER RATE ISSUES.
AND SERVICE COORDINATOR TWO
CONSUMER CASELOAD RATIOS THAT
ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE. WE HAVE
TO WONDER IF THE- PROGRAM WOULD
NOT NECESSARILY HAVE A
FOUNDATION CONDUCIVE TO
SUCCESS. IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS BASED
ON THE REMARKS OF DIRECTOR
BARGE MINIMUM GONNA GO. THAT
FUNDING WOULD BE INCLUDED- IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS WELL THE FIRST
YEAR WOULD BE FOR PLANNING AND
THEN IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS THERE
WOULD BE SOME FUNDING AVAILABLE
FOR- TO HIRE MORE SERVICE
COORDINATORS. IT IS WE WOULD
KNOW THAT IT DOES MAKE SENSE TO
SPEND A YEAR PLANNING- THIS
PROGRAM PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTATION. BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY CLEAR TO US WHY THE
STATE WOULD NECESSARILY HAVE TO
WAIT A YEAR TO FIND MORE
SERVICE COORDINATORS WHEN THIS
IS A CLEARLY IDENTIFIED PROBLEM
IN THE SYSTEM. I'M FINALLY- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ME REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR DDS- THAT MOST
PROPOSALS- EAT AND INCLUDING
THOSE THAT WOULD ADDRESS
SERVICE ACCESS AND EQUITY
ISSUES- MAY HAVE MERIT BUT
LACKS SUFFICIENT DETAIL ABOUT
HOW THE FISCAL ESTIMATE WAS
DERIVED AND WHETHER THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT- AND HOW THE
PROGRAMS WOULD BE HE DESIGNED-
FOR US TO CONDUCT. A FULL
ASSESSMENT NOR IS IT CLEAR TO
US NECESSARILY HOW OUTCOMES
WOULD BE TRACKED AND REPORTED
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISS
PENNOCK WE WILL NOW BRING IT UP
TO THE DíAS FOR MEMBERS
QUESTIONS WE WILL BEGIN WITH A
SIMPLE NUMBER FRAZIER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SKEWS ME.
WHERE DO YOU BEGIN- YOU KNOW
AGAIN ON THE SOCIAL WRECK. AS
YOU KNOW THE RECORDS OF
PROGRAMS- I DID A SURVEY IN MY
DISTRICT AND ASKED ALL THE
RECREATION DEPARTMENT'S IN THE
CITIES IF THEY HAD PROGRAMS OR
OR PAUL ORDER PEOPLE IN PLACE.
TO WORK WITH THE I. D. D.
POPULATION. AND NOT ONE OF MY
CITIES ACTUALLY HAD THE ABILITY
OR ANY PROGRAM FOR ANYBODY WITH
DISABILITIES. NOBODY. SO THIS
IS IMPERATIVE A PROGRAM THAT
NEEDS TO BE FUNDED AGAIN WITH
THE INCLUSION AND ALSO THE
DIVERSITY CAN OCCUR THE SELF
ESTEEM THE DIGNITY THERE
PROVIDES SOCIALIZING I COULD GO
ON AND ON AND ON BUT THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT REALLY DOES NEED
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ADOPTED ANY
WHERE. ELSE IN THE STATE.
COUNTY CITY ANYWHERE ELSE. SO I
WOULD HOPE THAT WE AS A
COMMITTEE- MAKE THAT IMPRESSION
VERY LARGE THEN THIS IS. MORTON
FACET. AND I APPRECIATE ONE OF
THINGS I HAVE TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE. IS THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT- DDS AFFORDED THE
PROVIDERS DURING THE PANDEMIC I
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUTSIDE OF THE
BOX AND- WORK- TO ADAPT TO THE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE THEY SERVE
SO. YOU KNOW KUDOS TO THE
DEPARTMENT ON THAT IT WAS A
GAME CHANGER FOR OUR
POPULATION- THE- THE EARLY
START PROGRAM. TO ME IS JUST
ONE OF THE BEST INVESTMENTS
THAT WE CAN MAKE OUR FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN WHEN THEY ARE
DETERMINED TO HAVE AUTISM UP
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
AMOUNT OF CHILDREN THAT ARE.
PRECLUDED FROM AN I. E. P. OR
LESSENED I E. P. OR THEIR- OR
THEIR- YOU KNOW REGIONAL CENTER
NEEDS JUST WITH US EARLY
INVESTMENT IS SUCH A BUSINESS
MOVE ON TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
AT LEAST DOUBLE DOWN ON THIS
INVESTMENT TO CAPTURES MUCH OF
SUCCESS FOR THESE YOUNG
CHILDREN AS WE CAN. ON IT AND I
EMPLOYER THIS COMMITTEE TO BE
ABLE TO- PUSH THAT OF GOING FOR
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
INVESTMENT WE MAKE IN OUR FIRST
FIVE TWELVE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND LOOK
AT ALL THE GREAT THINGS THAT
HAPPEN WHEN WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
THAT INVESTMENT. THERE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE- THE
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS IN AN
OUTGOING YEAR JUST DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME. AS I AGREE WITH
THE L. A. O. WE HAVE THIS
ABILITY TO DO THE PLANNING BUT
WE WE'VE KNOWN THAT WE'VE BEEN
SHORT THESE. HE'S INDIVIDUALS
FOR A LONG LONG TIME. AND JUST
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
TO BE ABLE TO. ADD THAT
ADDITIONAL A HUNDRED WE'RE AT
NINE HUNDRED AND SOMETHING I
BELIEVE SHORT.RIGHT NOW- BUT
WE'VE WE'VE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO
CATCH UP- IF WE JUST CONTINUE
THIS IS JUST A DISSERVICE TO
THE- INDIVIDUALS THAT WE WANT
TO CARE. FOR TO THE AT LANHAM
ACT. AND ALL YOU KNOW I'LL JUST
QUOTE YOU KNOW OUR CHAIRS OF
CONCERN. I WILL ANIMAX STATE OR
NOT. THAT IS THE QUESTION. AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE PURPOSE OF
THE LETTERMAN ACT IS TO PROVIDE
QUALITY CARE TO THE
INDIVIDUALS. IN THE IDT
COMMUNITY AND ALL PEOPLE
DISABILITIES- YOU KNOW. I JUST
I CAN'T FATHOM WHY WE WOULD
WAIT. YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
IMPERATIVE SPECIALLY IN SUCH A
HUGE BUDGET SURPLUS ARENA OKAY-
NOW THE OTHER THING WAS THE- I
THINK IT WAS THE- I HAVE A
SIMILAR HAVE A BILLS KIND OF
ALIGNED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON CERTIFICATION
TRAINING. I'M HOPING THAT WE
CAN DO MINISTRATION. YEAH AND
MYSELF CAN HOW ARE GOOD
DISCUSSION ABOUT MAKING THE
STATUTORY INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW
OF THE GOAL AND PURPOSE- IF WE
DO NOT PROVIDE THIS WORKFORCE
WITH ADEQUATE TRAINING BECAUSE
OF THE MEDICALLY FRAGILE OR THE
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES OR IN ANY OF
THE OTHER. OBJECTIVES THAT WE
HAVE IN IN THAT WORK FORCE
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
A TURNOVER RATE THAT IS JUST
UNBELIEVABLY HORRIBLE AND I
NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE- HOW
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM AS IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED TO GET INTO THIS
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT TO
CREATE A CURRICULUM. TO CREATE
SOMETHING LIKE A CNA. TO GO
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
FOLKS. I HAVE A CLEAR PATH
FORWARD. IF THEY CHOOSE TO OR
BUT WE HAVE A RETENTION OF
QUALIFIED PEOPLE COMPASSIONATE
PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT BEING IN
THIS WORKSPACE. HELPING THIS
POPULATION- YOU KNOW THAT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS IS VERY IMPORTANT
WE'VE WE'VE KNOWN THAT THERE'S
A HIGH TURNOVER THE PEOPLE THAT
I TALKED TO. IN MY DISTRICT IN
AROUND THE STATE FROM OUR
FRIENDS THE IDT POPULATION SAY
THAT THE CONSISTENCY OF CARE
IS. NOT THERE THE TURNOVER IS
HIGH- YOU CAN MAKE MORE MONEY
FLIPPING BURGERS AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO SAY THAT FLIPPING
BURGERS IS A GREAT PROFESSION
IS A WE WANT TO THE FACT
POPULATION TO ANOTHER WORKFORCE
ALSO. BUT THERE'S GOT TO BE. A
HUGE EFFORT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WORK FORCE IS THERE TO
CARE FOR THE FOLKS AND WE'RE
GOING FORWARD ON THE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM I'VE HAD AN INSPECTION
AND PARTNERED WITH THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS I'VE HAD IN TERMS OF
MY OFFICE IN THE CAPITAL IN THE
DISTRICT FOR YEARS NOW. AND HAS
BEEN AN OUTSTANDING OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH PEOPLE AND LEARN I
LEARNED FROM MY FOLKS TO COME
IN AND HELP ME BE A BETTER
LEGISLATURE IN THIS WORLD ALSO
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO IN THE
WORK FORCE TRAINING. COMPONENT
VIA THIS MAY BE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR YOU KNOW TAX CREDITS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HIRED BY
EMPLOYERS TO GO OUT. AND BE
SUCCESSFUL- I'VE TOURED THE ART
PROGRAMS WHERE THEY HAVE THESE
PROGRAMS AND- AND THE JUST THE
IT JUST HOW PROUD THEY ARE TO
BE ABLE TO BE FUNCTIONING IN
THIS CAPACITY TO HELP. OTHERS
IS SOMETHING BECAUSE THERE. ONE
OF THEM AS DIRECTOR BARS MISSES
SOME OF THE BEST EMPLOYEES I'VE
SEEN IS. LOYALTY ON TIME THEIR
QUALITY OF WORK IS IMPECCABLE-
SO. AND I'LL JUST FINISH WITH
THIS YOU KNOW IT HAS BEEN
MENTIONED THAT WE PAID THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR RATE STUDY.
IT DID COME TO US A FEW YEARS
AGO. WE HAVE BEEN MAKING- SOME
EFFORT TO TRY TO GET THAT
IMPLEMENTED- BUT- SO DO WE HAVE
A COMEBACK PLAN. BECAUSE THAT
COME BACK PLAN WOULD BE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE THIS POPULATION
WITH THIS DEFICIENCY THAT WE
HAVE TO FIND AND SAY HERE WE
ARE NOW WE CAN DO IT- ARE WE
JUST GOING TO COME BACK AND
BASICALLY. GET BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE PRE PANDEMIC THAT'S WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR IS TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT IN POPULATION HAS
ALWAYS BEEN KIND OF THE CUTS OF
REVENUE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ON
THEIR BACKS EVERY YEAR WHEN
I'VE SEEN HISTORICALLY. YOU
KNOW OF FOR THIRTY YEARS FOR
THAT WERE FUNDING. ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS PER
PERSON NOW THAN WE WERE THIRTY
YEARS AGO NOT INCLUDING
INFLATION. AND SO I'M JUST
HOPING THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT IN THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
AND THEN THE PASSION. OF THE
CHAIR AND- SOME MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO THAT WE COME THROUGH FOR
THIS POPULATION SAME. I'M NOT
HAS ENOUGH. YOU DO MATTER AND I
AND WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THIS
THE COME BACK HERE FOR YOU
THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO GIVE
DIRECTOR PARCHMENT A CHANCE TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER'S
COMMENTS BEFORE RETURNING TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO DIRECTOR.
THE SHERIN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER- I'LL I'LL TRY
TO TOUCH SOME OF THE- THE
POINTS THAT THAT YOU MADE AND-
FIRST- WE ARE ALWAYS I'M
INTERESTED IN SUPPORT OF A
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
SEEING HOW TO THINK THROUGH-
ANY OF THE QUESTIONS AND-
CONTINUE TO- OFFERED THAT AS AS
WE HAVE CONVERSATIONS ON THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL AS- ON HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD THROUGH OTHER
INITIATIVES- AS WE GO. I WILL I
WANT TO TOUCH ON THE- THE AREA
OF- SOCIAL RANK YOU HAD NOTED-
AND WHILE IT MAY NOT BE GETTING
TO- EVERY POINT THAT YOU HAD
HAD MADE. WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WE ARE ADVANCING THE
STAFF THAT ARE SUPPORTED TO
INDIVIDUALS- AND ALL SERVICES
THAT ARE PROPOSAL ON I'M
LOOKING AT THE- BILINGUAL PAY
DIFFERENTIAL PROFESSIONAL ICE
IN THE WORK FORCE- BECAUSE WE
DO KNOW THAT MANY OF THE
FAMILIES- ARE USING STAFF THAT
ARE COMING IN TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTS. WELL IT'S NOT PENDING
THE SOCIAL RECREATION ACTIVITY
BUT THERE ARE ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE TIED TO RESPITE OR MAKING
SURE THAT THE SUPPORTS ARE
THERE AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE STAFF THAT ARE
THERE TO HELP- ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHETHER THEY'RE CHILDREN OR
ADULTS AND ENGAGE IN THE
COMMUNITY- THAT THEY ARE
TRAINED AND THAT THEY'RE READY
TO PROVIDE THOSE SUPPORTS. ON
ON THAT DISCUSSION AROUND THE
GRANT PROGRAM OR LOOKING AT HOW
TO AND ENHANCE AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS AS
INTERNS- AND WE'RE SEEING MORE
THAT WERE ABLE TO DO THAT
WITHIN THE STATE AND REALLY
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO.
ADVANCING EMPLOYMENT ONE OF THE
AREAS IN WHICH I'M LOOKING
FORWARD. TO THIS PROPOSAL WITH
THE INVESTMENT IN THE GRAY AXES
THAT AS WE DID WITH A DESPAIR
GRANT WE REALLY FOUND IT AN OP.
TO SEE WHAT'S WORKING SOMETHING
NOW WE CAN GET INNOVATIVE YOU
KNOW AND IT CAN HELP US INFORM-
FUTURE PROPOSALS ARE POLICIES.
ON REALLY HOW TO MAKE THAT
MEANINGFUL CHANGE SO I'M REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
IN ADDITION TO OUR COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS AND THEN-
WITH THE- PARTNERSHIP WITH
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB. USING THIS
TO SEE ARE THERE THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY INNOVATIVE AND BEING
ABLE TO- SEE WHAT WE CAN BUILD
UPON TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
REALLY LOOK AT OF MOVING US
FORWARD ON THE ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES AND HOW WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO RESPOND DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND WE ARE CONTINUING
OUR ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
COMMUNITY- AND SEEING HOW WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT- WE ARE
STILL MEETING THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE- EVERYBODY
IS AT DIFFERENT PHASES AND SO
ARE THEY COUNTIES AS TO HOW
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING BACK INTO
SERVICES- SO AS WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION THIS YEAR- WE DO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE DID DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THAT PROVIDED THE
PROVIDERS AND THEN INDIVIDUALS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO HAVE A
PERSON CENTERED APPROACH TO
ACCESSING SERVICES- THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME MORE TIME IN
CONVERSATION THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
PRIORITIZING- AS WE CONTINUE
TO- RE ENGAGE INTO. ACCESSING
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
CONNECTING PEOPLE BACK TO THOSE
SERVICES- THAT THEY WANT TO
RETURN TO OR IF THEY WANT TO
EXPLORE ALTERNATIVE SERVICES
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE- SO I.
I MAY NOT HAVE TOUCHED ALL YOUR
ITEMS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANYTHING
THAT- MAYBE I DIDN'T TOUCH ON
THAT IS- MISTER CHAIR THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE SURE I
CIRCLE BACK TO. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR WITH THAT WE WILL NOW
GO TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I THINK
ONTO MR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER'S POINT- WE WANT TO
SUPPORT ALL OF THE BILL NUMBER
COMMUNITIES AND IN THIS CASE
THE IDEA OF COMMUNITY BUT AND
THE LAST FOUR YEARS SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THIS COMMITTEE I THINK
THE THEME ACROSS. ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS IS THAT WE'RE NOT
PAYING PROVIDERS- YOU KNOW A
SUSTAINABLE WEIGHT OR IN SOME
CASES A LIVABLE WAGE SO WE-
WANT TO- SUPPORT ALL OF THESE
COMMUNITIES BUT IF WE DON'T PAY
OUR OUR PROVIDERS ENOUGH FOR-
IT'S ONE THING TO TRAIN THEM
BUT IF WE DON'T HAVE LIVABLE
WAGES- BUT TURNOVER HAS BEEN
REALLY REALLY HIGH. IN ALL OF
THE PROGRAMS NOT JUST THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM I HAVE A
BILL FOR FFA'S- TO TRY TO GET
HIM BACK TO A LIVABLE WAGE BY.
YOU KNOW LOOKING FORWARD OR
EVEN NOW ARE WE EVEN
CONSIDERING REINSTATING A LOT
OF THESE- SALARIES THAT WERE
CUT- OR THE PROVIDER- FEES THAT
WERE CUT BUT EVEN MOVING
FORWARD I THINK WHAT I'VE SEEN
IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS THAT
EVERY TIME THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S SOME KIND OF A
BUDGETARY ISSUE. WE ARE QUICK
TO CUT THE PAY OF THE PROVIDERS
AND WE CAN NOT HAVE OUTCOMES-
IF WE KEEP DOING THAT THE
CONTINUITY FORCED SOME OF THE
VULNERABLE PUBLIC POPULATIONS
MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE I'M A
FORMER TEACHER AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT A LOT OF THOSE. THE
STUDENTS THAT I SAW BOUNCED
FROM HOUE TO HOUSE SEARCH IN
THIS CASE IN SOME CASES FROM
SCHOOL TO SCHOOL AND THOSE WERE
THE KIDS THAT I SAW THERE WERE
MORE- FARTHER BEHIND OR HAD A
LOT OF ISSUES. AND THOSE ARE
THE SITUATION I'M PRESENTING
RIGHT NOW WAS BECAUSE THE
FAMILIES WERE MOVING RIGHT SO
THAT THOSE ARE THE REASONS IN
THESE CASES WERE NOT PROVIDING
ENOUGH- SUPPORT FOR THE
PROVIDERS SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO MOVE ON- BECAUSE THEY
ARE TRYING TO JUST FEED THEIR
OWN FAMILIES. ARE TRYING TO
SURVIVE AND SO I AT WHAT POINT
IN AGAIN WE HAVE A- WE'VE SAID
IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN THIS IS
A ONCE IN A. GENERATION
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES COVER RIGHT- YOU
KNOW ALL THE THEME FOR THE
PANDEMIC THAT THEME FOR. FOR
RECOVERY IS GETTING PEOPLE OUT
OF POVERTY GET IN LIFTING
PEOPLE OUT. SO WE CANNOT LIFT
PEOPLE UP OF WE DON'T ALSO LEFT
OF PROVIDERS UP AND TO MR
FRASER'S POINT. YES THE
TRAINING IS REALLY CRITICAL
INCENTIVES ARE CRITICAL SO THAT
THE CONTINUITY FOR ALL OF THESE
POPULATIONS- YOU KNOW CONTINUE
IN SEOUL. SO I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE THAT STATEMENT BUT ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO- THINK ABOUT OR
ARE IS ARE ARE DEPARTMENTS
REALLY THINKING ABOUT RESTORING
SOME OF THOSE THOSE- PROVIDER
WAGES ARE PROVIDER- MONIES. SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT WE'RE REQUESTING
YOU KNOW FROM ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS IN THIS CASE- BUT TO
MR FRASER'S POINT THE IDT
POPULATION AND- YOU KNOW JUST-
OUR FOSTER KIDS ALL OF THOSE.
ARE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
NEEDS CONTINUITY AND IF WE
DON'T PROVIDE THE LIVING WAGES-
TO THOSE PROVIDERS THEN WE'RE
GOING TO LOSE QUALIFIED AND
REALLY TALENTED PROVIDERS ARE
WALKING WANTING TO. PROVIDE
THEIR SERVICES BUT THEY CAN'T
LIVE ON THE WAGES THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING. SOLD A LONG WINDED
BUT- WANTED TO. A MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE THINKING ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MEET MAKE. THE
PROVIDER FEES TO STAY IN A
BALL. NUMBER ONE BUT NUMBER TWO
IS. THE IT BUT THINKING UP THE
BOX. I THINK RIGHT NOW WE JUST
NEED TO THINK YOU KNOW
RATIONALLY AND YOU KNOW- WE
NEED TRAINING WE NEED. NOT
STUFF OUTSIDE THE BOX WE NEED
THINGS THAT ARE REALLY LIKE
BASIC- TO- THE POPULATION BUT
ALSO TOOK TO THE PROVIDERS.
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX IS
LEFT FOR WHEN WE DON'T HAVE ANY
MONEY RIGHT NOW WE DO HAVE
MONEY AND AGAIN WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS A GENERATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY. TO MAKE THIS RIGHT
SO I THINK THAT I'M ASKING AND
REQUESTING THAT BEFORE WE THINK
OUT THE BOX LET'S JUST DO THE
BASIC THINGS FIRST. AND THEN WE
CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT OUTSIDE THE
BOX- IN FROM OUR- I'M THINKING
WE NEED A DEAL- SO ANYWAY AGAIN
LONG WINDED BUT- ARE WE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT STABILIZING A
LOT OF THESE RATES FOR JUST THE
CLASS BUBBLE NUMBER POPULATION
THAT WE'RE SERVING THROUGH THIS
DEPARTMENT- AND TO. CAN WE TALK
ABOUT- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER'S- SUGGESTIONS ABOUT
HOW DO WE ATTRACT AND TRAIN-
NEW PROVIDERS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO- I LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING A LITTLE
BIT MORE CONTEXT- THAT I THINK
MAKE IT TOO- ANSWERING SOME OF
YOUR QUESTION- WE REALLY ARE.
YOU KNOW PUTTING FORWARD A
PROPOSAL WITHIN THE DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONAL TRAINING-
THAT IS IDENTIFYING A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE-
PROVIDING THE TRAINING TO THE
STAFF AND CERTIFICATION
PROVIDING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY PROFESSIONAL LICE. THE
DRUG SERVICE- PROFESSIONALS
THAT- ARE DOING THEIR DAILY
WORK. THEN AGAIN IT'S FOR TWO
THINGS ONE IS TO SUPPORT ALL OF
THEIR GOOD WORK BUT IT ALSO IS
TO ACHIEVE REALLY STRONG
OUTCOMES FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
THEIR SURNAME- ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT I CAN HIGHLIGHT MORE IS
THAT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
TIER LEVEL OUR PROPOSAL IS THIS
TO MEAN. THAT THERE'S A TIER
ONE AND TIER TWO EIGHT TIER
THREE THAT WOULD BE- DESIGNED
TO GO ON TOP OF EXISTING
TRAINING FOR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS I'M ENTITLED TO
THAT UPON COMPLETION OF THAT
THAT THERE WOULD BE A BOY AGED-
ENHANCEMENT FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL
SO ARE SUBSTANCE LOOKING AT A
DOLLAR TO TWO DOLLARS MORE AN
HOUR. THAT THAT STAFF PERSON
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE-
POTENTIALLY FOR EVERY TIER
LEVEL- SO AGAIN WE ARE LOOKING
TO WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITY TO
SAY THAT IS THAT IS THAT KIND
OF THAT CONCEPT I'M GOING TO
AFFECT THE INTEREST AND
MEANINGFUL CHANGE. YOU KNOW TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE
THAT MEANINGFUL WAITS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A CAREER
ADVANCEMENT AND THEN FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE SERVING AND
SUPPORTING THAT THEY GET THE
BENEFIT OF HAVING THAT- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT AS AN EXAMPLE
WE HAD DESIGNED SOME NEW MODELS
OF SERVICE. WHICH WAS REALLY
GREAT WE NEEDED TO DO THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO BUILD IN- RATES TO
SUPPORT- THE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
HIRING- REGISTERED BEHAVIOR
TECHNICIANS. BUT WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
ALL OF THE SERVICES THAT WE
HAVE A WORKFORCE THAT IS ABLE
TO ADVANCE IN THEIR TRAINING
AND SO- WITHOUT- REGARD TO THE
TYPE OF SERVICE SO IF YOU'RE
PROVIDING RESPITE SUPPORT IF
THEY'RE PROVIDING- SUPPORT
THROUGH SUPPORTED LIVING YOU
KNOW THAT THERE'S DIFFERENT
AREAS BUT THERE'S PROFESSIONAL
STAFF PROFESSIONALS THAT- THAT
PROVIDERS CAN HIRE OR OR- THEY
CAN STEP. TO THAT TO YOUR
LEVELS OF. ON THAT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
COVERING THAT PAY DIFFERENTIAL-
FOR SUSTAINABILITY GOING
FORWARD- IF THE I DO WANT TO
JUST MAKE A NOTE BECAUSE I.
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENT ABOUT KIND OF THE
INNOVATION. YOU KNOW I MIGHT- I
I'M ALWAYS LOOKING AT WAYS TO
BE ABLE TO LOOK AND THINK HOW
DO WE GET SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS- BUT THE EXAMPLE
THAT I PROVIDED WAS VERY
SPECIFIC TO THE GRANT PROGRAM
TO ACHIEVE EMPLOYMENT. SO WHILE
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF THESE
OTHER IMPORTANT AREAS I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE STILL
MOVING FORWARD WITH WAYS TO
ADVANCE POLICIES THAT ARE
REALLY GOING TO BE POSITIVE FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE. AND
HELPING INDIVIDUALS BE ABLE TO
HAVE- CONSUMERS- TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THEIR- LIVING WAGE
THEMSELF IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PARALLEL ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS- LASTLY I'LL JUST MAKE
NOTE THAT. AS MISS PEDICAB
NOTED- THAT ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS IS FOR THE EIGHT
POINT TWO PERCENT- GREAT
ADJUSTMENTS- AND THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY THAT THOSE TWO ITEMS
ARE- PROPOSED TO BE SUSPENDED
I'M GOING FORWARD SO THOSE ARE
THE PROPOSALS THAT- WE WERE
ABLE TO MAKE- AND TO PUT
FORWARD TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES AND CONCERNS AND- AND
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
FOLLOWED BY FRAZIER. THANK YOU
SO I DO HAVE A SUGGESTION- FOR
THE PROPOSED ON THE TIERED
SYSTEM AND I DON'T THINK WE
NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL- AS
A TEACHER- WHEN I STARTED
TEACHING- I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE SEEN THE PAY SCALE MODEL
FOR TEACHERS YOU GO BUY IT BY
ROLES IN COLUMNS FIRST. FIRST
COLUMN IS BASICALLY A BRAND NEW
TEACHER FIRST ROW MEANS THE
FIRST YEAR OF TEACHING BUT IT
WAS UP TO US TO ADVANCING
COLUMNS YOU WOULD GET
CONTINUING EDUCATION WHICH
RESULTED IN TRAINING. THAT I
DECIDED THAT I KNEW I WANTED TO
TAKE- BECAUSE THEN I COULD MOVE
DOWN DOT COM THE- COLUMNS IN
THE PAY SCALE AND SOULS. MAINLY
IT'S OPTIONAL BUT IT RESULTED
IN ME BEING ABLE TO EARN MORE
BY THAT RESULT IN THE SCHOOL
GAINING A MORE QUALIFIED
TEACHER BECAUSE MY- TRAINING-
WAS WAS. MORE THAN YOU KNOW
ANYBODY ELSE ON THE EXAMPLE IS
I AM THAT MY T. R. I AM STILL
IN THE LEAVE OF ABSENCE FROM MY
IRA I AM IN COLUMN F. WHICH IS
THE MASTER'S DEGREE PLUS SIXTY
ADDITIONAL ARE CONTINUING
EDUCATION UNITS AND THAT WAS BY
CHOICE I PAID FOR ALL OF IT
MYSELF. BUT THE RESULT FOR ME
WAS THAT I WAS ABLE TO ADVANCE
IN MY SALARY- BUT AGAIN SO IT'S
A WIN WIN IN MY OPINION FOR ALL
I GOT- I WAS ABLE TO INCREASE
MY SALARY. BASED ON WHAT I DID
AND ON THE SCHOOL GOT A BETTER
QUALIFIED AND MORE EDUCATED
TEACHER MORE TRAINED TEACHER
BECAUSE- THAT WAS THE INCENTIVE
AND I AGAIN I DON'T THINK WE
NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL BUT
IF WE CAN. INSTEAD OF TEARS
SYSTEMS THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT
SOMETHING AND THAT. RESPECT IT
WOULD HELP- FAVOR OF FIRST OF
ALL MOTIVATE ARE IN PLACE TO
GET MORE CONTINUING EDUCATION
BUT ALSO THE INCENTIVE IS
GETTING MORE WAGES BY WANTED
TO. ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE I
THINK WE KEEP WANTING TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL THEN YOU
KNOW- I THINK THAT'S PART OF
OUR- ISSUE AS WE ALL. LIVE IN
SEITEL'S HERE AND IF WE IT TOOK
SOME OF GOOD FROM A OTHER- KIND
OF- DEPARTMENTS I THINK WE
WOULD. FIND THAT WERE ALSO-
WANTING THE SAME THING AND I
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO REINVENT
THE WHEEL SO WANTED TO MAKE
THAT COMMENT- IN TERMS OF YOUR-
QUOTE DIED TIERED SYSTEM
BECAUSE I THINK THAT- SELF
MOTIVATION IS. IS ALWAYS. MORE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I THINK
PEOPLE ARE WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING THEY'RE ALREADY
DEDICATED. AND IF THEY WERE
INCENTIVIZED TO GET MORE
EDUCATION I THINK- YOU KNOW WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN A
WORK FOR MORE CONSISTENT WORK
FORCE THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER THANK YOU. CHECK
WOULD YOU MIND IF I CLARIFY ONE
THING SORRY FOR FRAZIER PLEASE
YES- THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO AYE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR AND PUT IN THE CONTEXT TO
NOT REINVENTING THE WHEEL- WE
ARE LOOKING AT OTHER STATES
THIS OTHER WITHIN YOU KNOW
STATE SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE AS WELL- I
FAILED TO NOTE THAT- ACTUALLY
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS
ACTUALLY A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
FOR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS. SO IT WOULD BE
THAT- DATE THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO VOLUNTEER TO ATTEND THIS
ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND IN
RETURN THAT HAVE THAT HIGHER
WAGE- SO WE REALLY DO LOOK
FORWARD TO LOOKING AT OTHER
SYSTEMS BECAUSE LIKE YOU IT'S
RATHER NOT REINVENT SOMETHING
IF THERE'S SOME REALLY GREAT
THINGS THAT WE CAN USE TO BRING
IT TOGETHER SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
DR APARTMENT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE HAD A HEARING I THINK WAS
LAST WEEK- ABOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH- THE- COMPONENT IN OUR
BUDGET. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS GLARINGLY ABSENT AND.
OPERATION WITH THAT AGENCY AND
YOUR AGENCY. TO JUSTICE IN THE
COMPONENT DUALLY DIAGNOSED-
COME- INDIVIDUALS NOW. AND I'M
WONDERING I KNOW YOU. I'M
REALLY PROUD THAT YOU-
PARTNERED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
REAL QUICK REHABILITATION. AND
THROUGH THE PENDANT YOU EVEN-
PARTNER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- IN SERVICES- AND
COLLABORATION WHICH- BUT THIS
IS BEEN. KIND OF A COMPONENT
THAT I'VE SEEN IN MY IMPRESSION
HAS BEEN GLARINGLY ABSENT- AND
VERY AS- SOMEONE. SAYING VERY
SILO. AND WONDERING IF WE CAN-
RESOURCES. AN ECONOMY OF SCALE.
TO BE ABLE I'D IN AND CAPTURE.
OF NOT SO MUCH SIX BUT HOW COME
FOR IN. WHO WHO. WHO ARE IS
OTHER REGIONAL CENTER BUT THEN
HARPER COMPLETELY DISTANCE FROM.
THE ABILITY FOR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE HI IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IT'S
SO FRACTURED. AND COULD YOU SAY.
WHAT IN THE BUDGET IS
ADDRESSING THAT OR IF IT IS
THERE A NEED TO COMBINE. THE
TWO AGENCIES TOLD TO PUT A LINE
ITEM. THAT WOULD ADDRESSES.
THANK YOU SOME OF THEM FRAZIER-
IT HAS BEEN- REMARKABLE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS COUPLE
YEARS- UNDER THE DIRECTION OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND
INTERESTS TO DO CROSS CUTTING
WORK AND MAKE SURE THAT
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES ARE
ARE REALLY LOOKING TO SERVE AND
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
HAVE IN COMMON- SOME REALLY
REALLY STRONG EXAMPLES- YOU-
JUST BEFORE THIS YOU YOU HEARD
SOME OF THAT- REAL POSITIVE
EFFORTS FROM DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES- AND- THE WORK.
UNDER THE TWENTY EIGHTY THREE
WHICH IS FOR THOSE CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE- THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN TOOL AGENCIES THAT HAS BEEN
A REMARKABLE EXAMPLE OF HOW
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT THEN
ALMOST EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT OR
EVEN SOMETIMES I'D ARGUE MORE
IMPORTANT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHERE THIS COLLABORATIVE IS
HAPPENING WHERE YOU HAVE YOUR
COUNTIES AND REGIONAL CENTERS-
AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS EDUCATION
OR PROBATION WORKING TOGETHER
TO. JUST SERVICE SUPPORT THE
SAME CHILD- THAT IS- ONE
EXAMPLE- THAT HAS REALLY BEEN
AN AREA IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
YOU KNOW AS WE CONTINUE AS AN
APARTMENT TO LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
MAKE SURE. THAT WE ARE ALSO
TOUCHING WERE EXPLORING
TOGETHER- WITHIN- YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AS TO WHAT
ARE THOSE COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE- THAT
WERE ADDRESSING IN ORDER
PARTNERING AND ADVANCING AN
EXAMPLE AND WHERE WE WNT TO DO
MORE OF THAT- AND WITH OUR
SISTER DEPARTMENT- DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES WITHIN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. YES REALLY
THOSE CHILDREN WHO HAVE A DUAL
DIAGNOSIS- FOR EXAMPLE THEY HAD
MAY HAVE A DIAGNOSIS OF AN
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY AND
THEN HAVE A CO OCCURRING MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSIS. AND SEEING
THEM THIS IS BAND AID CHALLENGE
FOR MANY YEARS- AND BEING ABLE
TO SEE THE PROPOSAL'S THAT ARE
NOT ONLY WITHIN. SERVICES BUT
OTHER DEPART- I WAS- LOOKING AT
ALL OF THE DIFFERENCE-
PROPOSALS BUT THEN HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND THE
REALLY GREAT LANDS THAT HAD
BEEN A COMMON THREAD- BUT AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE DEPARTMENT.
WE KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR FAN.
YOU KNOW WHO RECEIVE REGIONAL
SAID SERVICE- MANY OF THE ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES FROM. TO
PART. SO WE AS A APART ALSO HOW
THE RISK OF. TO I. WHAT WITH
SERVE. AT BELL OR THOSEAND
POLICIES THAT ARE GOING TO. OUR
PA. AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE A
FORM TO. SO WE CAN BE OGETHER
IT'S A MANY OF THE INITIAL- YOU
KNOW ALWAYS MORE TO BE DONE-
AND KEEPING- THAT IMPORTANT
LANDS OF WORKING IN A PERSON
CENTRED APPROACH- TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ALL AS A SYSTEM YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S- DDS OR OTHER
SYSTEMS. AND SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUAL SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO- PRIORITIZING ON THOSE
EFFORTS. THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE- FOR A FEW
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE I'D FIRST
LIKE TO. START BY THANKING DR
EVR FOR DIRECTOR THE SAME
EXCUSE ME AFTER THE WORK DONE
IN THE OF RE. I'D LIKE TO ****
MICHAEL ON TO THE- AND REALLY
WHAT LIKE TO THANK THE- FOR A
FOCUS ON INCLUSION. AND EQUITY
AS I BELIEVE THAT ITEMS NUMBER.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY THREE FIFTY
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN AND FIFTY
EIGHT. ARE NEEDED FOR US TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS
BUT WAS HOPING TO TAKE INTO
ITEM FIFTY THREE IF I COULD
DIRECTOR. SPECIFICALLY WITHIN
THE AGENDA WE WERE TRYING TO
ASK FOR TRAILER BILL- FOR US
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE REALLY
ASKING FOR. IS AN OUTLINE FOR
REPORTING BACK HOW THIS
INVESTMENT WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS THE TWENTY ONE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS THE ISSUE WITH
PURCHASE OF SERVICES THAT WE'RE
SEEING. FOR MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WAS
HOPING YOU COULD COMMENT ON.
THAT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AS
NOTED WE- WE'RE LOOKING TO.
HAVE THE- WORK THROUGH WITH
THAT REGIONAL CENTER THROUGH
THE CONTRACT HOWEVER IT DOESN'T
TAKE THE- RESPONSIBILITY OF
REPORTING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE STATUS OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND THEN ALSO
THAT THE BENEFITS- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
DO- AND ALREADY IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT ARE
THE STANDARDS THAT WE WOULD BE
LOOKING AT- ON THE ON SET. UP
THE DELIVERY OF THE ENHANCE
CASELOAD BUT THEN ALSO AS
INDIVIDUALS FINISHED- WORKING
WITH THEIR- SERVICE COORDINATOR
IN THIS CASE LOAD SO WE WOULD
HAVE A PRE AND A POST AND HAVE
STANDARD MEASURES ACROSS THE
STATE- WE HAVE- A NUMBER OF
AREAS IN WHICH- WE REPORT TO
THE- THROUGH THE OUR QUARTERLY
BRIEFINGS WITH LET'S STAFF. AND
I WOULD SEE THIS IS A REALLY
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
UPDATES ON HOW AND WHERE WE ARE
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION YOU KNOW
IN IDENTIFYING THE MEASURES TO
WEAR REGIONAL CENTERS ARE BY
REGIONAL CENTER IN IMPLEMENTING
IT AND- MONITORING THE PROGRESS
ON BOTH ON IMPLEMENTATION AND
THEN- ON THE- TAIL END OF IT.
I'M SO HAPPY TO HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS IS TO THE
APPROACH OF HOW TO- MEMORIALIZE
THAT- WITH THIS COMMITTEE. I
WILL SAY SEND IT HAS BEEN PRIME
FOR THE COMMITTEE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN AND NINE
FOR TO FOCUS ON. SOCIAL CAN
WRECKED I WOULD IN. AND TWENTY
TWENTY THAT WERE ALSO GOING TO
LEAN IN. AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN PROVIDE THESE SERVICES THAT
ARE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
RELYING UPON FOR- THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SERVICE
FOR OUR FAMILIES. WOULD LIKE TO
NOW TURN TO ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN. AND REALLY WASN'T
CURRENT FIVE THIS PROPOSAL AND
BELIEVE AGAIN IT'S ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ATTEMPTING TO
GET UPSTREAM OF MANY PROBLEMS
AND IDENTIFY. THOSE WHO NEED
RESOURCES BUT WAS HOPING YOU
COULD COMMENT ON HOW THIS HELPS
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM
SPECTRUM DISORDERS. IN UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
SPECIFICALLY. AND I AM. MISTER
CHAIR THAT I'M. JUST SOMEHOW
LAW CONNECT ON MY CAN YOU
REMIND THAT ITEM COULD SEVEN
IT'S LAND FOR AN ACT ALLEGE.
FOR THE REGIONAL. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- YES SO IT NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WE- DO THAT WE ARE.
MON IS BY SO. WE ARE TO AS WE
TOOK ALL AT THE DETAIL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD LEFT- EARLY
START AND THEN RETURNS TO
LETTERMAN SERVICES THAT THAT'S
HOW WE HAD IDENTIFIED. A NEED
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND THEN
AS I SAID- THE PANDEMIC
DEFINITELY- INCREASED THE
URGENCY AND IN ADDRESSING THAT
HAVING A PROPOSAL TO- ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE- SO WE HAVE THE
ABILITY WE ALREADY HAVE DATA-
BASED ON ETHNICITY AND THEN
ALSO LANGUAGE- BY REGIONAL
CENTER SO WE CAN TRACK- THAT
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS- THAT.
ARE LEAVING EARLY START AND
THAT HAVE RETURNED BUT WE CAN
ALSO START TRACKING ON THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS NEW
PROVISION- BY ETHNICITY BY
REGIONAL CENTER AND THEN ALSO
COMPARE THAT TO BOTH EARLY
START. AND LETTERMAN SERVICES-
I WOULD ALSO ANTICIPATE THAT
THIS WOULD BE A MEASURE- THAT
WE COULD WOULD WANT TO USE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AT LOOKING AT
PERFORMANCE MEASURES FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL. TO BE
ABLE TO TRACK- SERVICE ACCESS
AND EQUITY- AND- MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO BRING IN
KIDS- FROM DIFFERENT ETHNIC.
GROUPS THAT ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED. THANK YOU.
I'M AND SO MY QUESTIONS-
WANTING TO A THE RATE STUDY
REALLY WANTING TO ENGAGE WITH
YOU. TO BETTER ON- WHAT WHAT I
FEEL WAS ONE IF NOT BE MY
GLARING TO WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED. REGARDING
OUR INABILITY TO MEET THE NEEDS
OR RECOMMENDATIONS OF THIS RATE
STUDY INSULTS WANTED UNDERSTAND.
FROM YOU WHETHER OR NOT THERE.
SOMETHING WITH THE RATES TO OR
WHEN WE WERE PLANNING TO FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH SOME THE RECORD.
AS IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE RATE STUDY HELPS US TO
ACHIEVE THE LAND FROM AN ACT AS
IT'S DEFINED IN STATUTE AND
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSTAND FROM
YOU DIRECTOR HOW YOU. RECTIFY
THAT. THANK YOU AND WE HAD-
THAT. WITH THE RATE STUDY THE
RATE MODEL- WORD. AS A RESULT
OF THE STUDY. AB HELPED INFORM
A- OF. OVER THE SEVERAL YEARS-
YEAH I AS WE LOOK AT EVEN THE
AMPLE. OF THE EIGHT POINT 2%
THAT HELPED INFORM AND THEN WE
HAD ALSO USED THE RATE STUDY IN
RATE MODELS- TO REALLY AMP OUR
TIER PROPOSAL FOR THE DRUG
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS- WE
CONTINUE TO- MAY BE OPEN TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS AS WORK
HAD BEEN ENGAGING OUR
STAKEHOLDERS RIGHT NOW. ON HOW
DO WE MOVE FORWARD AND-
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES AND WHAT
DOES ALTERNATIVE SERVICES LOOK
LIKE AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ON
PERSON CENTERED APPROACHES AND
THEN ANY INTERSECTION THAT
WOULD HAVE TO DO WITH-
REIMBURSEMENTS- SO AT THIS TIME
THE PROPOSALS THAT- WE PUT
FORWARD OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS HAVE BEEN INFORMED BY THE
RATE STUDY BUT WE HAVE NOT- PUT
A PROPOSAL IN- FOR-
IMPLEMENTATION. FULL
IMPLEMENTATION. OR WOULD YOU
ECHO ENOUGH THE OF MANY PEOPLE
ON THE DIE HERE FOR NOT TO NEED
TO REINVENT THE WHEEL. OR TO
THANK OUTSIDE OF THE BALL BUT
TO TOWARD. WHAT WE FOR ASISTIR
IN THIS RATES TO AND LOW TO THE
RECOMMENDED THAT THEY MADE
WITHIN A- AS A REAL MAP. US AS
A STATE TO BE PER. WITH THAT I
DO LOOK FOR TO THOSE CAN KERR.
WITH THE A PART AND AGAIN THAT
YOUR- FOCUSED ON EFFORTS ON
INCLUDES AND THAT. WITH WE WILL
THANKS FOR MUCH PANEL TO AND WE
WILL ON A PANEL THREE WHICH IS
ON THE- OF AGING IN MAY. UP WE
WILL HAVE TO. AND DIRECTOR
MCCOY WAY. FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGE AND- BUT ALSO WITH THE
LID. ANALYST'S ON. DIRECTOR WAY
CAN PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THE UP. TO HIM BALLPARK. TO
SUPPORT IN A OLDER ADULTS AND
THE A INTO. SERVICES THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGE. IS OLD
ADULTS AND OUR SERVICE NETWORK
BACK FOR THE DEFICIT PANDA. AND
IS TO GET WE IN BY PLAN AGING
AND BUILD A CALIFORNIA ALL A.
TODAY ALL PRESENT VERY. ON THE-
TARGETED. AT THE OF A- TO
ADDRESS. THAT BECAME MORE SO
DURING THE PAN- TALKING WILL BE
THAT'S- DURING THE PAST
FOURTEEN. AND- OVERALL SUPPORT
OLDER AND FOR. LIVING IN THE
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES. OF THEIR
CHOICE. THEREFORE ISSUES WHICH
OPERATES SUMMARIZE AND ONE
QUESTION WHICH ALL OF. ISSUE
SEVENTY ABOUT HOW OR WE CALL
THE- COMMUNITY BASED ON SERVICE.
THIS IS A WORK PROPOSAL WE ARE
ALL SORT OF OVER. HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE. EITHER SERVING THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND CLIENTS AND THIS
PROPOSAL OF ONE EIGHT FIVE AND
TWENTY ONE TWO. AND TWO POINT
ONE EIGHT ON GOING. WOULD ALLOW
US TO. MEET THE GROWING TO BE
ABLE A AND THIRTY TWO APPLES
BEFORE US RIGHT NOW. WITH MORE
PROVIDERS TO SERVE A MARKET
MORE PEOPLE. THE SECOND ISSUE
IS- I TO TRY FROM. GIVEN THAT
URGENCY OF THE ISSUE. A
SPECIFICALLY THIS IS ABOUT HOW
FOR EXPAND. TO OLDER ADULTS THE
WORK OUR AGING. TO REACH OLDER.
ON THE IS A PARTNER WITH THE-
OF SERVICES. TO DOLLAR ON GO.
INTO THE WORK BEGAN WITH THE
EMBLEM. OF CAL EXPAND. TO
PARTICULARLY TARA OLDER AND
JUST. ARE S. TO ALSO CALFRESH.
OUR THIRD PRO COMPOSED IS
PERHAPS. IS THE LAW IN THE COME.
IT IS A NEW WALDRON. IN BRAZIL
PASS. THAT HAS NOT TO AREA- TO
INVESTMENT PROPOSED. A HUNDRED
AND SIX MY OVER THREE. A
HUNDRED FOR OUR NETWORK WITH
TEMPER OF FOR OTHER NEEDS
CAPACITY. ADMINISTRATION IN.
I'M GOING TO SECOND JUST LISTA
NINE OUT PURPOSES BIG THEY ARE
ALL IMPORTANT. PARTS OF HER AND
COMMUNITY. UNDER TRISH OUR
MEALS PRO THAT. AND CAN CENTERS
WERE ARE SLOWLY REOPENED. LEGAL
SERVICES WHICH HELPS WITH. FROM
PREVENTING EVICTION. TO OFFER
ON IN ADMITTED AGAINST THEM IN
EVERYTHING ELSE IN BETWEEN.
FALTERED AND OUT OF. FALLS OR
OF INTO BECAUSE OF DEATH FOR
OLDER. DIGITAL CONNECTION ARE
SO MUCH OF TO CLOSE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. MORE THAN TWO OLDER AND-
ARE UNDER CONNECTED AROUND CAN
IN THE THAT CAN FOR. AND- AND
SO. CONNECT SENIOR UP. MAY
SENIOR BOTH NEED TO WORKING
STORE. I TO FORTY AGING. AGING
RE CONNECTS ARE AS WE KNOW THEM
NUMBER ON. SYSTEM THE PUBLIC
CAN FOR IN FOR ABOUT JUST.
BEHAVIORAL FRIENDSHIP LINE
WHICH CAN TO RECEIVE HER OF
TODAY. AFTER OLDER ADULTS I
FEEL A LITTLE LONG LOOKING FOR
CHAT I A FRIENDLY PERSON TO
TALK WITH THEM. FAMILY CARE
SUPPORT THEM CARE GIVER HAVE.
BORN IN BURDEN THE PAST YEAR
KAREN LOVED ONES AT HOME AND
LOOK TO INCREASE THE SUPPORT.
IN A NEW STATE ELDER ABUSE. K.
WHICH- WAS CALLED FOR IN ABOUT
PLAN AGING TO. A THE- AND STATE
ALL THAT WE'RE DOING. ON ABUSE
NEGLECT EXPLAINED AND FRAUD.
INFORMATION AND SERVICES. FIVE
OKAY THE GENERAL PROCEDURE THE
QUESTION WHICH IS ABOUT THAT
PACKAGE OF OLDER ADULTS
RECOVERY RESILIENCY AND ASKING
HOW DOES NOT ADDRESS THE NEED
AND WHAT NEEDS MIGHT REMAIN I
THOUGHT I JUST GIVE A COUPLE
EXAMPLES OF WHERE CURRENT
SERVICES OR WHAT THE OPPOSE
FUNDING WOULD DO AND WHAT GAPS
MIGHT REMAIN BASED ON OUTCOME
DATA IN THE DATA WE HAVE.
PARTICULARLY FROM THE NEW DATA
DASHBOARD FOR AGING FOR THE
MASTER PLAN SO OLDER ADULT
MALES. HOELTZEL WOULD PROVIDE
ONE TIME FUND OF UP TWENTY
POINT SEVEN MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS. ON TOP OF THE REMOVAL OF
SUSPENSIONS ON ONGOING
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE. WE'RE
COMING OFF OF AN AIRCRAFT STILL
IN A RECORD SETTING. PACE OF
OUR NETWORK SERVING MEALS
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION MEALS WERE
SERVED IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND
ALL THROUGH LAST WEEK WE HAD
ELEVEN MILLION MEALS COMING
THROUGH OUR NETWORK IN THIS
YEAR. OF THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDS
DEPENDING ON HOW IT'S ALLOCATED
COULD- REACH AS MANY AS ONE
POINT NINE MILLION ADDITIONAL
MEALS. IN PART WHY I'M HEDGING
ON THAT EXACT NUMBER IS SOME
MAY BE USED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
AS THE NETWORK NEEDS TO
ADDRESS- FREEZERS AND COOLERS
AND OTHER CAPACITY NEEDS OF TO
MEET THESE RECORD SETTING
NUMBERS. AND ALSO THE SYSTEM IS
ALWAYS INFORMED BY THE MIX OF
HOME AND PONDERED AT HOME IN
COMMUNITY SETTINGS AND THAT'S
IN FLUX WE EXPECT SOME
COMMUNITY SETTINGS TO AND WE
KNOW FROM OUR SURVEYS OF OUR
NETWORK THIS SUMMER COMING BACK
IN PERSON. BUT THAT'S THAT'S IN
FLUX STILL AS MANY AND MOST IN
FACT REMAIN HOME BASED. ALSO
THERE'S- AND AGAIN SO WHAT'S
THE NEED WE LOOK AT OUR
STUDENTS SECURITY RATES OLDER
ADULTS. IN CALIFORNIA 30% FOOD
AND SECURITY RIGHT. THAT'S
EIGHT HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS REPORT
FOOD SECURITY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
EVEN HIGHER RATES AND BLACK
ELDERS A NATIVE AMERICAN
ELDERS. SO WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO EVEN WITH THAT
COMBINATION OF HOME MEALS AND
CALFRESH OUTREACH AND SO MUCH
MORE TO REDUCE FOOD INSECURITY.
IN OLDER ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA.
TWO OTHER QUICK EXAMPLES- THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE WITH FEDERAL FUNDS WE
WERE ABLE TO BEGIN THIS
INITIATIVE. ARE WE WERE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE- THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS WE DISTRIBUTE
FOUR THOUSAND DEVICES TO OLDER
ADULTS WITH TWO YEARS OF
BROADBAND IN TECH SUPPORT. WE
ALSO HAD EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
DONATED GOOGLE SMART SPEAKERS
THAT WE DISTRIBUTED WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION WE
ANTICIPATE THAT WE'LL BE ABLE.
TO DISTRIBUTE TEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL DEVICES AGAIN
WITHOUT. TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
BROADBAND WRAPPED IN A BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO. JUST MILLION
DOLLAR INITIATIVE UNDER CLASSES.
BUT ONLINE AND FOR TO HELP
PEOPLE OUT USE THAT. NO WAY IS
MEETING TO THEM. AND WE KNOW
AGAIN THE DIGITAL BY- IS THE
STRONGEST FOR OLDEST DAUGHTERS
THE WIDEST FOR OLDER ADULTS.
OUR NETWORK REPORTED THAT THE
CIRCUIT DE TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE
OUR COMMUNITY CENTERS WHO ARE
NOT CONNECTED TO WOULD LIKE TO
BE CONNECTED. AND RESEARCH ALL
THE UC SYSTEM SHOWS MORE THAN
TWO MILLION- OF THE EIGHT
MILLION OLDER ADULTS ARE UNDER
EVER AND CONNECTED. AND LASTLY
JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON FALLS
PREVENTION. YEAH THERE'S A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ON GOING. THAT
IS ALLOWING US TO SERVE ABOUT
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE WITH
VERY ESSENTIAL HOME
MODIFICATIONS GRAB BARS RAMPS
ETCETERA TO PREVENT THOSE FALLS
THAT CAN BE TO DEATH OR A
SERIOUS DECLINE OR MOVE TO MORE
INTENSIVE CARE. THE NEW FUNDING
WOULD GET US TO ABOUT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE. ARE WHICH IS
TERRIFIC- BUT AGAIN WE KNOW
THAT. FALLS ARE THE LEADING
CAUSE OF INJURY RELATED DEATH.
ABOUT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED ADULTS
IN CALIFORNIA DIE FROM FALLS-
AND- WE WANT TO OBVIOUSLY GET
TO THOSE WHO AWESOME SERIOUS
INJURIES AS WELL SO MORE TO BE
DONE TO REDUCE SERVICE. THOSE
ARE JUST THREE EXAMPLES I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROPOSALS
OR ANYTHING ELSE. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR WITHOUT A WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE DíAS. TO SEE IF
ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS. C.
NONE- FOR I'D LIKE TO SAY HOUSE
STAGGERING IT WAS TO HEAR. THE
FOOD AND SECURITY IN OUR OLDER
ADULTS WITH EIGHT HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN THOUSAND. OLDER ADULTS
WHO ARE SUFFERING WITH THIS AND
SECURITY AND WANTS TO MAKE SURE
TO THANK YOUR ENTIRE DEPARTMENT
FOR ALL THE EFFORT. THAT YOU'VE
DONE THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC TO
HELP TO DELIVER. HOT MEALS TO.
THOSE WHO HAVE NEEDS THAT HAVE
NOT GONE UNNOTICED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE AND JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU FEEL THAT
APPRECIATION. IT WAS A HUGE
LEFT FOR YOUR DEPARTMENTS TO
UNDERTAKE AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU. UNDERSTAND THAT- WE REALLY
DO APPRECIATE ALL YOUR EFFORTS
DIRECTOR- DID WANTS TO GO INTO
YOUR MASTER PLAN OF AGING AND-
STATISTICALLY WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT ETFS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE MASTER
PLAN. ON AGING WAS TO LOWER THE
AGE OF- APS FROM SIXTY FIVE TO
SIXTY. IN AN EFFORT FOR US TO.
BETTER ADDRESS THE ABUSE
NEGLECT AND FRAUD THAT ARE
OLDER ADULTS ARE GOING THROUGH
SO I'M- WONDERING IF YOU COULD
COMMENT WHY- WITHIN THIS BUDGET
WE DID NOT DECREASE THE AGE OF
APS FROM SIXTY FIVE TO SIXTY.
FOUR FOLLOW SPECIFIC A APS
QUESTIONS I WOULD DEFER TO
DIRECTOR JOHNSON DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES WENT THAT
HOUSES A PS BUT I CAN'T OF FROM
THAT THAT IS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT CAME IN FROM
STAKEHOLDERS- DURING THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING PROCESS AND THAT
IT IS SOMETHING WE ANTICIPATE
THE NEW ELDER JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL. ON TAKING
INTO RUBIO. I'M I'M HAPPY TO
ECHO THE QUESTION TO HER BUT- I
THINK SINCE IT STARTED WITH THE
MASTER PLAN OF AGING I'M JUST.
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THERE'S THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT- IT SHOULD BE
OBVIOUS BY NOW I HAVE AN
INTEREST IN TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE EXTEND THESE
SERVICES AND AGAIN GET.
UPSTREAM OF MANY PROBLEMS THAT
WILL OCCUR LATER ON IN LIFE
ANYWAY SO. REALLY BELIEVE IT'S
ADVANTAGEOUS FOR US AS A STATE
TO MOVE THAT AGE DOWN TO
SIXTEEN AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. WITH THAT
IN IN LIGHT OF THE HOUR THAT IT
IS I WILL HOLD THIS PANEL I
WILL THANK THIS PANEL FOR ITS
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL MOVE
ON TO PANEL FOR. WHICH IS ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT WE
WILL HAVE TO PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL. FIRST WE WILL HAVE DAVID
SCRIBNER WHO IS THE ACTING
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF COUNSEL FOR.
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT AS
WELL AS ANGELES SHORT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
CAN WE PLEASE BEGAN WITH
DIRECTOR SCRIBNER. THANK YOU
MISTER STARING FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS A TRAILER
BILL BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSALS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT. I HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE OF THE TOP FOR
SOUNDING LIKE A BILLY GOAT
ROUGH BUT MY ALLERGIES ARE
KICKING UP AND EVERY TIME THE
WIND BLOWS LIKE THROW JUST GETS
DESTROYED SO I WILL MAKE IT
THROUGH- BUT IT IT. I DO SOUND
LIKE I AM DISEASE BUT IT'S JUST
ALLERGIES. THE FIRST DVL
CENTERS ON LOW INCOME. HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR
LIHEAP WHICH HELPS LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS PAY THEIR UTILITY
BILLS AND ALSO PROVIDES
WEATHER'S ATION SERVICES. YES
HE IS SEEKING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO EFFECTUATE THE
BETTER UTILIZATION OF
SUPPLEMENTAL LIKE HE FUNDING
APPROPRIATED UNDER THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE SIGNS WILL BE USED TO
ADDRESS ENERGY UTILITY A
RESURGENCE ACCRUED BY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. DUE TO THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED AND THREE
MILLION IN PARKS SUPPLEMENTAL
LIGHT HE FUNDING. AND THAT'S
FUNNY AUGMENT CSP'S REGULAR
LIFE ANNUAL FUNDING IT IS
INTENDED TO BE ADMINISTERED
LIKE LIKE HE- JUST ON AN
EMERGENCY BASIS TO AID THOSE IN
NEED. AS A RESULT OF THE COMING
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I COULD NOT
MAKE IMPACTS OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OF LEAD TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ACCRUING
HISTORIC LEVELS OF ENERGY THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION DATA THROUGH MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT OVER
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS R. B. HOLT
BEHIND ON THEIR ENERGY BILLS.
WITH A TOTAL RICH OF OVER SIX
HUNDRED MILLION. AND WITH MANY
POTENTIALLY AT RISK OF LOSING
ENERGY UTILITY SYSTEM SERVICES
DUE TO NON PAYMENT. THE
PROPOSAL I HE TPL WILL ALLOW
CST TO SUSPEND SPECIFIED CODE
SECTIONS IN ORDER TO DEVOTE A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
SUPPLEMENTAL LIGHT HEAT FUNDING
APPROPRIATED UNDER OUR- I
FINANCIAL SYSTEMS PAYMENTS FOR
HOME ENERGY. AND HELP LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS MANAGE THE
REPAYMENT OF HISTORICALLY HIGH
ENERGY BILL REVISIONS. UNDER
THE GOVERNMENT COAT. CST IS
REQUIRED TO ALLOCATE SPECIFIED
PERCENTAGES OF LIFE FUNDING
TOWARDS VARIOUS PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES. INCLUDING UP 225%
FOR WEATHER IS ASIAN SERVICE.
THE PROPOSED TBL AGAINST CSKA
THE FLEXIBILITY TO ESTABLISH
PERCENTAGES THAT WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO UTILITY ASSISTANCE
AND WEATHERIZATION. TO BEST
MEET THE NEEDS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. THIS TBL MIRRORS
A SIMILAR WAIVER GRANTED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND DASH SEVENTY FIVE
DASH TWENTY. I TO THE FORTY
NINE POINT FIVE MILLION IN
SUPPLEMENTAL WHY HE FUNDING CST
RECEIVED UNDER THE CARE THAT.
THE NEXT TV DON'T DEALS WITH A
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THE
PROPOSAL AMENDMENTS GIVE SHE
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO ADMINISTER
THE NEWLY CREATED FEDERAL LOW
INCOME WATER SYSTEMS PROGRAM.
THIS NEW PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE
ONE TIME FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH THE
LOWEST INCOMES. THAT PAY A HIGH
PROPORTION OF HOUSEHOLD INCOME
FOR DRINKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER SERVICES. NATIONWIDE
CONGRESS APPROPRIATED A TOTAL
OF ONE POINT THREE BILLION FOR
FEDERAL WATER SYSTEM FROM THE
FEDERAL WATER SYSTEMS PROGRAM.
BUT WHILE NO OFFICIAL GRANT
FIGURES HAVE BEEN RELEASED BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. CST ESTIMATES
CALIFORNIA PREPARATION TO BE IN
THE RANGE OF EIGHTY TO NINETY
MILLION. ACCORDINGLY FINANCES
PUT PLACE HOLDER IN THE BUDGET
FOR NINETY MILLION. US
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AS A VICE STATES THAT
THE LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
SYSTEMS PROGRAM WILL CLOSELY
FOLLOW STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
GUIDELINES ESTABLISHED FOR
LIGHT. IN RESPONSE GOVERNOR%
SOME IDENTIFIED CST IS THE
DESIGNATED AGENCY TO ADMINISTER
THE LOW INCOME HOME WATER HOLD
WATER ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA. THE FINAL PROGRAM
DESIGNER REQUIREMENTS HAVE YET
TO BE RELEASED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES BUT YES HE IS INFORMED
IT WILL BE BASED IN LARGE PART
ONLINE HE- AS WELL TIMELINE FOR
EXPENDITURES HAVE NOT BEEN
IDENTIFIED. CST IS AWARE THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
DIRECTS ONE BILLION TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO ADDRESS
WATER REGIONS WHICH WILL IMPACT
THOSE OR YOU'RE JUST ON A MUCH
LARGER SCALE THE WHITEWATER.
WELL I WANT AND THE STATE WATER
SO THE SYSTEM SHARE THE COMMON
OBJECTIVE OF EXTENDING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO LOWER
THE FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS. BOTH
PROGRAMS WILL ACHIEVE THIS GOAL
IN VERY DIFFERENT WAYS. WHAT C.
S. B. WAS DESIGNATED AS THE
STATE AGENCY TO ADMINISTER THE
FEDERAL WATER PROGRAM CST THE
STATE WATER BOARD AND THE CQC.
BEGAN TO COORDINATE AND DEVELOP
A PROGRAM DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGY. HIS
INITIAL MEETINGS TOOK PLACE
PRIOR TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SIGNALING ITS INTENT TO
MODELADO UP CLOSE WE WOULD LIKE.
FROM SUCH WHAT WAS NEED WILL
NEED TO BE ADMINISTERED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN A ONE CUSTOMER
ONE APPLICATION APPROACH
SIMILAR TO LIFE HE- OUREARLY
DISCUSSIONS SURROUNDING A STATE
WATER PROGRAM DESIGNED SENATE
ON A MORE MACRO LEVEL RESPONSE
BY WORKING DIRECTLY WITH WATER
UTILITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN CSU WILL CONTINUE RECORDING
WHY WHAT DEVELOPMENT WITH THE
STATE WATER BOARD AND THE CQC
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE. EVEN
PROGRAM LIMITATIONS INHERENT IN
UTILIZING THE LIE HE FRAMEWORK
FOR SERVICE DELIVERY. THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE ALSO
INCLUDES A BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
CSK TO ADMINISTER THE NEWLY
CREATED CALIFORNIA RESEARCH
PAYMENT PROGRAM. A PROPOSED ONE
BILLION FROM THE STATE'S ART
ALLOCATION WILL BE USED TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA REPAIR
PROGRAM OR CAP. OFFERING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO PREVENT
ENERGY UTILITY DISCONNECTIONS
APPEARANCES FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS EXPERIENCING
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS RELATED TO
THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED OVER ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION I OWE YOU
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE
BEHIND ON THEIR ENERGY BILLS
ONLY ROUGHLY SIX HUNDRED. THESE
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE
POTENTIALLY AT RISK OF LOSING
ENERGY UTILITY SERVICES WHEN I
OWE YOU MORE TOWARDS PREVENTING
DISCONNECTION FOR NON PAYMENT
ARE LIFTED OR RESCINDED. CST
SERVERS SKINNER CST PRESUMES
SIMILAR TRENDS WITH ACCUMULATED
ENERGY UTILITY DEBT AND PAYMENT
DELINQUENCY EXIST WITHIN NOT
REGULATED UTILITY COMPANY
SERVICE AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BASED ON THIS ASSUMPTION.
ESTIMATES THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
ENERGY UTILITY CUSTOMERS IN
ARREARS THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
BE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER WHAT IS
BEEN REFLECTED IN CPC SPECIFIC
REPORTING. CAP WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY CST A LEVERAGE
THE EXISTING LINE MECHANISMS
FOR PROVIDING FINANCIAL ENERGY
ASSISTANCE. CAP IS DESIGNED TO
MOBILIZE A STRONGER STATE
RESPONSE THE STATE ENERGY BURST
THE TO THE ENERGY UTILITY DEBT
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS ARE
CARRYING. I WILL EXPEDITE THE
DELIVERY OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO THESE CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS BY WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH YOU ENERGY UNTIL THESE TO
IDENTIFY AND CREDIT ACCOUNTS OF
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS
PRIORITIZED FOR KAPPA SYSTEMS.
BY USING THIS METHOD WOULD. CAP
BENEFITS CAN BE DELIVERED TO A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THE LIKE
WHAT LONG TERM CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS VIA SINGLE PAYMENT
TRANSACTION. IT IS ANTICIPATED
THAT THE MAJORITY OF WELCOME
CUSTOMER BENEFICIARIES WILL NOT
NEED TO APPLY FOR ASSISTANCE.
FOR CUSTOMERS IN AREAS WHERE
UTILITIES ELECTED NOT TO
ADMINISTER TACKLE SYSTEMS
DIRECTLY. CSP PLANTS ARE
PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
OUTREACH AND ENROLLMENT
SERVICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SIMILAR TO WHY HE- GOAL THE
PROGRAM IS THE EIGHT THE
MAJORITY OF LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS FACING ORIGINS AND
HOW QUICKLY THIS FINANCIAL
SYSTEM REACHES. OF MOBILE HELP
CALIFORNIANS WILL ULTIMATELY
DEPEND ON HOW SUCCESSFUL THE
STATE AND ENERGY UTILITIES CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO EXPEDITE THE
DELIVERY OF BENEFITS. CST IS
CONFIDENT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WILL BE ABLE TO LOOK DELIVER
THIS RELIEF OFFICIALLY AND
EFFECTIVELY. TO HELP LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS KEEP THEIR LIGHTS ON
IN THEIR HOMES COOL COMFORTABLE
AND SAFE. APPROXIMATELY NINE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION. WILL BE DEVOTED TO
LOCAL SYSTEMS WITH SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION RETAINED BY CSP
FOR STATE OPERATIONS. AND
THERE'S A NEW THERE'S AN AD TO
THE AGENDA. I WAS ASKED TO
COVER. OF THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM. THE MAY
REALIZE PROPOSED ONE POINT
THREE BILLION IN GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT OVER THREE YEARS TO
HELP MEET THE STATE'S PRIORITY
CLIMATE GOALS. FUND PROJECTS
THAT INCREASE RESILIENCE AND
ADDRESS CLIMATE RISKS WITHIN
THE STATE SUCH AS EXTREME HEAT
AND SEA LEVEL RISE. BUT IT
WOULD BE FOR PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS SUPPORTED IN THE
MINISTERED BY VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
INCLUDING GST. THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE INCLUDES
FIFTY MILLION FOR THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
MULTI FAMILY COMPONENT.
ADMINISTERED BY C. THE STATE.
THE LIGHTWEIGHT MULTI FAMILY
COMPONENT HELPS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
PROVIDING INVESTMENTS AND
SERVICES TO IMPROVE THE ENERGY
PERFORMANCE OF LOW INCOME MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING AND
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THROUGH THE
INSTALLATION OF ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEASURES. AND
ROOFTOP SOLAR PEAVEY SYSTEMS.
IN ADDITION. THESE INVESTMENTS
REDUCE ENERGY COSTS FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS RESIDING IN
MULTI FAMILY PROPERTIES WHILE
ALSO HELPING TO PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY LOWERING
OPERATING COSTS. FUNDING WILL
BE USED TO CONTINUE PROGRAM
OFFERINGS AND SERVICES WILL
SUPPORT ADDING HIGHER
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
REPLACEMENT OF HEATING AND
COOLING SYSTEMS WITH LOW GLOBAL
WARMING REFRIGERANTS IN ORDER
TO ELIMINATE THE USE OF HIGH
GLOBAL WARMING REFRESHMENTS
THAT ARE THOUSANDS OF TIMES.
MORE POTENT PER POUND THAN
CARBON DIOXIDE. AN INMATE MY
BROTHER DIDN'T GIVE UP. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR MMHM NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM ANGELES SHORT WITH
THE L. L. THANK YOU TERRY MILLA
AND LET'S START WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME AS
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT A
NUMBER OF THESE PROPOSALS IS
STILL FORTHCOMING- IN
PARTICULAR AS OF THIS MORNING
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR
THE NEWLY PROPOSED- ONE BILLION
DOLLAR CALIFORNIA. A RIDGE
ASSISTANT PAID PAYMENT PROGRAM
IS NOT YET AVAILABLE BUT ONCE
THAT IS WE WILL BE SURE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
REGARDING ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS SHORT AND IT WAS- THE
CHAIRS OVERSIGHT NOT TO INCLUDE
JACQUI BORA SEAL IT WITH THE L.
A. L. ON THE LAST PANEL. SO I'D
LIKE TO BRING IN JACQUI TO
COMMENT ON THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IF WE CAN
ON PANEL THREE NOW. SURE
JANUARY CHAU- AGAIN PER YOUR
DIRECTION FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
I'LL START WITH WHICH PROPOSALS
DO GENERALLY ALIGN WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES BASED
OFF OF WHAT WE KNOW I THINK ONE
THE PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO CONNECT EXERCISES
P. RECIPIENTS TO CALFRESH BUILT
UPON LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO
EXTEND CALFRESH TO S. SCIENCES
PETE I THINK THE OTHER ONE WITH
PERHAPS THERE IS. A MORE CLEAR
CONNECTION- IT IS D. R. LARGER
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING PROPOSAL
AND THAT THE SUB COMMITTEE IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE NUTRITION
AUGMENTATION- HAS EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN PURSUING AND
REDUCING AND ELIMINATING SENIOR
HUNGER- AND AGAIN THE PROPOSED
SUSPENSION ENDS- OF BINDING
ASSOCIATED WITH BOTH SENIOR
NUTRITION AND ADRC OUR ACTIONS
THAT THE SUB COMMITTEE HAS
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN DOING
EMPIRE HEARINGS I'M WITH THE
SENIOR NUTRITION ONE I WOULD
JUST ECHO THE SENTIMENT WITHIN.
THE AGENDAS QUESTION IN THAT
THINKING AHEAD AND HAVING THE
NECESSARY DATA TO KNOW WHERE
SENIOR HUNGER TODAY OR WHERE
WILL IT BE POST COLD VICT- WILL
BE CRITICAL TO FOR THEM THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE- THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
ACCOMPLISH ITS OWN GOAL WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ELIMINATION
REDUCTION OF SENIOR HUNGER IN
THE STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS BUT ALSO WITH THAT WE WILL
RETURN TO PANEL FOR DEPARTMENT
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT WE WILL BEGIN. OUR
QUESTIONS WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER. FOR YOU MISTER CHAIR-
AND I THINK I HEARD. THAT THE
WATER SITUATION WAS GONNA BE IN
A BILLION. AND I'M JUST ASKING
CST USED. THE WATER BOND THAT
WAS BROUGHT OUT IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE WAS FIVE POINT
SOMETHING BILLION DOLLARS WAS
POSED TO ADDRESS A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES AND HERE WE ARE AGAIN
WITH ANOTHER BILLION IS THERE
ANY KIND OF FACTOR FIG FIGURE
THAT ACTUALLY GETS TO WHERE WE
NEED TO BE TO GIVE PEOPLE
RELIABLE CLEAN WATER SOURCES- I
MEAN WHAT SEEMS LIKE WHAT WE
THOUGHT WE WERE DOING IT IN THE
WATER BOND AND HERE WE ARE
AGAIN- IS. THIS GOING TO DO IT
OR DO WE NEED TO ANTICIPATE FOR
MORE. AND WHY DID WE GO FOR
MORE NOW WHEN WE AGAIN LOOK
INTO. A BUDGET SURPLUS WHERE
THIS ONE TIME INVESTMENT REALLY
DOES BRING BACK A VALUE. I
BELIEVE THE QUESTION IS FOR-
ACTING DIRECTOR SCRIBNER FEAR.
PROPEL I'M SORRY I. WE AT THAT
CST DON'T MINISTER OF A WATER
PROGRAM AND WE WOULD HAVE TO
DEFER T THE STATE WATER BOARD
ON ON THE NUMBERS AND FUNDING
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERN. NOT ACTING DIRECTOR
SCRIBNER I BELIEVE HE WAS
REFERENCING ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
FIVE THE FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLD WATER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM GRANT THAT IS UNDER
CST- BUT I WILL ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER TO
CLARIFY. SO IN A LOT OF
INSTANCES WHEN WE'VE HAD THE
OF. THE ISSUES OF WATER WE'VE
WE'VE ADDRESSED IN A WATER BOND
WE'VE ADDRESSED IN DIFFERENT
RESOURCES. I UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW THAT WE CONTINUE TO CHIP
AT THIS. ADDITIONAL HELP. AND
I'M WONDERING IS THERE
ANTICIPATED IS THIS. CONSIDERED
TO BE A FIX- OR IS THERE AN
NECESSITY TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT MORE RESOURCES TO HELP MORE
PEOPLE I MEAN- HEY AGAIN IN
THESE ANTICIPATED BUDGET
SURPLUS. SHOULD WE BE
ADDRESSING THIS IS A ONE TIME
LET'S FIX THIS GOING FORWARD.
WELL THE CST IS ONLY A MINISTER
IN A VERY SMALL WATER PROGRAM
WITH FEDERAL FUNDS AND AGAIN
THAT IS GOING TO BE IN THE
RANGE OF EIGHTY TO NINETY
MILLION WE DO KNOW THAT THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO DO WITH YOUR
RELIGIOUS BUT- TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION AS TO WHETHER. THIS IS
ENOUGH FOR IF THERE'S GONNA BE
A NEED FOR MORE I WOULD HAVE TO
DEFER TO THE WATER BOARD THAT
CST DOES NOT HAVE ANY OF THAT
DATA OR STATISTICAL EVIDENCE TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ANSWERS HERE
THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU I
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE CHAIR
FOR. MY QUESTIONS I'M GONNA
FOCUS ON ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
SIX REGARDING THE ENERGY A RE
RIDGES THE BILLION DOLLARS THE
STATE IS. PROPOSING AND I WAS
STRUCK BY YOUR EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT. COMMENT OF
ADMINISTERING THIS PROGRAM. AND
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
BEING BOTH CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY. COMPETENT AND
OUR OUTREACH AND SO WANTED TO
ASK YOU ACTING DIRECTOR HOW ARE
WE ADDRESSING OUR MONO LINGUAL
COMMUNITIES OR- SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES THAT MIGHT NOT BE.
ABLE TO TRADITIONALLY ACCESS
THIS PROGRAM BUT THAT COULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM THAT. HOW
ARE WE INTENTIONALLY DOING
OUTREACH TO THOSE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. WELL THE INITIAL
PROGRAM DESIGN IS AT A MUCH
HIGHER LEVEL AND THAT I THINK
THAT THE PLAN WOULD BE TO GET A
MAJORITY OF THE LOW INCOME AND
THOSE GLOBAL POPULATIONS. I'VE
DEALT WITH DIRECTLY FROM THE
UTILITY ITSELF AND THEN THE
OUTRAGE WOULD BE. NONEXISTENT
IT AND SEXUALLY THAT THEY THEY
START CUSTOMERS WOULD THEN BE
TAGGED AND IDENTIFIED IN AN
APPLICATION TO THE DEPARTMENT.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD THEN JUST
ISSUE ONE BIG CHECK AND THEY
WOULD BE THEN APPLIED TO- THE
ORIGINAL BALANCE IS THAT THESE
CUSTOMERS HAVE. NOW IN THE
AREAS OF WHERE UTILITY MAY NOT
BE PARTICIPATING WITH CAP
DIRECTLY WITH CSP. WHAT WE
WOULD DO EXACTLY WHAT WE HAD
DONE BEFORE- WE WOULD HAVE WE
RELY ON OUR- NETWORK OF CEOS A
LOCAL PROVIDERS TO DO THAT
OUTRAGE AS NECESSARY AND HOW
THEY BELIEVE IS THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY TO DEAL WITH IT
FOR THE LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS
THAT THEY'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
FOR. DECADES UNDER THE LIKELY
PROGRAM SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WE WOULD FIND ANY GAPS IN
SERVICE- AND YOU BELIEVE IN AND
ACTUALLY HAVE THE MICRO TO
MACRO LEVEL WILL BE. ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES MUCH QUICKER
THAN WE COULD IF IT WERE DONE
ON A. ONE APPLICATION ONE
CUSTOMER APPROACH- I'M
ENCOURAGED BY WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING REGARDING- HOW THE
PROGRAM WILL BE IMPLEMENTED I
HAVE CONCERNS THAT- ARE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR MIGHT NOT.
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AND
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
HAVING- IN INTENTIONALITY IN
ADDRESSING THIS IN ADVANCE. OF
THE APPLICATIONS AND IF THAT
REQUIRES US AS A STATE TO LOOK
TOWARDS SUPPORTING THOSE CBO'S
ARE NONPROFITS WHO ARE. DOING
THAT OUTREACH I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THIS IS
REACHING THOSE HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES. WHO COULD GREATLY
BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM- AND
WITH THAT I WILL AGAIN THANK
VERY MUCH THIS PANEL AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL PANEL.
WHICH IS ON THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY MAY REVISE UPDATES WE
WILL HAVE TO PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL MARKHAM YOU CHECK WITH
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY. OF
PROGRAM AND FISCAL AFFAIRS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. AND SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE CAN WE PLEASE
BEGIN WITH MR MAJOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON- DR. AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH
YOU TODAY- THERE TO PARTICULAR
ITEMSTHAT I'D LIKE TO SPEND A
LOT- SOMETIME ON AND THEN
CERTAINLY WOULD WELCOME. ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
RELATED TO THIS ITEM SO FIRST
STARTING WITH THE LANGUAGE
ACCESS PROPOSAL THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE AT THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. TO EXPAND OUR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE IN LANGUAGE-
DOCUMENTS AND RESOURCES TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE
ACROSS THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS I
WITHIN OUR AGENCY- AND THIS
REALLY IS A- IS AN EFFORT OF
BOTH- OUR AGENCY AND OUR
STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE LAST MANY
YEARS. IN ORDER FOR US TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE REACHING
FOLKS IN LANGUAGE OUT WHILE
ALSO LOOKING AT WAYS IN WHICH
WE BE FIVE PER CAPABILITY. I
HAD TO DO A SL AMERICAN SIGN
LANGUAGE. INTERPRETATION AS
PART OF- VIDEOS OR OTHER THINGS
THAT WE PUT OUT AT AT AT THE AT
THE AGENCY AND SO THIS PROPOSAL
REALLY COMPLEMENTS AND AT THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WHICH
INCLUDES SOME RESOURCES THE
AGENCY TO BEGIN TO BUILD OUT A
FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT LANGUAGE
ACCESS LOOKS LIKE ACROSS ALL OF
THE DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. AND THE INTENT HERE
REALLY IS TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
DEPARTMENTS HAVE A BASELINE
THIS DOES NOT NEGATE OR CHANGE
THE LANGUAGE REQUIREMENT
LANGUAGE ACCESS REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS OR IN
STATUTE FOR A NUMBER OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS BUT THEY'RE EVERY
SERIES OF DEPARTMENTS. THAT
DON'T HAVE REQUIREMENTS AND SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE BASICALLY CREATING AN
OPPORTUNITY. ACROSS THE AGENCY.
MAJORITY OF DOLLAR WILL BE ON.
ARE REALLY UP OUR CONTRACT KEEP.
TO TRANSLATE DOCUMENTS THAT WE
PUT OUT TO CONSUMERS AND
INDIVIDUALS IN ORDER TO MAKE
THEM MORE ACCESSIBLE. WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME REALLY LOOKING AT
COORDINATING AMONGST BOTH ARE
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED
DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER FOR US TO
GET ECONOMIES OF SCALE AND
LEVERAGE OUR PURCHASING POWER
ACROSS THE STATE. OR ACROSS OUR
AGENCY IN ORDER FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO REALLY DELIVER ON
LANGUAGE ACCESS SO. THAT IS THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PROPOSAL THE
SECOND PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE YOU AS PART OF THAT MAY
REVISION IS A RESOURCES AT THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY I TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
OUT. HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE. AND I THINK MANY OF
YOU ARE FAMILIAR AROUND WHAT H.
I. E. IS I WILL JUST SAY THAT-
OUR VISION HERE REALLY IS FOR
US TO TAKE A BOLDER LEADERSHIP
IN TERMS OF. NOT ONLY HOW ARE
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN OUR AGENCY
LOOK AT HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE BUT ALSO HOW THE
INDUSTRY LEVERAGES HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE OR HOW IT
USES. AT THE DATA THAT IT
COLLECTS IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
THE HEALTH OUTCOMES. AND THE
DELIVERY OF. SERVICE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES AND SO OUR TENSION
HERE REALLY IS TWO FOLD ONE IS
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE SOME
STANDARDS OF HOW THIS
INFORMATION IS EXCHANGED AND TO
ENGAGE STAKEHOLDERS IN A MORE
ROBUST WAY AROUND. HOW WE DO
THIS COLLECTIVELY I WILL JUST
SAY THAT THE TRADITIONALLY THIS
HAS BEEN ABOUT HEALTH
INFORMATION INFORMATION THAT IS
COLLECTED AT A PROVIDER'S
OFFICE BUT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT THIS FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
INFORMATION EXCHANGE BOTH FOR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
THE REASON I SAY THIS. IS THAT
SOME OF THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEONE HAS ACCESS TO HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION FOOD. ETCETERA
ARE PARAMOUNT IN US HAVING THE
ABILITY TO ADDRESS HOW. COMES
OR IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
MANY INSTANCES. AND REALLY WORK
WITH- THE INDUS TO THINK ABOUT
HOW DO WE THINK. ABOUT THE
SOCIAL SERVICES DATA AND HOW
THAT COMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
CLINICAL DATA- THAT IS- REALLY
COLLECTED AT THE PROVIDER LEVEL
IN ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
WRAP OURSELVES AROUND MORE
REALISTICALLY AROUND THE
INDIVIDUALS WERE TRYING TO
SERVE IN ORDER TO. IMPROVE
OUTCOMES SO BOTTOM LINE THIS
PROPOSAL IN PARTICULAR MAKE
SOME INVESTMENTS AT THE STATE
LEVEL. TO READ SOME LEADERSHIP
IN ORDER FOR US TO BOTH CREATE
STANDARDS AND CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT INFORMATION EXCHANGE FROM
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PERSPECTIVE LOOKS LIKE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. DR RANDALL
I'LL PAUSE THERE AND- LOOK TO
ENGAGE YOU IN YOUR- AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE ON THE
COMMITTEE WITH ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE FOR ME.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE L. L. I
THANK YOU MR CHER CINEMATIC L.
A. IN REGARDS TO THE AGENCY'S
PROPOSAL FOR TWENTY MILLION FOR
LANGUAGE ACCESS- THIS PROPOSAL
DOES APPEAR TO ALIGN WITH
LEGISLATIVE- THAT PRIORITIES
THIS ESPECIALLY GIVEN AS MR
MNUCHIN NOTED THE VARIOUS-
PROVISIONS IN THE STATUTE
REGARDING REQUIREMENTS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THRESHOLD
LANGUAGES- IT WAS IT WAS ALSO
NOTED THE PROPOSAL BUILDS ON-
AT. GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
IN JANUARY- THAT HAD APPROVED-
PROPOSAL TO. CREATE A LANGUAGE
ACCESS POLICY FRAMEWORK- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT- ALTHOUGH THE
PROPOSAL TO ACTUALLY START
PROVIDING LANGUAGE ACCESS
SERVICES WITH THE TWENTY
MILLION. LIKELY MAKES. SENSE TO
SOME TO SOME TO. THE PROPOSAL
AND- WAS TO AS- THE- FOR THE
STAY WOULD HAVE- WHEN ACCESS.
WE'RE WONDERING IF SOME OF
DOLLARS FOR THIS THAT. MIGHT BE.
BEFORE THE FOR MARKET IS. A THE
SAME TIME LIKE I SAID IT'S
THERE'S PROBABLY SOME OBVIOUS
AREAS WHERE LANGUAGE ACCESS IS
NEEDED WE RIGHT NOW WE DON'T
HAVE A WAY TO REALLY ASSESS
WHETHER TWENTY MILLION IS THE
RIGHT AMOUNT BECAUSE WE HAVE
NOT SEEN- DETAILS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL JUST YET- IN REGARDS
TO THE SECOND PROPOSAL ABOUT
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE
LEADERSHIP THIS IS ANOTHER
PROPOSAL THAT WE JUST DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION
ABOUT. YET AND SO AS MORE
DETAILS BECOME AVAILABLE WE'RE
CERTAINLY I'M HAPPY CHIU TO
WEIGH. IN ON THOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WITH A I
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE TO SEE
IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS.
DOCTOR WHAT. YES AND MY- MY
APOLOGIES FOR NOT BEING IN THE
ROOM WHEN- MARCO WAS- SPEAKING
ORIGINALLY AND- WITH REGARDS
TO- THE H. I. E. PROPOSAL IS
THAT. THAT REALLY MEANT TO JUST
FOCUS ON THE MEDICARE OUT.
PORTION OF THE STATE POPULATION
OR- HELP ME HELP ME GET MY ARMS
AROUND THAT BECAUSE I'M I'M NOT
SURE I UNDERSTOOD. HI DOCTOR
WHAT THANKS FOR THE QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY NOT ADD THIS TO THE
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION THAT'S
AT THE AGENCY IS REALLY
INTENDED TO DO A FEW THINGS
ONE. IT'S INTENDED TO BRING
TOGETHER AN ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE- AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO HELP
GUIDE OUR WORK AROUND
INFORMATION EXCHANGE- AND I
THINK I SEE THIS MORE ABOUT
BOTH HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
INFORMATION. AND HOW THAT
INFORMATION IS EXCHANGED AT THE
PROVIDER LEVEL OR AT THE HEALTH
SYSTEM LEVEL AND THEN THE
SECOND PIECE REALLY IS TO BEGIN
TO THINK ABOUT. HOW DO WE-
CREATES SOME STANDARDS. IN IN
THE WAVE THIS INFORMATION%
EXPECTS CHANGED OUR TEMPLATE
SILICATES FURTHER EXCHANGE OF
THIS INFORMATION MORE BROADLY
IN AS A PROVIDER YOURSELF AND
BOTH YOU AND DR ARAMBULA. I
THINK REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROVIDER HAS ALL OF THE
INFORMATION WITH REGARDS TO THE
INDIVIDUAL SO THAT WE CAN
FURTHER. IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND FOR ME IT'S A IT'S
IMPERATIVE OBVIOUSLY ABOUT THE
DATA THAT YOU COLLECT AN EMR OR
EHR BUT IT'S EQUALLY IMPORTANT
TO THINK ABOUT SOME OF THE
SOCIAL. DATA WHETHER OR NOT AND
SOMEONE'S GETTING ACCESS TO CAO
WORKS OR CALFRESH AWAKE AND HOW
THAT ALL UNDER LINES ARE UNDER
CONSTABULARIES. FOR A FOR
YOUTUBE TO IMPROVE THEIR HEALTH
OUTCOMES SO THE BOTTOM LINE
THAT THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
THAT'S AT THE AGENCY LEVEL IS
REALLY SPECIFIC TO BUILDING
SOME LEADERSHIP IN ORDER FOR US
TO. AB CREEK BEGIN TO CREATE
STANDARDS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEN MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR US TO
CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS. TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT THE FUTURE OF H. I
EAT AND I WOULD EXPAND HIV TO
NOT JUST INCLUDE HEALTH. AND
HUMAN SERVICES DATA AS WELL.
OKAY I DO I GUESS I MY COM
WOULD JUST BE THAN I THINK
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF STUDY
AROUND THIS OVER THE YEARS
THERE HAVE BEEN VARIOUS. GROUPS
OF STAKEHOLDERS BABY NOT
ORGANIZED TOGETHER THAT WAY- TO
WORK ON THESE ISSUES AND-
THERE'S BEEN A FAIR AMOUNT OF
MONEY SPENT ON HEALTH
INFORMATION- YOU KNOW-
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE. SO
I GUESS. I GUESS WHAT DO YOU
EXPECTING THE OUTCOME TO BE
BECAUSE THERE'S ALREADY A HUGE
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION OUT
THERE. WE ARE SET WE ALSO HAVE
NEW GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ABOUT. CERTAIN
ADMISSIONS AND DISCHARGES AND
THINGS WERE HOSPITAL SO- IN IN
THE LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE ACCESS
TO SOME OF THIS INFORMATION
WOULD HAVE BEEN HUGELY VALUABLE
TO US. WHICH SIMPLY WASN'T
THERE- YEAH HOW LONG DO YOU SEE
THIS PROCESS GOING I MEAN. IT
JUST FEELS LIKE WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE WE'RE KIND OF SLOW WALKING
SOMETHING THAT REALLY SHOULD
GET DONE SOONER. I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH YOUR
DOCTOR WELL I DON'T THINK THE
INTENTION IS TO STUDY ANYTHING
BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE STUDIED
IT QUITE WELL I THINK THE
INTENTION HERE IS TO. BEGIN TO
LOOK AT THE NATIONAL STANDARDS
THE ONC STANDARDS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT OUT HOW DO WE ADD TO
THOSE OR BUILD OFF OF THOSE SO
THAT WE HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
UNDERSTANDING AROUND HOW WE
ACCELERATE THE EXCHANGE OF DATA
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
AND THEN REALLY BEING ABLE TO
BUILD. UP A YOU KNOW AN
ADVISORY BODY TO HELP GUIDE THE
STATE BOTH IN THE SHARING OF
OUR OWN DATA AMONGST OUR OWN
DEPARTMENTS BUT ALSO WHAT
STANDARDS INDUSTRY CAN USE IN
ORDER TO FURTHER ACCELERATE THE
USE OF THIS AND YOU'RE RIGHT-ON. YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE
PANDEMIC REALLY EACH SHIP ON A
LIGHT ON THE FACT THAT THIS
DATA SOMETIMES ISN'T SHARED BUT
THE VALUE IN SHARING IT OR
HAVING IT SHARED IN A IN A- IN
A IN IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
PRIVACY. AND LOOKS AT KIND OF
THE POPULATION MORE BROADLY IS
PARAMOUNT TO US BEING ABLE TO
DO THAT SO OUR GOAL HERE REALLY
IS TAKE CELEBRATE THIS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IN ORDER
FOR US TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
DELIVER ON THIS VISION OF
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE. SO
JUST A FOLLOW UP TO THAT SO IS
THIS- IS THIS MEANT TO BE MORE
INTROSPECTIVE OF STATE
GOVERNMENT OR ARE YOU LOOKING
AT A STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT
INVOLVES A BROADER A BROADER- I
NEED. IT I GUESS IN MY MIND
THESE KINDS OF THINGS DON'T
WORK UNLESS EVERYBODY'S IN AND
SO- SO WE'RE JUST LOOKING AT
SOMETHING THIS IS GOING TO HELP
WITH OUR STATE DATA THAT'S NOT
THAT DOESN'T DO IT FOR ME
BECAUSE THAT'S ONLY A THIRD OF
THE POPULATION. AND SAID YEAH
AND IT'S NOT INTENDED TO BE
STATE IT'S FULLY ENCOMPASSING
SO I THINK WE WANT TO ENGAGE
WITH OTHER H. I. EASE H. I.
OWES HEALTH SYSTEMS PROVIDERS
AT SENTARA LOOKING AT HOW WE
MAKE THIS AS BROAD AS POSSIBLE
THE INTENT HERE IS NOT TO JUST
FOCUS ON STATE. AT THE EXCHANGE
OF STATE DATA. OKAY THE THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU
I WILL BRING IT BACK UP TO THE
CHAIR FOR A FINAL COMMENT IF I
CAN FOR HHS I WILL BRING BACK
CST FOR ONE FINAL QUESTION IF
ACTING DIRECTOR SCRIBNER STILL
AVAILABLE THE FIRST MARCO SINCE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN BREAK DOWN SOME OF
THE SILOS BETWEEN HHS AND
SOCIAL SERVICES. EARLIER WHEN
WE WERE SPEAKING WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES WE HAD TALKED ABOUT
THE INTENSE AND EXCUSE ME THE
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
BENEFIT WITHIN CAL WORKS WAS
HOPING YOU COULD TALK ABOUT CAL
AIM IN THE EFFORTS BEHIND THE
ENHANCED CARE MANAGEMENT
BENEFIT THAT IS BEING PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION AND
SIMILARITIES WITH THE PROGRAM
IN SOCIAL SERVICES AND
ADVANTAGES FOR US TO GETTING
UPSTREAM AND- INCREASING THOSE
SERVICES BEFORE WE GOT TO ECM
WAS HOPING TO YOU COULD JUST
PROVIDE SOME INSIGHTS OUR
CONFIDENCE IN THAT SPACE. SURE
DOCTOR ARAMBULA FIRST THANKS-
FOR THAT QUESTION I THINK AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
PARAMOUNT TO S. AT THE AGENCY
IN THIS IS REALLY LED BY DR
GALLEON AND ARE UNDER SECRETARY
MACHON BAIS IS REALLY THINKING
ABOUT THE WHOLE PERSON AND WE
TALK ABOUT A WHOLE PERSON FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF HEALTH AND
MEDICAID- BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
THINK ABOUT A WHOLE PERSON WITH
REGARDS TO- THE SERVICES THAT
WE DELIVER ON THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES CITING SO WE'VE
BEEN SPENDING A LOT OF TIME.
REALLY ENGAGING- AN ARRAY OF
OUR DEPARTMENTS TO SAY HOW ARE
WE WRAPPING OURSELVES MORE
REALISTICALLY AROUND THE NEEDS
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WERE SERVING
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE ACCESSING
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS ACROSS
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS WITHIN OUR
AGENCY AND MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED IN THE SILENT
STRUCTURES OF GOVERNMENT AND
NOT BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO SERVE AND
SO OUR INTENT AND OUR GOAL
HERE. IS REALLY THINKING ABOUT
HOW DO WE HOLISTICALLY WRAP.
OURSELVES AROUND THE NEEDS OF
THE PERSON AND HAVING THEM COME
THROUGH ONE DOOR ANYTHING
DOCTOR ADD TO DIRECTOR CAME.
WAIT TIMES TALKED ABOUT THIS
FROM AN AGING PERSPECTIVE BUT
IT'S NOT IMPERATIVE ON AGING I
WAS HEARING YOUR CONVERSATION
AROUND. THE DD SYSTEM AND AN
EARLIER AROUND THE CONVERSATION
AROUND HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
REALLY THINKING ABOUT THIS MORE
ABOUT. HOW DO WE AS AN AGENCY
AND HOW DO WE AS AN AGENCY THAT
ENGAGE WITH OTHER AGENCIES
WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT TO SAY
WE ARE SERVING SIMILAR
POPULATIONS AND HOW DO WE WRAP
OURSELVES AROUND WITH REGARDS
TO CALAMP. OUR INTENT IN THE
SECRETARY'S VISION AND DIRECTOR
LIFEFORMS VISION HERE REALLY IS
ABOUT HOW DO WE COME UP WITH
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
MEDICAID SYSTEM- THAT REALLY
LOOKS AT SERVING THE NEEDS OF
THE INDIVIDUALS AND WORKING
MORE UPSTREAM. WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH AND SO PART OF THIS IT
PROPOSAL WOULD WITH REGARDS TO
CALLIN IS REALLY THINKING ABOUT
HOW DO WE ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
AND MAKE A MEDICAID AND
EQUALIZER AND YOU KNOW NOT NOT
EQUITY TOOL IN MANY WAYS. AND
SO OUR INTENT MOVING FORWARD.
IS REALLY LOOKING AT WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN CROSS AB PROGRAMS
CROSS DEPARTMENTS LOOK AT THE
INDIVIDUAL SILOS BREAK THEM
DOWN SO THAT ARE UNDERLYING
FOCUS IS ON THE PEOPLE WERE
TRYING TO SERVE AND THEIR
NEEDS. NOT THE BUREAUCRATIC
STRUCTURES OR PROGRAMMATIC
STRUCTURES THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED BECAUSE OF
CONVENIENCE AND SO I THINK THAT
IS GOING TO BE WHAT WHERE WE
DRIVE TOWARDS. I THINK THAT
THIS BUDGET BEGINS TO LAY THE
GROUNDWORK TOWARD SAD WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE THEMES OF OUR- ARMY
REVISION INVESTMENTS THEY KIND
OF UNDERLINE SIX DIFFERENT
TEAMS IN THE CROSS. EACH OF THE
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN OUR AGENCY
AB AND SO I THINK THAT THAT IS
GOING TO BE REALLY WHAT THE
FOCUS OF OUR WORK AS- WITH THIS
BUDGET. AND FUTURE BUDGETS
MOVING FORWARD. I'D LIKE TO
THANK FOR MUCH THIS THE- AND
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR ON GOING
CONVERSATIONS IT IS- ABSOLUTELY
THAT TIME FOR US TO BE HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND
FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THESE PROGRAMS
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO THE
COLLABORATION THAT WE CAN DO
TOGETHER. I'D LIKE TO BRING
BACK IF I CANNOT FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THIS PANEL BUT BRING BACK
ACTING DIRECTOR SCRIBNER FOR
PANEL FOR. AS THERE WAS A
QUESTION THAT CAME UP AFTER
WORDS THAT I'D LIKE TO GET ON
TO THE PUBLIC RECORD. AND THAT
IS SINCE THESE FUNDS ARE ONE
TIME FROM THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
MY QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE APPLICABLE FOR ARE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY SINCE
THEIR FEDERAL FUNDS. WE WILL
BE- CAP WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
ALL RATEPAYERS. THAT'S
WONDERFUL AND THAT'S THE ANSWER
WE WERE HOPING FOR AND I
APPRECIATE THAT FROM YOU-
ACTING DIRECTOR SCRIPT. WITHOUT
I WILL THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS AND IF THERE IS NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE WILL NOW BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT. AS A REMINDER
WE WILL WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ANY ISSUES ON THE AGENDA
INCLUDING THE NON PRESENTATION
ISSUES. WE HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEREFORE I WANT TO URGE YOU TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF SO
THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM EVERYONE.
WE WILL GO TO THE PUB PHONE
LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND AS
A REMINDER THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
INTERNET THE KEYS WITH THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE PHONE UMBER
IS. 1-877-692-8957 THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CALL THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. I WILL
REMIND EVERYONE THAT WE DO HAVE
FLOOR SESSION WHICH BEGINS AT
ONE PM WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS FOR AS LONG AS WE CAN
BEFORE FLOOR SESSION WE WILL
THEN TAKE A BREAK AND RECONVENE
AFTER. FLOOR SESSION IF
NECESSARY TO CONTINUE WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT. BUT WITH THAT
OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO BEGIN
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER.
THANKS COMMITTEE CHAIR. THE
GERMAN FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THENZERO ON YOUR PHONE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PARDON ME MISTER CHAIR ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NOW. HI DOCTOR ARE
BILL AND MEMBERS INTERCHANGE
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ALL POLL
JUST BE BRIEF WILL HAVE MORE IN
COMMON- I AM NUMBER THREE
STATUS DE INCREASE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AS
WELL AS THE ALEJO'S COMMENTS.
ABOUT THE NEED TO FULLY RESTORE
INCLUDING FOR INFLATION THE
GRANT FOR INDIVIDUALS AS WELL
AS COUPLES WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- RESTORATION AT IN
THE ME REVISED BUT WITH THE
BUDGET CONDITION WE MUST DO
MORE- ON ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWO. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE- UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME
FOR OTHER BENEFITS SO
INSTRUMENTATION I WOULD THIS BE
IMPORTANT LIKE THERE AND THEN
FINALLY- FROM THE COMPANY
SUFFICIENT TO MAKE WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS- ON
THE NEED TO INVEST IN OUR
EMERGENCY COULD DETERMINE COULD.
GREATLY APPRECIATED THAT THERE
SIR THANK YOU. Q. AND OPERATE
WE'RE GOING TO A BRIEF PAUSE.
IT'S A NEW BUT WE HAVE A PUBLIC
IS PRESENT HERE WHO'D LIKE TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. AND NOW
HE'S SHAKING HIS HEAD THAT HE
DOES NOT SO WITH THAT OPERATOR
WE WILL RETURN BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE GO TO LINE FIFTY ONE.
POINT FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BEEN ASKING ON BEHALF
IN OUR FAMILY PARTNERSHIP WELL
WE WERE PRESENTED WITH A BUDGET
THAT CAN REINVESTING PART
POCKET EQUITY FOR MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S LOWER INCOME
FAMILIES THROUGH THIS.
UNPRECEDENTED SURPLUS. OR
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED THAT
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
FUNDING AMOUNTS WERE NOT FUNDED
TO AT LEAST PRETEND AT MY CLUB
OPEN ACCOUNT WORK. CALVET HOME
VISITING CIRCLE ONE TIME THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR CUT LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET PREVENTING HELD HUGE
MOLDING THE FALLOUT CASELOADS.
EVEN WITH THE PANDEMIC SWEEPING
THE EAST COAST IN. SERVICES THE
PAYING. HOME VISITING PROGRAMS
COMMITTED TO HELP THE HELP OF
OUR FAMILIES CAN STAY CONNECTED
TO TRUSTED SERVICES EMOTIONS.
COUNTY NEED THE SECURITY IN OUR
BUDGETING TO PROVIDE HOME
VISITING ANY SERVICES ARE
PROVEN LIFELINE TO HELP LOW
INCOME FAMILIES ON THE PATH TO
SELF SUFFICIENCY. MILLION HEARD
LEGISLATURE FUNDS HOW WORK FROM
BEGINNING TO AT LEAST PRETEND
I'M NOT LEVELS. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE SUBCOMMITTEES
QUESTION BOND YET THAT THIS
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES PLAN MCCARTY INCLUSION
OF MORE EVIDENCE BASED. PROGRAM
CONTAINS ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALL PLEASE.
LINE. FIFTY TWO. OH SORRY I
DIDN'T CATCH MY NUMBER THEIR
FIRST MISTER CHAIR MIGHT CAROL
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY- AND I APPRECIATE
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION OBVIOUSLY
IT'S A VERY GOOD BUDGET YEAR
THERE'S MANY THINGS- FOR
CONSIDERATION- I DO WANT TO
THANK MY COMMENTS RIGHT OFF THE
TOP ON ITEM NUMBER THREE WITH
MR CHANGE COMMENTS ON THE APPLE
PIE GRANT INCREASE WELL WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE- THE FIRST
TRAINING CREEK THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN MANY YEARS IT IS STILL WELL
BELOW WHERE THE GRANT LEVELS
NEED TO BE AND WE HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE A LAW
AUGMENTED MINISTRATIONS FUNDING
ON THAT- WE- ALSO WANT TO. TALK
ABOUT COUCH GRANT INCREASE-
THE- AGAIN WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL COME
FORWARD WITH A LARGER INCREASE
THAT WAS IN THE JANUARY BUDGET-
IT STILL FALLS SHORT OF WHAT WE
AGREED JUNE TWENTY- NINETEEN
WHEN WE AGREED AND TO INCREASE
GRANTED THREE STAGES SO WE GOT
TO- A PLACE OF THE ASSISTANT
YOU HAVE ONE LEVEL WHICH WOULD
ENSURE THAT NO CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA EVER LIVED IN DEEP
POVERTY AGAIN SO WE WOULD URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO- WHAT TO
ENSURE THAT WE GET TO THAT
THIRD STEP- THE IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET I'M MORE VERY HAPPY FOR
FUNDING INCREASES FOR BALLPARK
HOW AGENTS PEOPLE GRANDPA. AND
H. STAFF WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE LEGISLATURE ON- THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT MAY
GET ASSOCIATED WITH THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO SEE THE FAMILY
REUNIFICATION FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET ARM AND THEN WE ALSO SEE
THAT THERE IS- A PROPOSAL HERE
ON CAL WORKS OVER PAYMENTS- WE
WOULD REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION OF COMING UP
WITH A MORE ROBUST PROPOSAL
THAT WOULD MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES DON'T GET INTO
BERKELEY HIP WITH- REDUCTIONS
IN THEIR POWER TO GRANT OVER
THE ISSUE THAT REALLY WEREN'T
THERE PAUL IN THE FIRST- SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE SEE IN THE BUDGET THAT
WE. LIKE TO COMMENT ON. TODAY
I'M SURE MISSING OR TWO- ALSO
WITH YOU KNOW THE- WE WOULD
ALSO I TO SEE SOMETHING IN THE
BUDGET THAT WOULD SURE- CAL
WHICH POINT NO. BOB AND
INDEMNIFY CAL. OF FROM TED
PENALTY. GETS UNDER. IN THIS
YEAR BY. SO WITH THOSE REMARKS
WILL LET I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER THANK YOU FOR
MUCH. THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALL
PLEASE. ONE SIX NINE. GOOD
MORNING THIS MARK STIVERS THE
HOUSING WITH STRAW SO THE
APPROPRIATION FOR THE INCOME
WHETHER AS PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT AND WE
THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS IS
PROPOSAL IN VERY MUCH THE CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR HIS
SUPPORT OF THIS- THIS CHAMPION
OF THIS REQUEST WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I CAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
KATHY SANDERLING A DONALD WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS IN A
COMPREHENSIVE HEARING THIS
MORNING WE APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSIONS ON THE ISSUES THAT
RELATE TO THE PROGRAMS ARE
MEMBERS ALL OVER OF THE STATE'S
BEHALF ACROSS ALL OF THESE
PROGRAM AREAS WE HAVE MUCH TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR IN
TERMS OF THE SIGNIFICANT AND IN
MANY AREAS OF PRESIDENT
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
NUMEROUS PROPOSAL PENDING
BEFORE YOU WOULD EACH OF OUR
PROGRAM AREAS. WE APPRECIATE
PENSION OF SOME OF THOSE TODAY
IN APIA TELL WELFARE POWERS CAL
PRESS AND HOUSING AND HOMELESS
SERVICES WHEN THE MEMO
YESTERDAY EVENING TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND RELATED
STAKEHOLDERS CROSS WALKING THEM
NAY REVISION PROPOSALS THOSE
THAT WE HAVE PUT FORTH OR
COMMENTED ON DURING THE PAST
FEW MONTHS OF SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING WE'VE ALSO CONTINUED TO
MAKE COMMENTS ON THE POTENTIAL
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY IMPACT.
OF A NUMBER OF THESE PROPOSALS.
CONSULTANT WE DECIDED. CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED BOTH ASSEMBLY AND A
QUICK AND TALK. I AM IF WE GET
ADDITIONAL THE ON THE FROM FROM
THE- WE DO INTEND TO SEND
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE. OVERALL WE WOULD SAY
THAT THERE IS WORK TO BE DONE
AND ALL OF THE AREAS THAT ARE
PROPOSED FOR INVESTMENT BUT
OVERALL WE APPRECIATE THAT WE
ARE ALL IN THE SAME ARENA AS IT
WERE IN TERMS OF RECOGNIZING
THE KEY ISSUES. EVEN IF WE ARE
NOT QUITE IN THE SAME PLACE YET
ON HOW TO ADDRESS THEM THANK
YOU AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE THIRTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING KELLY BROOKS
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES ARE
GENERALLY PLEASED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION MAY REVISION
INVESTMENTS AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAM I WOULD HIGHLIGHT A FEW
ISSUES FIRST REGARDING HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS
URBAN COUNTIES ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR HUMAN
SERVICES RELATED PROGRAMS WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE 25% TO
COUNTY SHERIFF COST THE SHARE
OF THE COSTS MAY LIMIT SOME
COUNTIES ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE
I'M THINKING PARTICULARLY
PARTICULARLY OF OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY AND INLAND EMPIRE
MEMBERS WHO HISTORICALLY HAVE
HAD FEWER RESOURCES.
ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO ENSURE
THEIR SUFFICIENT STATUTORY
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW COUNTIES
TO ADDRESS INDIVIDUALS AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS NOT JUST
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ALREADY
HOMELESS SECOND URBAN COUNTIES
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S I. S. I. H. AS
THAT'S PROPOSAL ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR TO KEEP THE STATE COUNTY
SHARING RATIO AT 65% STATE 35%
COUNTY AND CONTINUE THE TEN
PERCENT. OVER THREE YEARS TO
ALL THIRD URBAN COUNTIES OR
SUPPORT OF THE DEATH OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BEYOND THE
MAY REVISION FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE FAMILIES FIRST
PRESERVATION ACT SERVICES WE
SUPPORT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FOR
FAMILIES FIRST IMPLEMENTATION
FINALLY URBAN COUNTIES CONTINUE
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF ADDITIONAL
LESS MONTHLY ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM BE ON THE MAY
REVISION TO ALLOW FOR MORE
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT AND
SERVE A DUAL. STARTING AT AGE
SIXTY THANK YOU DETERMINE
ARAMBULA FOR CAMPING ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT THIS
MORNING THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE TWENTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OBLIGATE THE INTENT ON
BEHALF OF THE SEIU CALIFORNIA
WANT TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION
FOR. THE HEARING TODAY THE
QUESTIONS ASKED. AND THE TOPICS
COVERED. IN ADDITION TO
EXPRESSING APPRECIATION. FOR
THE ART MAY REVISE AND PUT
FORTH BY THE GOVERNOR WHICH
WILL ENSURE THAT MANY MORE
CALIFORNIANS IN NEED. ARE GOING
TO HAVE ACCESS TO IMPORTANT
LIFESAVING SUPPORT FROM SOCIAL
SERVICES. FROM PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES PROVIDERS- WE DID WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF ISSUES
HOWEVER AS WAS MENTIONED BY
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS OF PARTICULAR
LEAD COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
OF MANY OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
HIGHLIGHTED IN THEIR LETTER.
AND YOU WILL BE SHORTLY
RECEIVING A LOT ARE- FROM US ON
THAT REGARD. BUT WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED TO NOT COULD BE-
SUBSTANTIVE- THAT SUPPLEMENTAL
INVESTMENT PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION ACT AND PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES ON GOING FUNDING
FOR SAME. WE ARE CONCERNED AS
WAS MENTIONED BY THE RURAL
COUNTIES REPRESENTATIVE.
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL
DILATORY AT THE FACT OF THE 25%
COUNTY SHARE MATCH WHICH WE
BELIEVE WILL RESULT IN
DISENFRANCHISED IN THOSE
COUNTIES. IN GREATEST NEED AS
IT RELATES TO THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS- WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL REDUCTION. IN HOW
WORK ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING- AS
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY ANTICIPATING
AN INCREASE THE WORKLOAD- AND
BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT THERE
CANNOT BE A REDUCTION IN
STAFFING OR AN ADMIN- FUNDING
AT THIS TIME OF GREATEST NEED.
WE WERE FURTHER DISAPPOINTED
THAT WE DID NOT BE A
SUBSTANTIVE INVESTMENT AND- I'M
WORKING TO RESPOND. CHILD
WELFARE SERVICE SOCIAL WORKER
AS WE DO BUT THERE WILL BE A
DRUG INCREASE ONLY WORKLOAD BUT
AUTHORED THE- NATURE THAT WERE.
ONCE FULLY OPEN AND MANDATE
REPORTER HAVE THEIR EYE ON THE
EIGHTH CARE. AND TO CLOSE THE
ALSO TO RE THE ISSUE RAISED BY-
AS WORK. COUNTY NURSE BEDS
PROGRAM AS IT WAS NOT RESTORED
TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND
SIXTY SIX. GOOD MORNING CHEN
ARAMBULA MEMBERS TYLER WE NEED
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PRACTICE ASSOCIATION
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
SEVERAL OF THE ITEMS IN THE CDS
AT SECTION ON ITEM NINETEEN C.
B. HA CONTINUES TO RAISE
CONCERNS REGARDING THE
INTERPLAY OF PART ONE- AFFECT
PSA SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WITH
MEDIC HOW SERVICES PROVIDED BY
COUNTY THINKING ABOUT HOW. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
TO THE ASPEN CDF PASS. ALL OF
THE QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL AND
PARKS FOR. EACH YEAR IN OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
HELP OF DRAFTING OF THE RETURN
OUT OF STATE PARK YOU AND
CONTINUE DOING CAL ISSUE WITH
NOT. BY THAT YOU BOTH FROM ONE
TO AND- WE STRONGLY SO A
REACHED THAT THE SUPPORTS OUR
CONTRACT THE MALL DELIVERIES
AND WORKING TO ADDRESS A- NEED
TO BE GOING TO THAT. TV HD A
THE POINT OF H. NUMBER TWO
SEVEN ON THE- TO EXPAND THE
COMMUNITY CARE AND CRY. AND
LOOKS TO REVIEW ANYWAY IN ON
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BECAUSE
WILL TAKE HELP TO IT THE GAP
AND HOW THE OF WITH A HOPE
CONDITION. THE H. D. A. SUPPORT
OF THIRTY NINE AND FOR TWO
RELATED TO STRIKE IN A-
LANGUAGE THE FAMILY AT RISK
FROM TO BE A PRO. ABOUT THANK
YOU. JENNIFER THEY WOULD
CHILDREN FLOCK AND OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S BOX
CENTER REPRESENTS ALL THE
CHILDREN OF LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER COUNTY
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
HEALTHY FUTURES ARE PLASTIC THE
POSTAL TECH SENT THE INFANT UP
AMEND. THEM OFFENSIVE COUNTY
EXPECTING YOU CURRENTLY RECEIVE
THE INFANT SUPPLEMENT THREE
MONTHS PRIOR TO CHILDBIRTH. IN
OUR EXPERIENCE THE SMALL
INVESTMENT HAS MADE A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY OF OUR CLIENTS TO
PREPARE FOR THE UPCOMING BIRTH
OF THEIR CHILDREN. WITHOUT IT
THEY ARE LEFT SCRAMBLING FOR
RESOURCES OTHER VERY DIFFICULT
AND STRESSFUL. TIME IN THEIR
LIFE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
NOT CALLER PLEASE. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN KEEP
WHERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES AND I HAVE
FIVE ITEMS- TO ADDRESS THE
FIRST ITEM NUMBER TWO ON LONG
TERM CARE CAREER PATHWAYS WERE
VERY EXCITED THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN HIS NAY REVISED FOR-
ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND
EDUCATION FOR HSS PROVIDERS AND
POTENTIALLY OTHER LONG TERM
CARE- PERSONAL CARE ASSISTANT-
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS- AN
ITEM THAT IS STILL UNDER
CONSTRUCTION AND WILL INVOLVE
SOME DIALOGUE BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND
STAKEHOLDERS. AND WOULD
THEREFORE DAM PROJECT THERE BE
SOME KIND OF REPORTING LANGUAGE
FOR- THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE
BEING WORKING REPORTING BACK
SAID THAT BUDGET COMMITTEES ON
OF THE SPECIFICS ABOUT WHAT
THEY WOULD BE PUTTING TOGETHER-
THE SECOND ITEM IS OUR AGENDA
NUMBER FOUR ON DECK COUNTY
STATE SHARING RATIOS WHAT WE
CALL THAT A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING FISCAL ¡UCTURE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS RAMOS AND RAMOS
COMPETING ARE CHAMPIONS ON THAT
THEN THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
INCLUDED THE CONTINUATION OF
THE COUNTY STATE SIXTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE- SHARING RATIOS-
ON. AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT DEALING WITH THE IHS US
7% REDUCTION REALLY APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER BEING
OUR CHAMPION ON THE- ITEM AND
NOTE THAT IN YOUR AGENDA BUT IT
JUST SAYS TO BE ELIMINATING THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE AND
PROVISIONS FOR- BUDGET ITEM
FIVE ONE EIGHT OH DASH ONE ONE
ONE DASH OH OH ONE- UNLIKE MANY
OF THE OTHER- PROGRAMS THAT
WERE PART OF THE SUSPENSION
REDUCTION THE I. THAT'S
REDUCTION IS EMBEDDED IN STATE
STATUTE IN THE WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE THEREFORE
IT'S CRITICAL. THAT IN ADDITION
TO- ELIMINATING THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE. THAT YOU ALSO REPEAL
VOTES TO THAT'S YOU. AND-
ASSEMBLY FRAZIER TOPIC HAS
SUBMITTED LEDGE CAL- MY- AND
IT'S THIRTY BY TO THE- BY STAFF
INTO THE ADMIN. WELL NEXT ON
THAT ELECTRON VISIT. AGENDA I
NUMBER. FORTY THAT ADMIN. OF
PROPOSING TRADE BILL. THAT
WOULD WILL THE PROHIBITION. ON
GPS TRACKING- THAT SOMETHING
THAT THE CONSUMERS AND THE
PROVIDER HAS JUST BEEN
CONSISTENTLY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT- SO WILD THAT DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES INDICATING.
THAT BY GOOD MINISTRATION AS
SAYING THAT THEY WILL- CONTINUE
TO IMPOSE THE PENALTY THE
BUDGET- PROPOSES TO PAY FOR
THAT PENALTY AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT BY MID MINISTRATION
IS STILL SIGNALING A
WILLINGNESS TO TALK THE STATE
AND THE STAKEHOLDERS AND THAT
IT WOULD BE PREMATURE. WELL
THAT PROHIBITION. GPS AND THEN
NOT ON AGENDA IS THE PROPOSED-
DEALING WITH AMBER BACKUPS.
WORKS ABOUT THAT- AND LOOK TO
WORKING YOU MINUTES ON- A
MERCHANT HE GOT THERE BECAUSE-
DOWN THANK YOU KINDLY. THANK
MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. LINE FIFTY
FIVE. HI THERE CUTIE MARK I AM
THE PRESIDENT OF DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED AND I AM ALSO
APPEARANCE OF THE TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN WITH AMAZING
WITH AUTISM- I WANTED I THINK-
I DID IT GOOD GOVERNOR THE
MINISTRATIONS FOR INVESTING IN
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
IN THE BUDGET BECAUSE IT AND
NOW IT'S UP ITEM FIFTY TWO.
EIGHT IT IS SO CRITICAL THAT
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES HAVE CHOICE AND
CONTROL OVER THEIR LIVES AND
THIS PROGRAM PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TWENTY THIRTEEN HAS
BEEN HAVING A LOT OF PROBLEMS
GETTING IMPLEMENTED AND WHILE
WE ARE REALLY HAPPY WITH
INVESTMENT WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR HOW THE BALLOT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GET SPENT PARTICULARLY
THE INVESTMENTS IN THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE. AND HELPING PEOPLE TO
GO AND- SIGN. I JUST WANT TO
TALK SOCIAL RECREATIONAL
THERAPY. I MAKING SURE THAT WE
GET FUND IN FOR THE SOCIAL
PROGRAM. THEY ARE SO AND SHE
THAT THAT. PEOPLE WHO OBTAIN.
JUSTIN INEQUITY IN OUR SYSTEMS
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THESE KIND
OF PROGRAMS LIKE. YOU KNOW.
LIKE GYMNASTICS AND MUSIC AND
ART AND THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
TEACH ME NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD
OUT OF THEIR OWN POCKET CHAU
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND ENACT
ICON. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MY CLIENT. SIXTY
THIRTY WITH THAT DAY IN
CALIFORNIA- ONE OF THE COMING
ON A FEW TEMS TODAY FIRST I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YEARS ACCORDING A
DEDICATION TO SUPPORTING OUR
AGENTS THAT PROVIDERS IN
PARTICULAR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
EXAMINATION OF THE SEVEN
PERCENT- CORRECTIVE SERVICE I
WAS THAT AGE OF THAT- FOR ISSUE
NUMBER TWO RELATED TO THE LONG
TERM CARE PATHWAYS WE SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL AND LOOK FORWARD
TO FLUSHING OUT THE DETAILS
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE ISSUE
FOR RELATED TO AGES OF
PARDONING WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO BUT WE KNOW THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A CHANGE
SHOULD ENSURE. BILL LANGUAGE TO
ADDRESS COUNTY OF THAT TEMPLATE
AND OUTPUT RETOOL- ISSUE SIX
RELATED TO HOLD WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF TECHNICAL ISSUE
SEVEN RELATED AGE OF INCLUDING
WE ARE FOR OF THE FOR THAT
STRENGTH OUT THE FROM OF G. P.
WITH OTHER PRIMER AND CONDUCT
THAT THEY CALL PROCESS I DO.
LEASES WITH WELL JUST THE
FLAMES- IMPACT NOW REALLY TO D.
S. I WOULD ARE IN THE FOR OF
ISSUE FIFTY THREE SIX FOUR AND
WHAT THE POETRY FIFTEEN ELEVEN
OF THE SUPPLEMENT PROVIDER
INCREASE AND YOU FOR SUPPORT ON
THIS ISSUE I TO A SIXTY THREE
WE WILL TO BRING. SERVICE
COORDINATOR SHORT- BY PHILIPPE
THE CORNER SHIP SHORT UNTIL
INCLUDE OF THE- IN PRO- I THINK
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND WILL
ALSO BE PER A WRITTEN PROMISE
TO THE COMMITTEE THANK SO MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER.
PLEASE BY FIFTY THREE. HI THIS
IS JEFF GARRETT STACK
CALIFORNIA'S STATUS AS OF
COUNTIES I WANNA THEY'VE BEEN
FOR A OF THAT THAT IMPROVE THE
LIVES FAMILIES CALIFORNIA I AM
WE ARE SINCE GREAT FOR THE OF I
NUMBER. WHICH IS THE PART IS
EXACTLY PARTNERING ARE
SPONSORING TO PROVIDE
CONTINUITY FIGHTS THAT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING FUNDING
MECHANISMS I ALSO WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND BEING CHAMPIONS
ON THIS PROPOSAL- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING ON THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
THAT IT MEETS THE FULL INTENT
OF THE PROPOSAL. I'LL A COUPLE
OTHER AREAS WERE APPRECIATIVE
OPPOSE INVESTMENTS FOR COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND PREVENTION SERVICES
FOR CHILD WELFARE THE FOUR TO
LEARNING MORE DETAILS ABOUT
THESE PROPOSALS AND
COLLABORATING ON THE CONTINUING
NEED. THE NEWS PROGRAM AREAS
THANK YOU. THANK SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHY. SIXTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAMBERS
MARTHA GUERRERO REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS REALLY APPRECIATE
THE- ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT IS
IN THE MAY REVISION JUST WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT AND ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL TO QUIT CRISTINA
EIGHTY MILLION THAT- DEFINITELY
PROVIDES THE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
TO FAMILIES AS- THEY'RE WAITING
APPROVAL- IN IN THE FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM AND ALSO- WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS AND FEEDBACK
ON THE CHILD WELFARE PROPOSALS
WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE. SIXTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS AMY WESTLING I AM
CALLING FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES WANT
TO FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND YOUR STAFF FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE HEARING
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT WERE
ONLY A COUPLE DAYS OUT FROM THE
RELEASE OF MAY REVISE AND WE
KNOW THAT THIS WORKS DOESN'T
COME EASY SECOND WE DO WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
MANY OF THE PROPOSALS INCLUDED
IN- IT'S MAY REVISED PROPOSAL-
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO- TAKING
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADVANCE THE
SYSTEM FOR THROUGH THE
ELIMINATION OF FUNDING FUNDS
AS- THE STRENGTHENING OF THEIR
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
WORKFORCE- INVESTMENTS IN-
EMPLOYMENT AS WELL AS THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. AND ITS
FOCUS ON PRIORITY POPULATIONS
WE PARTICULARLY WANT TO CALL
OUT OUR SUPPORT FOR THE FOR
PROPOSED PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM OR
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND- BUT IF
YOU WANT TO NOTE THAT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED THROUGHOUT
THIS HEARING FOR ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT FIRST FOR
COMPREHENSIVE RATE REFORM- AND
REALLY BEGINNING TO LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR- FOR BUILDING
RACE THAT WORK ON AN ONGOING
BASIS SECOND- AS- MISS WHITTEN
FROM S. YEAH YOU'D HAVE TO BUY
JUST A MOMENT AGO- THAT WE
SUPPORT- AND INVESTMENT IN
SERVICE COORDINATION THIS YEAR
TO BRIDGE THAT SHORTFALL- AND
TO PAY FOR THE WELL DOCUMENTED
IT- SHORTFALL IN REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICE COORDINATORS
UNTIL THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THEIR. PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. AND THIRD- WE READ.
THE ROOM OF A SERVER BARRIERS
WE'VE SEEN- GREAT FLEXIBILITY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND HOPE
THAT WE CAN MAKE PERMANENT SOME
OF THE CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN-
MADE IT THROUGH PDF DIRECTIVE
DURING THIS TIME FINALLY WE-
STRONGLY SUPPORT AND HAVE LONG
SUPPORTED THE- REINSTATEMENT OF
SOCIAL RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WHICH PROVIDE
A CRITICAL FORUM FOR PEOPLE TO.
TESTING AND DEVELOPING AND-
PRACTICE THEIR- SOCIALIZATION
SKILLS WHICH ENHANCE THEIR
ABILITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL ENOUGH
FOR WIDE VARIETY OF AREAS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY- LIKE
TO PROVIDE THESE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE. NINE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY SEVEN OF RENDON
I'M NOT I'M A NINE NUMBER NINE
WELL I HAVE A SEVERAL COMMENTS
WONDERS ON THE ITEM NUMBER TEN
REGARDING THE- HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE TO A HOMELESS
SUPPORT PROGRAM AND DR WOODS
WAS TALKED ABOUT DATA I'VE BEEN
TRYING FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS
TO FIND OUT HOW MANY FAMILIES
ON CAL WORKS OFF HOMELESS.
MENDOZA NUMBER OF SOURCES OF
DATA BUT WE'VE NEVER SEEN IT TO
THIS TO THIS STATE. THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO FUND THE
HOMELESS SUPPORT PROGRAM. BY
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS. THE BILL START
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS THE
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE LIMITED TO
HOMELESSNESS SYSTEMS ONCE A
YEAR. AND THAT'S THE ONLY A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
AND WE HAD A SUGGESTION TO DO
AWAY WITH POINT TO YOUR
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE THE FAMILY
GETS HOMELESS ASSISTANCE OF
FEBRUARY AND THEN IN MAY THE
LANDLORD EVICTS THEM TO GET
THEIR NEPHEW AND THEIR- TICKET
THEY HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL NEXT
FEBRUARY. BEFORE THEY CAN GET
OFF THE STREETS THAT'S INSANE
AND THE HOMELESS SUPPORT
PROGRAM IF IT WAS ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD BE MUCH
BETTER BECAUSE I FELT THE WAY
IT IS THAT'S UP TO THE COUNTY.
SURCHARGES THAT LIMITS HOW MUCH
DECISION SUPPORT SYSTEM THE
PROGRAM TO GAIN PARTICIPANTS IN
LA END UP 15% PUBLICATION
ORDERS PARTICIPATING GAIN PRESS
OF ONE NOT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE WHICH
IS- COUNTY EXPENSE REPORT YEAH
WHAT IS KNOWN AS A FEW CLICKS
REPORT. WE BET WOULD BE- WE
WENT TO A LITTLE PRESENTATION
OF GIFTS IT WILL BE FOUND OUT
THAT THAT THIS REPORT DOES SHOW
HOW MANY WORKERS ELIGIBLE IS
WORKERS AND HOW MANY
SUPERVISORS HOW MANY WELL FOR
FARMWORKERS EACH COUNTY HAS.
BEEN DEAD VERY IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO FIND OUT WHY IS
SUB COUNTIES THE APPLICATIONS
ARE TAKING LONGER AND OFTEN
SOME COUNTRIES SAY WELL YOU
KNOW WE WILL HAVE A LOOK
WORKERS AND IF WE DON'T HAVE
THE DATA WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY. WORKERS EACH COUNTY HAS
AND WHY IS IT THAT OVER HERE
ASSEMBLY BECAUSE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA OPERATES WITH A
SINGLE AVOCATION SYSTEM TOOK UP
TO THE COUNTY AFTER. HOW THEY
SPEND THE MONEY. FINALLY ON- I
NUMBER EIGHT. WHICH IS COPS BUT-
BELIEVE AYE AYES- I THINK THAT
SHOULD BILL NINE SAYS. THAT-
THAT PARTICIPATION SHOULD BE TO
CDSS COUNTY AND SHE'S A D.
ERICA THAT THE WAY THE FOOD
SAID TOP FIRST. OF THOSE WHO
WERE WILL BE USE OF US TO THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO PARTY IN THE
PLEDGES AND ALSO ONE OF FIND
ASSOCIATE WITH BUT MIGHT
OURSELVES WITH ALL OF THE
COMMENTS THAT MICHAEL HELPFUL
BOTH WESTERN CENTER MADE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION. THANK
YOU BYE. THANK YOU FOR OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY.
GOOD MORNING CARILLO AND
MEMBERS STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF CENTRAL COAST ENERGY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY FIVE AND
SEVENTY SIX ALLOCATION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR UTILITY AND
WATER SYSTEMS AND UTILITY
PAYMENT EVERY REGION'S IT'S
CRITAL TO ADUATELY FUND
THESE PROGRAMS FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIE WHO DESPERATELY
NEED ASSISTANCE TO KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON AND TO HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. C. C. E. S. LOOKS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES- ARE MEANT
TO IMPLEMENT THE- AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY
FOUR. THE PHARMACY CARE NUMBERS
CUSTOMER SPONSORS POLICY
ADVOCATE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY ECHOING THE
COMMENTS THEY MADE MISTER CARE
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO HELP FOOD
REGARDLESS OF THEIR STATUS AND
THAT ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCENTS- WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE HUNGRY NOW
THAT'S WHY WE'RE FULL SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SUBJECT OF
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY FOOD ASSISTANCE THAT
WOULD BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ON ITEMS ARE TWENTY TWO IN
GENERAL WERE SUPPORTER OF
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME CONCEPTS
OF POLICIES OR INTERESTED IN
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ARE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BY THE
PROGRAM I WANT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAM
WOULD NOT REDUCE BENEFIT LEVELS
FOR RESTRICTED FOR PUBLIC
BENEFIT PROGRAMS AND LASTLY ON
ITEM THIRTY FOUR A FULL SUPPORT
OF DR NORTHEAST THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU. SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY. HI
DAN AND LET THEM KNOW WHAT
CHILDREN NOW WE WERE THANK
RECEIVE ELIMINATE OF CHILD
SERVE THIS I NUMBER THIRTY NINE
THEY'RE ALSO PLEASED TO SEE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
INCLUDED COMPILING PREVENTION
SERVICES BUT WAITED TO AFFECT
PFA ITEM NINETEEN- WE ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE PPL ON
THE PROPOSAL HOWEVER WE DO
THINK THAT THE FUNDING INCLUDED
IT AND PROFICIENT I'M MORE
HOPEFUL WILL BE INCREASED AS
THE PROCESS CONTINUES. FINALLY
WE STRONGLY ECHO THE L. A. O.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
PANDEMIC ASSISTANCE FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE WHO ARE LIVING WITH
RELATIVES RESEARCH FAMILIES AND
GUARDIANS IT'S TRULY BAFFLING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES IN THE NINETIES
FAMILY PANDEMIC WE STARTED TO
SUPPORT THE CHILDREN IN THEIR
CARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BLIND SEVENTY. MORNING RAIN
FORTE FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS EXPECTING
SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND PUBLICL
CHURCH PROPERTY. THE BILL TO
EXTEND THE- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHINE. EIGHTY FIVE. AN EIGHTY
FIVE PER LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH THAT
REALLY YOU ON BEHALF OF NEEDED
OF THE ACT YOU LOOK VERY NICE
THIRTY WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THE
CHANGES PROPOSED ITEM OR IN
THIRTY EIGHT IN ISSUE FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY THREE SHARED BY THE
CHAMPION ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANT
I'M IN THE MARAMA SOMEONE OVER
FRAZIER AND COMPANY WORK ON THE
PERMANENT RESTORATION THE THUMB
PERCENT CUT. OVER THE YEARS FOR
ISSUE TO YOU ON THAT HOME
CAREER PATHWAY ALIGNER CLEMENT
WITH L. A. L. MANY I THINK YOUR
FAMILY MEMBER AND ANECDOTALLY
BURKE THE PROGRAMS TAKE CARE OF
THEIR LOVED ONES AND ARE NOT.
LOOKING TO MOVE INTO ANOTHER
CAREER- SHOPPING FUNDING AND
THAT YOU CAN FIND TRAINING
PROJECT ALL PRIMARY CARE
CONCRETE QUALITY OF CARE AND
IDEALLY A CORE RUNNING WE
INCREASE. ON ISSUE FORTY SEVEN
WE OPPOSE THE TRACKING THE GPS
POSITION TO ENSURE EVEN BE
WOULD NOT BE OVERLY BURDENSOME
INTRUSIVE THE REFLECT THE EDP
PROVOKING ORIGINALLY PASSED. ON
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA WOODBRIDGE
YEAH I CAN STEP RESIDUAL OTHER
TERMINATION AND- CABLE BURKE
ALL OF THE CHANGE AND FINALLY
UP IMPORTANT WE ARE STOCK
OPTION OF THE COMPETENT THE
GOAL COUNTY PROPOSAL ON COUNTY
FAIRFIELD DEPARTING A FATE. IT
MARCOS WIL HELP THOUSANDS OF
PROVIDERS ARE PREDOMINANTLY ONE
OF COLOR CLICK ON MANY YEARS
WITHOUT BARGAINING CONTRACT.
REACH AN AGREEMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALLER. WHY AN EIGHTY SIX.
THE MORNING CARE ARAMBULA
NUMBERS THE IS JERRY CALL WITH
NEAREST CAL MY COMMENTS ARE IN
REGARD TO YOU OPERATE TO ACCESS
TO CALFRESH WERE OLDER AND ALSO
BUSINESS CENTER AND CAL LACK DR.
FIRST IN REGARD WE GREATLY THE-
IN ITEMS ONE THE FUND OUT OF
REACH I. WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
FOCUS ON CONNECTING MORE LOW
OLDER ADULTS BUT CALPERS. BUT
IT FURTHERS THE THOSE OUT
REGION THAT BY. A SIMPLIFY
CALFRESH APPLICATIONS GROUP
WILDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AS WELL AS
RECOMMENDED IN THE MASTER PLAN
FOR A KING. SECOND IN REGARDS A
GOOD ACTORS FOR IMMIGRANTS
YOU'RE WELL AWARE CARE ABOUT
THE LINE AS HE SPOKE SO
ELOQUENTLY. WE NEED TO BRING
EQUITY TO OUR STATE NUTRITION
SAFETY NET BY AND AT THE LONG
TERM SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THE
PUNCH OUT IMMIGRANT EXCLUSION
AND OUR FOOD ASSISTANCE THAT.
IT SHOULD INVEST IN MY- THE-
THROUGH THE- PROGRAMS A
PERMANENT PROVIDE NUTRITION
BENEFITS ALL CALIFORNIANS IN
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH. SOLELY
DUE TO THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
WE NEED TO ENSURE FOOD FOR ALL
THANK. THANK YOU SIR THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. LINE. EIGHTY
SEVEN. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- THE
SCARY JERKING OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
I'LL BE COMMENTING ON THAT YES
I DID FROM THE BUDGET I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE STAFF'S
PRESENTATION OF THE ITEMS ALSO
APPRECIATED MINISTRATIONS-
PROPOSAL ON A NUMBER OF SILENCE
INTO ME REVISED RIDICULOUSLY
THE PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE YOUR
OUR HOLIDAY SCHEDULE THE
SUSPENSION DATES FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASES
CERTAINLY GIVE US A PLATFORM
AND SOME STABILITY AS WE LOOK
FORWARD- ARE ALSO IN REGARDS
ADDED SIXTY DECILLION FONG A
GRANT WE'RE ALWAYS SUPPORTIVE
OF MORE INVESTMENT IN TRYING TO
ACHIEVE. EMPLOYMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT ALSO- MORE
INFORMATION ON THE REVISIONS
THAT PAID INTERNSHIP PROGRAM IN
COMPETITIVE BURDEN ON
INCENTIVES AND APPRECIATED- THE
STATIC FROM THE ELIAS'S
COMMENTS ON SPECIFIC TO THE
EXTERNSHIP PROGRAM IN
RECOGNITION THAT IT HAS LOST
THE OPPORTUNITY VALUE AS STATE
MINIMUM WAGE IS GOING UP SO
HOPEFULLY. WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
WITH A PROPOSAL SUPPORTED BY
FAMILY RESEARCH YOU AMENDED
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM TO BUILD TO
RENT AT AN HOUR'S CAPITAL
STRUCTURE EACH CHAPTER- MORE
QUICK CHANGE ITEMS FIFTY FIFTY
FOUR OF FIFTY EIGHT- MINUTE
CRISTINA FOCUS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE
PROFESSIONALIZATION OF THE
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
WORKFORCE- AND ALSO RECOGNIZE
YOU'RE STILL AND PAYING OF
COURSE- COME THAT STILL
DEVELOPMENT WITH A VITAL
DIFFERENTIAL- ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN'S HER QUEST FOR MORE
EQUITABLE RATE INCREASES A
STATE MINIMUM WAGE GOES UP SO
WE GET MORE MONEY IN THE
POCKETS OF OUR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS- THESE PROPOSALS
ARE ARE A GREAT START BUT OF
COURSE YOU REQUIRE INVESTMENT.
IN IT IT REALLY CHANGED MY
CLOTHES WHICH IS- IN SUPPORT
AND APPRECIATION OF THAT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
COMMENT TODAY ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE GAP THAT YOU STILL
EXPERIENCE YOU SYSTEM- WE ARE
STILL- WE ARE NOT YET
IMPLEMENTING THE RATE. ONE
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU- THE
MISTER CHAIR- MARTI AMADO
FAMILY MEMBER OF ASISTER WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
ALSO EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBER AN
UNPAID CAREGIVER TO AN ADULT
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WHO IS LIVING WITH ME NOW-
MEMBER THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE AND- ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING SUBCOMMITTEE- I JUST
CLICKED ON ONE OF THINK- THE
COMMITTEES STAFF FOR THE WORK
THEY HAVE DONE- OVER THIS PAST
YEAR AND FOR THIS HEARING AND
JUST WANT TO COMMENT THAT THE-
IT MAY REVISE AND THE
PRIORITIES SET BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO. IS A STARK NOT
JUST IN THE SIZE BUTTON IN THE
DIRECTION BUT THE ECHO THE
WORDS OF THE SOME WOMEN WOULD
IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THE
OUTCOMES THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
AND ALSO IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE
STATE- TOWARD THAT JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT I ECHO THE CONCERNS
AND IN THE WORDS ARE EXPRESSED
BY KAREN KIESLER ON I. HSS. AND
DO AGREED THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE A CHANGE IN THE STATUTE
REGARDING THE 7% ALSO STRONGLY
AGREE WITH- WITH- HER POSITION
THAT SHE RAISED ON THE ISSUE OF
DVD AND THAT TO ME TO BE A
LONGER DISCUSSION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE ISSUE OF
GLOW- GPS- WANTED TO A SHOUT
OUT TO DDS ON THE PROPOSAL FOR
PROVISIONAL ELIGIBILITY FOR
AGES- THREE TO FIVE- AND- BUT
WANT TO- UNDERSCORED THAT HOW
THAT'S IMPLEMENTED IS REALLY
CRITICAL TO MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO A
WIDE ARRAY OF NEEDED SERVICES-
WANT TO ALSO SUPPORT. THE
DIRECT SUPPORT TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM THE
BILINGUAL LANGUAGE-
DIFFERENTIAL- AND THEIR-
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE. OF REMOVAL
THE SONS- AND ALSO WANT TO
AMPLE THE THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT. CENTERED GREAT REFORM AND
LASTLY THE U. S. P. AND CAPTAIN.
THE ASSISTANCE- PRO. FOR-
ADJUSTMENT THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THAT BUT ALSO URGED
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE MOVE TOWARDS- AN
ANNUAL COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS. TO LOWER. INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE THIS HEARING AND ALL
THAT- YOU ARE DOING FOR US
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS
MAKING A CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I'M ENERGY VERY PLEASED
TO SEE THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROPOSED FUNDING TO
BE REVISED OR CST LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM OVER THE
YEARS WELCOME THE ONLY PROGRAM
OF ITS KIND OF CALIFORNIA THAT
FOCUSES EXCLUSIVELY ON SERVING
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITH
SOLAR AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES. THAT REDUCE EMISSIONS
STATE ENERGY AND IMPORTANTLY
SAVE PEOPLE MONEY ON THEIR
UTILITY BILLS IT'S A FIVE A
WAIT LIST FOR THIS PROGRAM AND
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL
TRACK RECORD OF THE TRONG
ENCOURAGE THE FAMILY TO INCLUDE
AN AUGMENT FUNDING FOR LIGHT
WITHOUT YOUR BUDGET DISCUSSION
THE BOARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER. PLEASE LINE.
EIGHTY GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
MARK MELANCHTHON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK HE
KAELIN OF THE STATEWIDE
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WITH
OVER ONE HUNDRED AGENCY
PROVIDER MEMBERS LARGE AND
SMALL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
SUPPORTED LIVING INDEPENDENT
LIVING EMPLOYMENT PARKING LOT
THAT THEY CAN WRAP THE
THERAPIST OF. THE FEELING OF
EXTREMELY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ELIMINATION OF THE ATHLETES
PENSION LANGUAGE FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE INCREASES AND
ELIMINATION OF THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE OF STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO STABILIZE
THE COMMUNITIES CAN BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THE UNDER FUNDED RATE
IN PLACE THE LAND ON THE
ALREADY LOW WAGES OF OUR DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL ALSO VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ABOUT YOU
CAN TALK TO TERMINATION HM THAT
AND THE OPPONENT. ALTHOUGH THE
FEDERAL. H. W. COMPLY NOTHING
WE DON'T CAL. NEED TO DO THING
WE CAN CONTINUE TO LEAD THE NAY
IN AREA. RESHAPED EFFORTS TO
PROFESSIONAL I THE DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL WORK FOR
WITH THE- ON. THE GREAT SHOWED
THAT THERE PATH AND PEOPLE
PROFESSIONAL COULD KEEP EVER
EQUIPMENT NUMBER TEN EFFORTS. I
HOPE SO THAT YOU GATHER WE
ALIGN THE FUTURE. ON DRUG
DEPARTMENT TO WITH THE
CURRICULA THAT WILL. OR SUPPORT.
THAT SUPPORT PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
AND- DISABILITY AND THE- AND
MEASURING OUTCOMES THAT LEAD TO
CHOKING THE LIFE. WE ALL KNOW
THAT TRAINING ALONE NOT AN
OUTCOME AND THAT TRAINING MUST
RESULT IN IMPROVED QUALITY OF
SERVICE. AND THAT LEADS TO
INCREASE WAGES FOR DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS. BUDGET
THAN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW AND
PUNK INCREASING DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL WAGES. CAN'T MAKE
FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD THAT MAKE
ANY INCREASES TO DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL WAGES. HAVE SPUR
BILINGUAL PROFICIENCY IN
TRAINING WHERE CURRICULA
NONPROFIT THERE. HAVE NOT YET
BEEN DEVELOPED. PEOPLE TO GET
THE DELAY ANY READ. OF THE WORK
CREDIT HELP KEEP HOW IN PLAY IN
A PANDEMIC WITHIN IN HERE IN
ALREADY LOW WAGE. YEAH I'M NOT
SUPPOSED TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMIN. TO DEPART. AND ALLEGE ON
HOW. GREAT OUR JEFF AND HAD AND
GET PEOPLE TO CREATURE AREA ARE
INTENSELY. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHY NOT. NINETY HELLO MY NAME
IS JACKIE REPRISE THEIR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICE DESK
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT MANY
HISTORIC- FUNDING ISSUES THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED WE
LOVE MOST OF THEM AND YET THERE
ARE SOME THAT WERE JUST LAST
COUNT. S. CLERGY KEYS ARE
INTEGRAL PART OF THE C. JACQUI
TEAM AND PROVIDING A CRITICAL
THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTION FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. NEEDING A HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE THAT ADDRESSES
BOTH THE TRAUMA AND MENTAL AND
BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS WITH THE
GOAL OF STABILIZING AND
ENABLING THEM TO TRANSITION TO
HOME BASE CAMP PERMANENTLY. IN
PARTICULAR AND AT THIRTY P. OF
THE TEN TO MAKE THE INSTEAD AND
UNCERTAINTY THAT THE COVER
NINETEEN CRISIS IS CREATED.
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN LOST REVENUES AND
COSTS THAT ARE PUTTING YOUR
OPERATIONS AT WEST. AND WITHOUT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT MANY AFTER DE
BEERS WILL BE FORCED TO CLOSE
OR SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED
CAPACITY. WE'D LIKE TO
SPECIFICALLY THANK ANGELES
SHORT FROM THE ALLEY- FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED FOR
FUNDING FOR BOTH AFTER TO BE AN
RESOURCE FAMILIES. AND WHO
SERVE FOSTER DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND ESPECIALLY THE
VICTIM BLAMING. IN ADDITION
THANK YOU FOR REMOVING THE
SUSPENSION LANGUAGE CONCOCTED
FAMILY AGENCIES PUBLIC HEALTH
MASTERS AND SEARCH. AND WE ASK
FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS TO REDUCE THE
HIGH TURNOVER WHICH IS HURTING
THE CHANCES OF PERMANENCY AND
SIX ASK AS MANY AUSTRIANS KEEP
LOSING FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
SOCIAL. WORKER FINALLY MADE
LIKE TO SEE IF THIS AND IN
PREVENTION. UNDER AT THE AT THE-
NONPROFIT. ARE PROVIDE MANY OF
THE MOST PART LIKE RESOURCE
FAMILIES CENTERS. THAT SUPPORT
FAMILIES AND REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVEMENT AND I SHOULD SAY.
THIS IS THE FINAL ONE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO RESEARCH PARENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN SO CRUCIAL TO THE
SAFETY NET. AS THEY CARE FOR
OUR CHILDREN DURING THE CALL
THE PANDEMIC AND WE REALLY
BELIEVE THEY WERE. LEFT OUT OF
THE BACK BUT THEY STILL. NOT TO
BE LEFT OUT OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WHY NINETY THREE STE YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN LARA AND THAT
REPRESENTING IT HERE AND THAT I
WANTED TO ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
AND BACK AT WHAT JACQUI THERE'S
OR AFTER KEEPS N. AFTER EIGHT.
OR JUST ADDED WITH THE OF I
THIRTY AND A QUARTER AND THAT
WE ARE NOT ANY THE CLIP A FACT
YOUNG AT THE TRANSIT OUT OF THE
NON MANNER DEPENDING PROGRAM
AND THEN WE DON'T ANY PEOPLE
HOMELESS. AND I GUESS WHEN I
PUT SPORTS. NOW AND JUST ADD TO
THAT AGREE. THEIR OF THE FUNDS.
ON THE EMERGING CHAO CARE
BRIDGE PROPOSED. AND WE- THE
LETTER. TO AND STAND BY.
PROPOSAL TO AND THREE. FOR THE
PRO. THAT WE CAN AND THAT. WE
ARE PROVIDING MORE ACCESS TO
CARE TO YOUNG PEOPLE AND NOT
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM BECAUSE THEY
CAN BE IN THEIR FIRST FIVE
PLACEMENT. WE ARE MAXIMIZING
THE TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING IN
THAT PROGRAM TO BENEFIT. ALL
THE DIFFERENT CHILDREN AND HERE
MAYBE IN CHILD CARE CUTTING THE
CROP STATE AND HAVE ADDITIONAL
NAVIGATOR SUPPORT THEM TO BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
FIND LONG TERM PLANS. FOR CHILD
CARE AS WE KNOW WE ARE MAKING
AND BUCKNER IN THAT CHILD CARE
SYSTEM AS WELL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT. CALLER PLEASE.
LINE NINETY FIVE. HI THANK YOU
SO- MISTER CHAIR PER AND THEN
OF THE MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
CANTERO AND I'M A PARENT- OF
THE TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD SON
WHO'S A REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMER AND A MEMBER OF THE H.
E. B. WAIVER PROGRAM- I MAY
ALSO DISABILITY INCLUSION
ADVOCATE AMAZON JOHNNY IS
COMPLEX MEDICAL HEALTH CARE
NEEDS. COMBINED WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND I WANT TO
TOUCH BRIEFLY- I'M JUST TWO
THINGS- ONE IS WHAT MARCO-
MAGIC IT HAD TALKED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THE SILO SYSTEMS IT IS
CRITICAL- THAT WE FIGURE OUT-
THE HOW TO SUPPORT CONSUMERS
AND FAMILIES ACROSS SECTORS-
HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH ALL
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW DID
DEPARTMENTS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT- TO COORDINATE AND
PEOPLE GET BURNED OUT VERY
EASILY. AND GIVE UP AND
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T GET THE
SERVICES THEY NEED BECAUSE OF
THE BARRIERS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE SO WHOLE WHOLE MODEL
APPROACHABLE PERSON MODEL
APPROACH I'M LOOKING AT A
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY PERSON
CENTERED PLAN FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL RECEIVING ANY SORT
OF SERVICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL- EACH EACH TO PASS A
SERVICE. I'M SORRY EACH
DEPARTMENT HAS A DIFFERENT
PERSON CENTERED PLANS BUT
THEY'RE NOT COMPREHENSIVE AND
OVERLAPPING ACROSS DEPARTMENTS
ON THE OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO
TOUCH ON IS- THINK GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND HIS MINISTRATION FOR
THE SUPPORT AND SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM THIS IS A
CRITICAL A PROGRAM THAT WILL
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES TO ACCESS
MEANINGFUL ENGAGING ACTIVITIES
IN THEIR LIVES I WOULD- ALSO
SUPPORT THE SOCIAL RECREATIONAL
PROGRAMS- IS THIS ISN'T HELPS
NOT JUST THEIR PHYSICAL WELL
BEING BUT THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
WHICH HAS BEEN GREATLY IMPACTED
IN THIS PAST YEAR ON THE SET-
IT WITH THE PANDEMIC. AND
LASTLY JUST PLEASE HAVE.
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY IN
PAYER. AND WITH OVERSIGHT IN
STAKEHOLDER. TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING GETS TO WHERE IT IS
INTENDED TO BE AND SUPPORT THE
ISSUES TOO OFTEN I'VE SEEN THAT
THIS IS NOT THE CASE THE
FUNDING DOESN'T GO WHERE IT'S
AN BEEN INTENDED- AND IT NEEDS
TO. WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TAKE CARE. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHY. NINETY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SIMONE
CORRECTLY HAVE HERE WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU I'D
LIKE TO FIRST EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE REMOVAL OF
SUSPENSIONS ARE CRITICAL SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND EXPECT
THE CORPORATE YOU PROPOSED TO
INVESTMENTS MADE BY THE
GOVERNOR FROM THE PREVENTING
AND REDUCING POVERTY
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR HOUSING NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM BOTH ADMINISTERED BY H.
T. T. I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
THAT INVESTMENT ALSO BE MADE TO
GFS BY TWO OTHER ITEMS WITHIN
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PREVENTING AND REDUCING
COSTS YOU COMMONSENSE PROPOSAL.
THOSE ITEMS WOULD BE ADDING
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSIVE WITH THE TRAINING
TOPIC FOR SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PROBATION OFFICERS AND
ESTABLISHING FUNDING FOR
COUNTIES WITH THE HIGHEST
HOUSING COSTS TO SUPPLEMENT THE
FUNDING FOR THE CHEESE PIZZA
PROGRAMS WHICH PROVIDE TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT SERVICES
DEPARTMENT PROPERTY IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHY NIGHT. SEVEN
KAREN NUMBER OF MY NAME IS RITA
MEDINA I'M OF FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHANDLER AND I
WATCH IT ON Q. ITEM THE ONE
THANK YOU CHAIR AND WILL JUST
COMING FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND-
CONTINUE TO UPLIFT IN THE OF
COMMENTS MADE FOR- FOR ALL TO
ENSURE THAT ALL. REGARDLESS OF
STATUS HAVE ACT TO EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE WE CANNOT UNDERSCORE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS ACCESS IS- AND
IT'S CRITICAL TO OUR RECOVERY
AND ALSO FIRST IN OUR FAMILY
COULD DRIVE OUT THE ONE IN THE
PORT BRIEFLY I DON'T NINE WHICH
IS THE UNACCOMPANIED
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS- ITEMS WE
ARE GLAD TO SEE THAT OUR STATE
IS PUTTING MONEY INTO. AREA
ACTIVE SUPPORT AND A COMPANY
CHILDREN HER COME INTO
CALIFORNIA WE HOPE THIS MONEY
CAN BE USED IN COLLABORATION
WITH LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
PARTICULAR WITH- THE LEGAL
SERVICES TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHILDREN ARE GETTING ACCESS TO
DAY CARE AND THEY DON'T THEY'RE
JUST THEY NEED ALSO THAT THE
PARENTS OF THESE CHILDREN ARE
BEING SUPPORTED. ACCELLER
PLEASE. LINE. EIGHTY TWO. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER THIS IS
JORDAN AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
FOR- THE QUESTIONS IN THE
DISCUSSION AND OF COURSE FOR
ALLOWING THAT- PUBLIC COMMENT
TIME. THE LABOR VISION I THINK
WE UP FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECT ABOUT DISABILITIES
THAT SOME HITS AND BIG MAC. FOR
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT OF THE HEAD
WHICH ARE ELIMINATE OF THE-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
OTHER THAN THE LEAD CLEVERLY
MADE A PRIORITY OF THE SEVERAL.
I COULD FOCUS ON INCLUDE AND-
IN THE PARK BUDGET. FOCUS ON
GETTING INDIVIDUAL WITH THIS
BILL COMPLY ESPECIALLY IN THE
QUEUE. ON GETTING THOSE BACK
THAT WE LOST DURING PANDEMIC-
REDUCING IN A CABLE RATIO ALSO
A GOOD THING IN THE MAY READ.
EXPAND AS OF OUR I'M SORRY TO
OUR AGE THREE TO BECAUSE- AND
ESPECIALLY WITH HOW PROPOSED
FOR TWO THROUGH. AFTER SUPPORT.
ANTI NOT TO WAKE INCREASES.
THIS IS A MOVEMENT RIGHT TO
DEATH. BUT I HAD CALM THE ONE
AS PER TO ME READ. THIS WILL
WOULDN'T BEING GOAL WAIT A
DOLLAR TO NEW. FOR ABOUT YEARS
AND THE- NEED FOR. IS NOW- ALSO
THE STATE WE ARE TO LOOK AT THE
PUMP BEHIND THE ON GOING COSTS
AND WORKING. WITH A LOT
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP. OUT
OF CONSENT AND WAY INCREASES
CAN CREATE QUALITY REVIEW
TURNOVER AND I MISS RUBIO HOW
SOME GREAT. ABOUT JUST THE-
THOSE AND KIND OF THAT. DURING
THE TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENTS
LET ME REVISE. THAT OTHER
SERVICES AND OTHER SECTORS. THE
ID THE COMMUNITY FEELS LIKE
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN A LITTLE BIT A
SECOND THOUGHT IN THIS COME
BACK PLAN- AS ONE EXAMPLE OF
JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO ONE OF
OUR CHAPTERS IN AMADOR COUNTY
HAD TO MAKE A VERY DIFFICULT
DECISION. TO CLOSE THEIR
SUPPORTED LIVING SERVICES
PROGRAM. REMOVING THAT CRITICAL
SUPPORT TOO MANY INDIVIDUALS
WITH IBD THE REASON WE HAD TO
CLOSE BECAUSE OF THE CONTINUOUS
LOW RATES ESPECIALLY FOR RURAL
COMMUNITY. MAKE IT MORE
CHALLENGING. AND THE OVERALL
COST THE LOST REVENUE FOR YOUR
INFORMATION YOU MEAN THAT THEY
ALONG ALONG WITH ADDITIONAL
RISKS OF COLON. THEY HAD TO
CLOSE THAT- M. CRITICAL SERVICE.
THIS IS AN EXTRA DECISION
KNOWING FOR WELL HOW MUCH AN
IMPACT. BUT NOT IN THIS MAY
REVISED DELIVERS A COME BACK.
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO JUST
LOST THEIR SUPPORT DUE TO LOW
RATES. NOTHING IN THE COME BACK
PLAN MAKES A DIFFERENCE THERE.
IN FACT NOT A SINGLE DOLLARS
BUDGET GOES TOWARDS SOLVING
THAT FUNDAMENTAL AND UNDERLYING
CHALLENGE WE WOULD FULLY
SUPPORT A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT A GENERATIONAL AND
WHAT BEEN TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENT. TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA ID AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND WE HAVE TALKED TO
PROPOSAL TO DO SO AND WE'RE
EAGER TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION.
TO DO SO IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
WEEKS. I FINALLY I LEARNED OF A
NEW UPDATE ON THE 10% S. MAX
INCREASE BUT WITHIN THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN- THAT-
THAT. THE STATE'S DEADLINE TO
SUBMIT ITS SPENDING PLANS
INSTEAD IS JUNE TWELFTH. I JUST
WENT OUT THIS MORNING TO SO AS
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH TO DO.
I'M WE ARE EAGER TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE ON DEVELOPING A
SPENDING PROPOSAL TO SUBMIT TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BY JUNE
TWELFTH. FOR THAT 10% AFTERMATH
BUMP WHICH WERE I'M THRILLED SO
THRILLED WE RECEIVE HER
INTERNET SERVICES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. LINE.
NINETY EIGHT. YES HELLO THANK
YOU FOR- ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
THIS IS LORRAINE S. PATEL HERE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
INDIAN HEALTH BOARD AND I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNORS MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL- IN DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES- IT'S ITEM
ELEVEN- TO RESTORE INDIAN
HEALTH CLINIC FUNDING THAT WAS
CUT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT- NINE
RESULTING IN THE LOSS OF SOME
CLINICS ABILITY. TO PARTICIPATE
AS WE APPROACH POST PANDEMIC
THERE IS EVEN GREATER NEED TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES FROM THE
EXTREME STRESS OF JOB LOSSES
CLOSE SCHOOLS AND THE LOSS OF
LIFE IN TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND- AND FAMILY
TRAUMA ARE VERY MUCH NEEDED-
ESPECIALLY AT THIS TIME AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I. NINETY NINE. GOOD
MORNING CURE PERSON CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES SIR I THINK IT'S NO
AFTERNOON THOUGH. ARE YOUR-
INTERMENT OF YOUR MY NAME IS
JEFF CHARTED YEAR AN ADVOCATE
AND I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA PROCESS ALL RIGHT. I
IN THE FSR. IT WAS ALREADY IN
THE BUDGET FOR THE COST OF
LIVING- YOU HAVE STILL NOT
DIRECTED ANY EFFORTS TO THE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION SSI
RECIPIENTS. OF GETTING THEM TO
BE ABLE TO SIMPLY TO PAY THEIR
BASIC RENT- I COULD GO ON
LONGER- A MANY OF THE OTHER
ISSUES HAVE BEEN BEFORE YOU. I
APPRECIATE THE EXCELLENT MANNER
OF WHICH YOU LISTEN. BUT PLEASE
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE EFFORT
THAT NEEDS TO BE MADE SO THAT
THREE YEARS FROM NOW WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE IN BETTER SHAPE.
THAN WE HAVE BEEN THE LAST TWO
YEARS. THAT'S MY COMMENTS. WE
SUPPORT ANYTHING RELATES TO A-
SOMETHING HAVE BEEN. FORWARD
THANK. AND THANK TO EUROPE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS INVENTIVENESS
FROM DEALING WITH THE HOMELESS
IN THE OTHER. BUT I AGREE LIKE
THE OTHER THINGS BUT PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU USE ME-
SHOULD WE SAY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THE AUDITING FUNCTION TO
DETERMINE HOW MANY IS BEING
CORRECT RESPECT EACH AND
WITHOUT ID IN MY PUBLIC COMMENT
TO YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHY ONE
I'LL TELL YOU- THAT WAS ONE
THING THAT I RAISED. JERRY AND
MEMBERS- I THINK SHE COLLEGE
I'D- ARE COUNTY BENELUX DONE
REPRESENTING JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU- YOU JUST
NOTICED IN YOUR AGENDA-
SOMETHING THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD
BE LOOKING WHICH IS- SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND- PRENATAL BENEFITS
FOR PREGNANT POTS ARE USING NON
MINOR DEPENDENTS- WE'VE FOUND
OBVIOUSLY THE OUTCOMES ARE
BETTER- FOR THESE DUDES- THAT
WHEN THEY DELIVER AND IT ALSO.
HELPED BUILD SPORTS AROUND
BRING THAT CHILD CONCERT JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THAT SHE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK. YOU
MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHY
ONE THREE. AND AFTER CARE
ARAMBULA MM OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ANNA THOMPSON FROM
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE ITEM JUST
MENTION TO EXTEND THE
INVINCIBLE MAN FOR FOSTER YOUTH
WHO ARE EXPECTANT PARENTS WHICH
WAS NOT INCLUDED IN MAY REVISED
BUT WE SEE AS A CRITICAL
SUPPORT FOR OUR PARENTS ARE
UNABLE TO RECEIVE CAL WORKS OR
OTHER PRENATAL BENEFIT PROGRAMS
DUE TO THEIR FOSTER CARE
STATUS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE GENTLEMAN AT
THIS TIME IF YOU DID WISH TO
SPEAKER MAKE COMMENT AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO
AND YOU'LL BE QUEUED UP TO
SPEAK PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT.
WELL I NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SHELLY
TO MOM AND THE FAMILY MEMBER OF
THE TWENTY NINE YEAR OLD WHO
HAS DOWN SYNDROME AND ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CHANCE
HOUSING ON THE CENTRAL COAST OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M ALSO ON THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE. I JUST WANTED TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND OFFER MY
FULL SUPPORT FOR ALL OFTHE
PROPOSAL IN A REVISED. FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT. AS
BOTH A HOUSING ADVOCATE AND AS
A FAMILY MEMBER ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL OF THE
INITIATIVES PUT FORWARD
INCLUDING. DE DIRECT SUPPORT
WORKER TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION THE BILINGUAL
DIFFERENTIAL. AND THE REGIONAL
CENTER INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. I
LASTLY HOUSING SERVICES HOUSING
ACCESSSERVICES AND HOUSING
NAVIGATION SERVICES ARE TOO
OFTEN LEFT BEHIND WHEN. YOU
KNOW BEING ELIGIBLE FOR CERTAIN
KINDS OF INITIATIVES
DIFFERENTIALS AND SO FORTH SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THE TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT THAT
HOUSING SERVICES NEED TO BE
INCLUDED THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OPERATOR CAN
WE DO ONE FINAL SWEEP TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY FINAL CALLERS. MR
CHAIRMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
IF YOU DO NOT WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT THIS IS THE LAST CALL
FOR THIS MEETING PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE OUT. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WITH THE CONCLUSION OF
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL NOW
ADJOURN THIS MEETING I'D ALSO
LIKE TO EXTEND A SPECIAL THANK
YOU TO LOCAL VASQUEZ FOR ALL
HER WORK ON THIS AGENDA AND-
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. WE ARE
ADJOURNED.